Tja, welche Informationen?
Ja, guten Abend, Holleri du Dödel die.
Dann kauft ihr bitte einen Mac. Aber wir haben Apple am Leben gehalten.
Dann halt.
Ne, bitte nicht.
Ja, ist ja auch so. Und da muss ich ja sagen, wollen wir mal zum Ende kommen? Bis dann, tschüss!
Haben wir noch Themen? Kannst du mich mal lauter machen, also hier, da Kopfhörer, also...
Deinen Kopfhörer möchtest du ein bisschen lauter haben. Das sollte sich machen lassen.
Das hält jetzt erst nach fünf Stunden ein?
War ja auch eine lange Sendung.
Wenn so eine Sendung irgendwie... Also, wenn man so lange gepodcastet hat...
Ich bin auch da erst mal einfach mal durch.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht kriegt man eigentlich auch Lust, irgendwie mal wieder auch...
Wollen wir nochmal anfangen?
Ja, also gerade wenn man so fertig ist, dann ist es eigentlich erst wieder so richtig geil.
Ja, drüber, wenn man so drüber ist.
Heide ist doch so eine Feindbezeichnung von den Christen für alle anderen, die eigentlich auch an was glauben, aber die sind ja auch so im Glaubensbereich, aber ich bin ja eher glaubstagnostisch. Ich bin ja auch nicht... Ich bin ja auch kein... Wie heißt das nochmal, wenn man... Hauptsache Gott glaubt an mich.
Rot ist.
Atheist. Atheist.
Rot ist. Nicht nochmal über die Zukunft von Apple sprechen?
Ja, wollten wir unbedingt.
Ten oder iPhone X, wie wir Gläubige ja jetzt dann sagen.
Nicht X, sondern Ten.
Ich lass mir ein X nicht für eine Zahl vormachen.
Heide.
Proteist.
T ist.
Er wird es bestimmt tun.
Am Ende sind es Glaubensfragen, die über alles entscheiden und die so ein bisschen definieren, was so das Universum mit einem vorhat.
Ich glaub, ich hab ein Déjà-vu.
Warum? Ich kann es echt nicht glauben.
Der Tag hat heute irgendwie schon so komisch angefangen.
Man muss sich erstmal locker machen, das ist ganz wichtig. Und dann muss man so sein Inner Self touchieren.
Ja, besser als tranchieren auf jeden Fall.
Das Glaubensfragen, das war ja in der letzten Sendung auch wirklich so ein Thema, das verbindet einen ja dann auch universell. Raum und Zeit, alles was dazwischen ist. Ja, das dehnt sich dann.
Ja, jetzt wo wir so lange über Segeln gesprochen haben, können wir ja nochmal da frisch einsteigen.
Oder willst du nochmal über das Glauben im Segeln reden?
Achso, aber das kommt ja erst später, oder?
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich glaube, ich werde verrückt.
Sendung ist doch erst halb durch. Das kriegen wir irgendwie noch hin.
Wo wir jetzt gerade in dieser religiösen Dimension angelangt sind, wollten wir noch nicht nochmal über die Zukunft von Freak Show sprechen.
Wollten wir unbedingt ganz dringend. Meinst du?
Ja, besonders der Freak Show.
Aber du redest nur von dir selber.
Ich weiß, bestimmt noch ein paar andere. Also ich hab die Freak Show schon gehört, als sie sich noch mit Macs beschäftigt hat.
Das hat sich irgendwie nie durchgesetzt. Ich wollte das ja auch nicht, bis ich dann wollte. Mir ist auch nie was eingefallen. Furchtbar. Ich geh einfach nachher in die Ecke und Beine.
Nein, Tim, das musst du nicht.
Gibt es eine Zukunft? Ich meine, jetzt irgendwie.
Definier erstmal Zukunft.
Also neue, großartige, richtig nützliche Verbrauchertipps.
Ach ja.
Dann bin ich voll, voll bei denen, aber nicht so.
Ist sowieso irgendwie, aber lassen wir das.
Du meinst, ich hab's völlig verkackt. Hauptsache, Gott glaubt an mich.
Naja, seh ich nicht.
Das fand ich einfach ein bisschen, also nicht so schön.
Wie gesagt, ich warte jetzt noch und hoffe, dass die Freak Show möglich ist.
Mama, ich bin jetzt hier Chef Brüttler weltweit. Keine Fragen, gib ihm! So, jetzt können wir ja mal anfangen. Oh ja, hochdynamisch, agil, modern, rausgeschlafen, modern und treibend. Das stand auf einer Schallplatte, die ich, Entschuldigung, dass ich jetzt wieder so alt rüberkomme.
Also nein, ich hab ja auch Schallplatten, aber...
Ja gut, aber ich war ja auch schon eine Wache in den 80ern. Die Zeit, die keiner versteht. Aber wir haben sie damals auch nicht so richtig verstanden. Auf jeden Fall gab es irgendwann diese neue deutsche Welle. Und da gab es ja so verschiedene Protagonisten, die habt sicherlich auch schon mal von Hubert K gehört. Rosemarie.
Also ich hab schon mal Hubert K gehört, auch in musikalischer Form, aber das bin ich mit keinem nicht.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall stand auf der Single, damals kaufte man ja noch Singles im Kaufhaus, und da stand modern und treibend, da stand da drauf. Das haben wir irgendwie bis heute nicht losgelassen. Das traf die Sache auch irgendwie ganz gut. Damit war dann irgendwie die Moderne dann auch offiziell eingeleitet. Da gab es ja diesen ganzen Quatsch von heute noch nicht. Keine Smartphones, kein Internet, nix. Wir hatten ja nüscht.
Furchtbar. Ich sag den oft, der ist heute auch ständig. Ja, sagtest du.
Ja, ich will mal die Jugend wieder zurückhaben. Noch mal zurückspulen.
An den 26. Oktober 1985.
Ja, das war jetzt eine etwas umfangreichere Begrüßung. Das hat natürlich den Grund, dass wir vor einigen Sendungen das Previously Toolkit vorgestellt haben.
Und das hat sich gleich sehr gefruchtet.
Das hat sich mich eingeschlagen jetzt, weil David ist auch gerade ganz glücklich darüber, weil er hat gerade viele andere Dinge zu tun, aber dass ich dann gleich irgendwie mit so drei geilen Sachen überschüttet werde, das hat mich dann auch ein bisschen überrollt. Deswegen mussten wir jetzt hier mal so ein bisschen an der Kurbel drehen.
Aber du musst natürlich gleich sagen, dass wenn du jetzt in der nächsten Sendung 10 Previouslys bekommst, dass wir jetzt...
Irgendwann besteht die Sendung aus nichts anderem mehr, dann mach ich ein Previously-Podcast irgendwie, der sich nur noch selbst referenziert.
Solange die Previouslys nicht aus Previouslys bestehen, dann ist das nur noch weißes Rauschen.
Genau, dann sind wir in einer Zeit in einer Schleife gefangen. Tja, also insofern vielen Dank an die Schöpfer, wenn ich das jetzt richtig kriege, war das in der Reihenfolge hoffentlich von Chris, Mr. Binn und Rainer. Ihr könnt euch gerne noch mal ein bisschen genauer melden, wie man euch so verlinken soll. Das stand dann immer so nicht so richtig drin. Na ja, wie das immer so ist, wenn es auf die Sendung zugeht, dann bin ich mal total barant mit 1000 E-Mails hier und da und dann überblick ich das auch alles nur so begrenzt.
Ich hoffe, das waren noch alle drei, dass da nicht noch mehr war.
Nicht, dass das die Weihnachtsspenden-Lebkuchen vom letzten Jahr waren.
Ja, also vielen, vielen Dank und keep it coming. Wir müssen nur mal schauen, vielleicht könnt ihr ja...
Vielleicht könnt ich dir das zwecklich entsprechen.
Ja, das wäre in der Tat eine Option so. Oder dass man mir das vorhersagt, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht wird das jetzt auch wieder dazu, dass sich das nächste Mal keiner mehr traut. Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht ist das auch eine Aussage, der Hörer an uns, eine Erwartung. Wie sagen das so Bundestagsmenschen? Eine Aufgabe für uns, dass wir das halt besser schauspielern dann müssen, hier so den Rahmen drum rum.
Wir haben den Hörer willen zur Kenntnis genommen. Und ich kann Ihnen sagen, wir haben verstanden. Freak Show Partei. Wählt Freak Show Partei.
Modern und treibend.
Ja, da haben wir es doch schon.
Sag das nicht zu laut, Timme, oder wir müssen das machen.
Wenn es mal so lange hält.
Wie? Meinst du, wir zerzoffen uns schon vorher? Wir treten hier vorher alle aus?
Nein, ich meine, Neuwahlen könnte es ja auch schon vorher geben.
Das heißt, wir müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen.
Das stimmt. Vielleicht würden wir auch in so einer permanenten Schleife jetzt gefallen, dass alle vier Wochen Neuwahlen, geht jetzt alles wieder von vorne los. Die ganze Aufregung, bis dann keiner mehr weiß, was er überhaupt noch will. Ja, es war Wahl. Warst du da?
Und wie war's?
Gar nicht mal so geil.
Ich darf ja nicht.
Stimmt, du darfst gar nicht.
Du darfst nur pöbeln.
Ich darf nur rumpöbeln, genau.
Wie war es? Traurig. Man wusste ja schon vorher, wohin die Reise geht.
Aber das so zu sehen, ist einfach nur traurig.
Und jetzt fällt es dir schwer, Optimismus zu entwickeln?
Meinst du, dass ich als Koffi vorher schon optimistisch war? Also ein paar von diesen Klischees muss ich auch ein bisschen leben, oder?
Also optimistisch bin ich nicht.
Weil Optimismus ist dein ekliger Großaugen, den du einmal in deinem Leben gesehen hast und danach nie wieder sehen wolltest.
Ich bin ja unverbesserlicher Optimist. Das ist ja so eine Eigenschaft von mir, die ich nicht unbedingt jetzt loben möchte, aber ist einfach so. Keine Ahnung warum, aber ich sehe immer das Positive im Moment. Weil alles andere ist ja auch irgendwie...
Zeitverschwendung.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Also da kann man sicherlich auch mit anders umgehen, aber für mich ist das eher Energieverschwendung. Weil ändert ja nichts, ne?
Das bin ich aber als Pessimist deswegen.
Achso, du siehst es genauso, es ist bloß Scheiße.
Und wenn es dann nicht so scheiße wird, dann kann man sich ja dann freuen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich bin auch eher, würde ich sagen, optimistisch veranlagt. Aber das geht auch eher, dann ist die andere Seite der Medaille nämlich, dass ich mir dann denke, ja ärgern oder Panik schieben kann man ja dann, wenn es wirklich scheiße ist. Also ne, also nicht schon vorher Panik schieben und nicht schon vorher 1000 Sorgen machen, sondern erstmal davon ausgehen, passt schon alles und dann, wenn es wirklich scheiße läuft, dann kann man ja immer noch sich der ganz, der hysterischen Schreierei und Panik Attacke widmen.
Aber nicht vorher schon.
Aber es gibt ja so Leute, die schon vorher immer sich so Gedanken machen und oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott und dann gar nicht erst dazu kommen, irgendwas zu machen und ne, so würde ich mich jetzt auch nicht bezeichnen.
Aber ich finde das schon ist ein trauriges Ergebnis.
Also, das auf jeden Fall.
Ja, irgendwas sagt es sicherlich aus. Ich meine, mein optimistischer Ansatz wäre halt okay, jetzt haben wir die Kaspar-Körper dann halt da in der Laberstube. So, ab jetzt können sie sich nur noch blamieren. Und ab jetzt sind sie halt Teil des Establishments. Und jetzt kann man das eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr steigern.
Das Schönste war, glaube ich, was Christian, äh, wie hieß der überhaupt? Ich krieg diesen Vornamen immer nicht zusammen.
Der FDP wollte ich dann sein.
Genau, der FDP Heini, genau. Ich glaube, der hat das Schönste bisher über die AfD gesagt, gleich noch am Wahlabend. So was von wegen uns so eben, dass es keine Partei mit Inhalten ist. Und immer dann, wenn es um Inhalte geht, sind die am Buffet. Also, vielleicht sollte man mal so eine kleine Buffet-Überwachung einfallen. Striche machen.
Auf jeden Fall wird es jetzt halt irgendwie ganz putzig. Ich meine, jetzt müssen die sich da irgendwie zusammenrotten in so einer Kollision, die Grünen und die CSU.
Weil das ist doch auch wie...
Da hätte ich ja fast noch Geld drauf gesetzt.
Für bezahlt irgendwie.
Um mal so eine Auseinandersetzung mit zu verfolgen. Das wird jetzt irgendwie ganz lustig. Ich meine, vielleicht kriegen wir ja Neuwahlen, oder was?
Ja, spannend ist ja auch, was die CSU macht.
Die dreht durch, die dreht frei. Ich meine, die sind jetzt irgendwie komplett...
Hätten wir das mit Bayern jetzt auch mal durch das Thema.
Na ja, gut. Aber wir sind ja keine Politik-Sendung hier, ne? Echt? Nee. Immer nicht.
Aber...
Aber kriegen wir das vielleicht die Bundestagswahl auf irgendein Apple-Thema umgemünzt?
Aber es fällt mir gerade noch nichts an.
Ja, nee, das mit der Wahl würde ich auf jeden Fall auch lieber schnell wieder in den Hintergrund schieben.
Gut, machen wir das. Hucke, du warst im Urlaub.
Ja, das war sehr gut, so Sachen in den Hintergrund schieben.
Wie lange warst du jetzt eigentlich im Urlaub? Du warst ja gefühlt den ganzen Sommer weg.
Das war auf jeden Fall ein Monat Sommer.
Durchgehend, ohne irgendeine Anschritte.
Also es war mal einmal was bewölkt. Aber das war das erste Mal, glaube ich, dass ich mal so wirklich am Stück einen Monat komplett durchgängig Sommer hatte.
Huckel hat auch ein bisschen Farbe bekommen.
Ja, so die Nerdbräune musste etwas weichen. Aber es ist immer noch im Rahmen, also man erkennt mich immer noch, oder?
Ja, du bist ganz nautisch.
Ich hab mir extra für den Trip bei meinen anderen gestreiften T-Shirts schon am verrotten waren, nachdem ich sie fünf Jahre auf Hoher See zur Schau stellte, hab ich mir extra ein neues Set bestellt. Und heute für die Sendung hab ich den Klassiker Blau-Weiß in breiten Streifen aufgelegt.
Darf man auch nicht anders das Segelboot betreten als in Blau-Weiß?
Du darfst, wie auch immer du bist, aufs Segelboot.
Du müsstest jetzt noch so einen Hamburger-Aktzent hier mal zulegen.
Bist du das hin? Das möchte ich jetzt hier nicht live probieren, um nicht die Werten Hamburger zu verunglimpfen. Nein, du kannst auf jeden Fall sein, wie du willst, auf so einem Boot. Also, kommt natürlich auf die Besatzung an, aber auf dem Elisabeth-Boot ist auf jeden Fall freie Kleiderordnung.
Freie Kleiderordnung, F-K-O.
Du kannst auch keine Kleider tragen, ist auch okay. Es wird nur nachts ein bisschen frisch. Ja, nee, aber ich war auf jeden Fall wieder mal segeln und diesmal eben einen Monat, weil ich die letzten vier Jahre schon immer dachte, zwei Wochen irgendwie reicht nicht.
Und man gerade so in Fahrt, ne?
Genau. Und diesmal habe ich es mir dann gleich so richtig gegeben, die ersten zwei Wochen waren mit einer Gruppe Freunde und die zweiten zwei Wochen mit einer anderen Gruppe Freunde und der erste Trip war gleich vier Tage am Stück ohne Land in Sicht segeln. Und da waren zwei Leute dabei, die das erste Mal überhaupt auf dem Segelboot waren. Und ich habe denen aber allen vorher gesagt, das ist so ein bisschen die Abenteuer-Route. Also es geht direkt auf den Atlantik, direkt vier Tage am Stück segeln und dann sind wir vielleicht so ein, zwei Tage am Land und dann geht es gleich nochmal drei Tage weiter.
Was war das jetzt? Das war so an Frankreich? Den Trip da Richtung Gran Canaria oder was?
Nee, südlichster Punkt oder fast südlichster Punkt.
Wo bist du denn eingestiegen?
Cádiz. Cádiz? Cádiz? Cádiz. Spanien. Da gleich um die Ecke von der Straße von Gibraltar. Und von da sind wir dann erst mal quer rüber nach Porto Santo und Madeira gesegelt. Wir waren nicht auf optimaler Route wegen des Windes, deswegen waren es 600 Meilen. Das ist dann mit dem Segelboot eben so in etwa drei, vier Tage je nach Wind. Ja, und das war auf jeden Fall auch...
Wo ist denn Madeira?
Ja, wenn du hier so ein bisschen...
Nee, nicht irgendwie.
Quasi fast...
Hätte ich jetzt welches gleich rausgeflogen, weil wir Millionär.
Also für die, die es jetzt nicht auf dem Schirm haben, ist es nördlich von den kanarischen Inseln, circa 300 Meilen.
Und das waren sozusagen die vier Tage von Cádiz nach Madeira.
Genau, und die Azoren sind sozusagen nordwestlich von Madeira. Das sind, glaube ich, die nördlichsten Inseln von Portugal und dann hat zwischen Madeira und den kanarischen Inseln sind noch so zwei kleine Inseln oder drei, die auch noch zu Portugal gehören. Die südlichsten Inseln Portugals sind, aber die nicht wirklich bewohnt sind, sondern Naturschutzgebiete sind und auch deswegen noch im Besitz von Portugal sind.
So kleine Fleckchen.
Ja, und wir waren noch da. Also wir sind das zweite Stück von Madeira zu den kanarischen Inseln nicht am Stück gesegelt, sondern wir haben noch bei den Islas Salvages Halt gemacht. Da muss man sich vorher eine Erlaubnis holen in Portugal, weil auch Wächter und die Polizei sind die einzigen Leute, die auf dieser Insel sind. Und die wechseln sich alle zwei Wochen ab. Was für ein Drop. Ja, die sahen auf jeden Fall gut gebräunt aus und gut erholt.
Da hat dann so der Staat einfach so ein paar Vögel auf dieser Insel, die passen einfach oft, dass sie keiner klaut.
Also die Geschichte von der Insel ist tatsächlich, sie war erst im Privatbesitz, dann hat die irgendeiner in einem Casino von dem anderen, vorigen Besitzer abgezockt und dann wurden darauf Häschen und andere Tiere ausgesetzt und als privates Jagdrevier genutzt. Dann hat irgendwie zwischendurch auch Spanien immer mal wieder Bedarf angemeldet, so dass sie ja auch gerne diese Inseln hätten. Und irgendwie hat dann wiederum ein, ich hab jetzt die Namen alle nicht parat, aber so ein Mensch hat gedacht, da gibt es Vögel, die heimisch auf dieser Insel sind und nur auf dieser Insel und wir machen da jetzt ein Naturschutzgebiet drauf und hat quasi bei der portugiesischen Regierung darum geworben, dass sie die Inseln zurückkaufen und wieder in staatlichen Besitz überführen. Und das haben sie auch irgendwann getan. Und in diesen ganzen Rangeleien mit Spanien, wer jetzt nun die Inseln bekommt, war das auch so ein kleiner strategischer Move, um die zu behalten, indem man sagt, wir machen ein Naturschutzgebiet drauf, wir machen da keine Basis oder Hafen oder sonst irgendwas so. Und deswegen sind diese Wardens da drauf, um sicherzustellen, dass da keiner illegal fischt und angelt und so weiter und dass keiner einfach so auf die Inseln kommt und da Dinge tut. Und die Polizei ist halt da, um wenn dann Besucher kommen, eben die Bootspapiere und die Papiere der Mitreisenden zu checken. Und dann sitzen da halt irgendwie auch vier Polizeioffiziere sozusagen. Und das Geile war, wir kamen da irgendwann am Nachmittag an und sagen so über Funk ja, hallo, wir würden mal die Insel besuchen, wir haben auch den Wisch dabei. Und dann meinen die, ja, also es war um 10 Uhr morgens, meinten die so, ja um 17 Uhr könnt ihr kommen. Okay, 17 Uhr. Dann haben wir die ganze Zeit in der Lagune oder in der Bucht gelegen, haben im Fernglas geguckt, was die so machen. Und die so hingen da alle so oberkörperfrei rum, haben gegrillt, gechillt. Und dann so Punkt 17 Uhr, wir nochmal so, also wir würden jetzt mal so rüberkommen, die verschwinden in ihrem Häuschen und waren dann wirklich so voll uniformiert und alles angelegt und wir meinten schon zu den Jungs, Leute, für uns hättet ihr euch jetzt nicht bei 33 Grad in die Stiefel und so weiter schmeißen müssen, aber ja.
Ist das hier diese Insel, auf die ich hier gerade schaue?
Ja, die sind auch sehr unspektakulär. Wir haben eine Führung bekommen, auch in der späten Nachmittagshitze, das ist im Prinzip wirklich nur ein Fels, wo diese Vögel drauf wohnen und viel mehr.
Wo wohnen denn die Polizisten, ich sehe hier irgendwie gar nichts.
Wenn du unseren Matenka-Tracker nochmal aufmachst.
Ja, den Matenka-Tracker hatte ich schon mal.
Genau, such einfach nach Garmin und Matenka, dann findest du den, dann siehst du auch, an welcher Station wir da halt gemacht haben. Ja, aber genau, das war auf jeden Fall, so die ersten zwei Wochen waren auf jeden Fall mal richtig geil für Leute, die Bock auf Segeln hatten. Das waren vier und zwei von den anderen, naja, sagen wir mal eine von den sechs Leuten, die war wirklich nicht so richtig gut auf, also segel- kompatibel und auf dem letzten Stück sind dann auch noch die Medikamente zu Ende gegangen und die letzten zwei Tage waren dann noch mal volle Seekrankheit. Genauso dazwischen. Also ihr seht das jetzt gerade nicht, aber es gab, wenn ihr auch im Internet nach Garmin und Matenka sucht, da gibt es eine Seite, weil die Elisa hat halt so einen Tracker, der wenig kostet, aber über Satellit immer die Position alle 10 Minuten rausfunkt und sie kann auch glaube ich im Monat, was weiß ich, 10 Textnachrichten schreiben, die dann auf Facebook gepostet werden, so Twitter-Style. Und ja, den hatte sie jetzt die ganzen, seit dem letzten Jahr an, so dass man genau sehen konnte, wo man ist und wie schnell das Boot fährt und ob es überhaupt noch fährt. Und ich habe das auch all meinen Bekannten und Verwandten gegeben und meine Oma hat dann auch auf ihrem iPad immer so geguckt, wo ist er denn gerade und...
Aber das kann man ja nirgendswo richtig anlegen, ne?
Doch, da gibt's...
Ah, hier ist es!
Das linke Haus gehört dem, also dem Typen, der dafür geworben hat, dass Portugal die Insel zurückkauft und der kommt einmal im Jahr oder so für ein paar Wochen dahin und ist wirklich nur so eine kleine Bude. Und das rechte Haus da sind so die ganzen The Wardens und Police-Officers halt drin und die kümmern sich auch um die anderen Inseln und so und ja.
Und haben sie die ganzen Hasen dann wieder abgeschossen, bevor sie da Natur draus gemacht haben?
Alles wieder in den ursprünglichen Zustand quasi überführt. Die Ratten und die Hasen haben sie alle.
Ah, und was ist da sonst drauf?
Eigentlich nur Vögel und ein Hund, das ist der einzige permanente Bewohner dieser Insel seit 14 Jahren.
Wie ein wilder Hund.
Naja, ne, der Hund von denen da halt. Aber die Leute wechseln halt alle 14 Tage, deswegen der Hund bleibt halt immer da. Und die Vögel sind halt auch ziemlich krass. Ich hab jetzt schon wieder vergessen, wie sie heißen, aber die brüten da halt auf der Insel, dann irgendwie überqueren sie tatsächlich irgendwie auch den Atlantik und kommen sechs Jahre später wieder und gehen genau zurück in das gleiche Loch, wo sie geboren wurden, um dann sozusagen den nächsten Nachwuchs zu zeugen und so. Und ja, wir hatten dann noch ein Opfer zu beklagen auf dieser Insel, weil ein Freund von mir, der bei den ersten zwei Wochen dabei war, der macht immer sehr schöne Fotos und er hatte so eine richtig coole Drohne dabei, ne? Und dann wollten wir halt irgendwie so Footage machen vom Segelboot vor der Bucht mit Segeln und es war alles perfekt und wir hatten den Plan, ne, und er fliegt halt los mit der Drohne und direkt kommt so ein Vogel und macht so baf weg und die fällt einfach direkt ins Meer. Das war wirklich so zehn Sekunden. War der erste Flug oder was? Ne, wir hatten davor schon ein bisschen was aufgenommen, aber das sollte jetzt so der Action-Shot werden, das Segeln, das Boot vor der Insel.
Jetzt wirds geil so.
Jetzt wirds geil, ne, aber Vogel-Naturschutz-Gebiet sollte man mit seiner Drohne etwas aufpassen. Ja, naja, auf jeden Fall, genau, und das war so Spanien, Madeira, wobei Porto Santo ist noch eine Insel vor Madeira. Ich glaube, zuerst Ila Salvages und dann sind wir die zweiten zwei Wochen nur um die kanarischen Inseln rumgefahren und so als touristisches Review würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, ich würde nicht unbedingt noch mal auf die kanarischen Inseln oder in die Nähe fahren. Madeira hingegen würde ich mir auf jeden Fall noch mal geben.
Warum nicht? Weil das schon zu touristisch ist?
Es ist so krass touristisch. Also da sind, wir sind ja da alle, fast alle Inseln, fünf von sieben Inseln sind wir abgefahren. Und die ganzen Küsten sind einfach voll mit Hotelkomplexen und Apartmentkomplexen. Wir waren in zwei Marinas, wo wir festgestellt haben, die ganze Stadt, also wirklich Stadt, ist fake. Also ist alles nur für den Tourismusbetrieb. Da ist kein Haus bewohnt sozusagen von Einwohnern. Man muss erstmal in die Insel reinfahren, bis man überhaupt echte Einwohner sieht. Und auch von der Landschaft her, zum Beispiel Fuerteventura und Lanzerote sind halt so Mondlandschaften. Las Palmas oder Gran Canaria, das geht so einigermaßen. La Gomera war eigentlich mit das Schönste so. Das war halt schön grün zumindest. Genau. Aber ja, Tenerife und auch Gran Canaria, ich fand das extrem touristisch. Und auch diese großen Schiffe, die die ganzen Touristen immer so abladen. Da gibt es auch so Lokalzeitungen, wo auch drin steht, wann so die nächsten Cruise-Ships kommen und dann wieder die 10.000 oder wie auch immer Leute da abladen. Und das war in Madeira auf jeden Fall sehr viel entspannter. Madeira ist auch, würde ich sagen, vegetationstechnisch sehr viel facettenreicher. Also es gilt ja auch als der Blumengarten oder Garten oder keine Ahnung, hat irgendwie so einen Gartennamen. Und wir haben da Früchte gegessen, da hab ich noch nie in meinem Leben davon gehört oder gesehen. Die hatten irgendwie sieben oder acht verschiedene Maracuja Sorten mit unterschiedlichsten Geschmäckern. Also Essen war da auch sehr viel besser als in Spanien, fand ich.
Also ich bin jetzt ein bisschen geschockt mit diesem Madeira. Ich meine, da kann man bestimmt auch Urlaub machen, oder?
Ja, absolut. Ist auch im Winter noch für uns halt klimagewohnten Menschen auch immer noch T-Shirt-Wetter wohl.
Das ist nämlich, also ich hab, wegen letztem Jahr hatten wir geschaut, wo wir hinfliegen in den Urlaub. Und da gab es auch kurz die Überlegung, ob wir irgendwie da auf die Inseln fahren. Ich hab halt auch von vielen gehört, dass es gerade im Sommer nicht so geil sein soll. Also ihr seid natürlich auch voll in der Tourisaison dort gewesen, ne?
Aber auch so, ich fand halt, die Kanarischen Inseln, da gab es irgendwie wenig, was mich jetzt wirklich auch so, also landschaftlich, ja, du guckst ja dann mal diese Vulkanlandschaften an, aber da sind teilweise auf, ich glaube, was, Landsohr Rot oder Fuerteventura, da sind so kilometerweit Landschaft, wo man nicht mal laufen kann, weil die Erde so zerklüftet ist und so. Wie gesagt, Lagomera war von denen noch am ersten, das wo ich noch mal hinholen würde. Aber Madeira, wie gesagt, das war, die Vegetation ist da auch so unterschiedlich von Nord zur Südseite teilweise, oder auch wenn du hoch in die Gipfel gehst, da ist dann plötzlich so richtiger Wald, also richtiger Wald und wie gesagt, das Essen war, fand ich auch besser. Nach den vier Wochen bin ich jetzt echt, brauche ich nicht mehr spanisches Essen erst mal in nächster Zeit.
Bist du durch mit, ja?
Ja, naja und da würde ich auf jeden Fall, da waren wir auf dem Gipfel mit dem, Tim ist gerade im Google Earth Modus und wir schauen uns den höchsten Gipfel an, wo auch so ein schönes Radom drauf steht. Ja, genau, da waren wir auch. Wir haben uns da auch einen Mietwagen auf einigen Inseln geholt, um dann auch wirklich mal alles zu sehen oder so viel wie möglich, sagen wir mal. Ja, wie gesagt, Madeira kann ich empfehlen. Porto Santo, die kleine Insel davor, die ist im Wesentlichen nicht so ultra interessant. Die hat nur einen Sandstrand, was Madeira nicht hat, der ist auch ziemlich lang.
Also Madeira hat überhaupt gar keinen Strand und deswegen ist es auch nicht so touristisch so überlaufen.
Genau, aber die ganzen Madeiraner, die gehen dann halt zum Baden, fahren halt mit der Fähre rüber und gehen dann an den Sandstrand da. Aber da gab es ein Lokal, das war spektakulär. Da habe ich den besten Thunfisch gegessen ever, glaube ich. Das war richtig groß. Wer jemals nach Porto Santo geht, las siesta. Cheesy Name, das sieht auch der Weg, der da hinführt, sieht auch so aus, als würde man da nicht essen wollen, aber geht dahin und ihr werdet sehr gut...
Das gleich mal die Homepage raussuchen.
Ich habe das hier auf Tripadvisor rausgesucht.
Porto Santo ist sozusagen, das besteht im Wesentlichen aus dem Strand und dem Flughafen.
Genau, aber der Flughafen ist auch nur für so kleinen, also da ist kein Linienflugbetrieb so richtig.
Ich versuche gerade diese Fähre zu finden.
Ja, die ist ja nicht besonders groß.
La siesta Porto Santo. Ich gucke mal den Link hier kurz. Da ist es auch schon. 4,5 Sterne immerhin. Also alles war da unglaublich gut. Weil hier auch gerade jemand im Chat ein Bild vom Madeira-Flughafen zeigt. Der ist auch recht spektakulär, weil der teilweise in der Luft hängt auf so Stelzen. Was? Na ja, sie haben das an der Seite gebaut, wo nicht so viel Land ist. Quasi ist bei Funchal, da in der Hauptstadt. Tim zoomt rein. Wenn ihr nach Airport Madeira sucht, weiter... Ja, geh mal da, wo der Hafen ist.
Erzähl du mal.
Genau, der ist dann halt so der Runway teilweise auf Stelzen gebaut und unter den Stelzen parken sie Boote. Also es ist so... Wir sind da nicht reingefahren, aber sieht schon von der See auch sehr merkwürdig aus, wenn man dann von der Seite da so vorbei fährt. Auf dem Google Earth sieht man es gar nicht mal so gut. Wenn du im Slack guckst, da ist ein besseres Bild von den Stelzen. Genau. Wir verlinken das. Ja, da... Da war dann schon eher Linienflugbetrieb. Komisch, das kommt dann halt bei Google Earth nicht so gut gerendert.
Nicht die Auflösung ist ja jetzt auch keine Überraschung.
Ja, und was gibt's noch zu erzählen? Also, ist auf jeden Fall ein schöner Trip gewesen und ich würde glaube ich nächstes Mal eher von den Azoren nach Madeira segeln, statt von Madeira zu den Kanarischen Inseln, weil die Azoren sollen wohl auch sehr schön sein und noch weniger touristisch überlaufen, weil wahrscheinlich noch mehr Leute denken, oh, da kann man bestimmt nicht schwimmen gehen.
Und wie war das jetzt so? Du warst ja dann auch das erste Mal ein paar Tage auf See, oder? Oder hattest du das schon mal jetzt nur so ein, zwei?
Das längste wäre so 36, vielleicht 40 Stunden. Ja, ich find's gut. Also ich wusste ja vorher auch nicht so ganz, wie mir das jetzt passt. Und vor allen Dingen dann mit sechs Leuten wieder eine leicht andere Gruppierung von Menschen auch. Weiß man dann auch nicht, ob das dann immer so gut geht. Dann gibt es halt kein Land, wo man mal flüchten kann. Und noch dazu gab es eben zwei Kandidaten, wo man schon vermuten konnte, dass Seekrankheit ein Thema sein wird. Also waren die Vorzeichen nicht unbedingt optimal. Glücklicherweise kamen aber alle mit zwei Händen voll Pillen. Und irgendwie hat sich dann auch relativ schnell ein Gewinner rauskristallisiert. Biodramina Caffeina. Ich hab's schon getwittert und so. Ja, ich warte hier. Weil das sind ja in der Regel Antihistamine sowie Heuschnupftabletten. Und die machen halt auch bisweilen sehr müde. Und die haben sozusagen mit Caffeinen das versetzt, sodass die Müdigkeit gekontert werden sollte. Und es war einfach die Tablette sozusagen, wo alle befreit waren von der Seekrankheit, also die nicht mehr seekrank waren und auch keine anderen Nebenwirkungen hatten. So muss man das sagen, genau.
Weil andere haben Nebenwirkungen, die dich dann gegebenenfalls anders ausknocken?
Genau. Oder noch schlimmer, die lassen dich zwar in Ruhe, dass du dich nicht übergeben musst, aber dir ist trotzdem die ganze Zeit schlecht. Also du hast trotzdem so ein mulmiges Gefühl im Magen. Und bei denen war das so, dass die Leute dann sogar unter Deck kochen konnten, während das Boot so am Schaukeln war. Also es war dann wirklich, die waren komplett okay, ohne Nebenwirkungen. Und das Problem war dann eben, als die alle waren.
Dann ging es los.
Ich poste auch mal noch einen interessanten Artikel zum Thema Sea Sickness, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal gemacht habe, aber der ist wirklich ganz cool, weil sie da eine Regatta begleitet haben und auf die verschiedenen Boote, sozusagen auf den verschiedenen Booten, die Leute interviewt haben. Und je nachdem, wie die Crew mit der Seekrankheit umgegangen ist, zum Beispiel auf Booten, wo die mehr gestresst wurden, so von wegen, hier, du gehst sie jetzt auskotzen, dann kommst du sofort wieder an deinen Pfosten oder so. Oder im Vergleich zu anderen Booten, wo man die Leute, die seekrank waren, eher hat chillen lassen. Und dann ebenso verschiedene Bereiche beleuchtet und verglichen, wieso die unterschiedlichen Crews sich an die Seekrankheit gewöhnt haben. Und das ist in diesem Artikel alles sehr schön zusammengefasst. Also wer sich damit mal beschäftigt oder auch gerne mal aufs Wasser will und Angst hat vor Seekrankheit. Also Biodramina, Caffeina, das gab es halt in Spanien nicht. Gibt es sicherlich auch in irgendeiner Form in Deutschland oder kann man sich nach Deutschland bestellen. Und diesen Sea Sickness Artikel kann man sich auch mal durchlesen, weil da sind auch noch andere Sachen dabei, wie zum Beispiel Alkoholkonsum oder wenn man ein Hangover hat vom Vorabend, weil es so lustig war. Das ist dann eben auch nicht förderlich für die Seekrankheit am nächsten Tag.
Wie ist das eigentlich? Kann man das vorher testen, ob man seekrank wird?
Na du kannst dich auf dem Wann sehen, auf so eine Nussschale setzen und mal ein bisschen rumschippern. Meine Testfragen sind eigentlich immer, wo ich schon weiß, okay, ist ein riesiger Kandidat. Wird dir schlecht hinten im Bus? Wird dir schlecht, wenn du im Auto liest oder auf dein Smartphone guckst? Hast du irgendwelche Erinnerungen daran, dass dir jemals auf einer Fähre oder sowas schlecht geworden ist? Und wenn eine von den drei nur dabei ist? Na ja, okay, vielleicht. Wenn zwei oder drei sind, dann ist man schon so ein Kandidat.
Echt, Lesen im Auto finde ich furchtbar, es sei denn, man fährt auf der Autobahn. Ich könnte jetzt nicht im Stadtverkehr lesen, aber auf einer Fähre ist mir noch nie schlecht geworden.
Ultimativ kann man es nicht beantworten, aber ich muss jetzt sagen, in den vier oder fünf Jahren, fünf Jahre, fünf Trips, habe ich jetzt sehr unterschiedlichste Leute so gesehen.
Das war schon das fünfte Mal auf der Martinka?
Und du noch kein Mal?
Naja, schlechte Voraussetzungen.
Also, tja, auf jeden Fall, man kann es überstehen. Ich würde sagen, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, wie empfindlich man ist, dann, es gibt zum Beispiel so eine Webseite handgegenkohje.de, wo man sozusagen nicht so chartermäßig sich einen Platz auf dem Boot bucht, sondern sagt, man hilft halt ein bisschen mit, und dafür kann man da halt pennen auf dem Boot. Das ist eher so ein gemeinschaftliches Prinzip, da kann man sich dann mal für eine Woche vielleicht was aussuchen oder irgendeinen anderen Wochentrip, wo man weiß, okay, mit so einer Packung Pillen kommt man hin, im schlimmsten Fall. Und wenn man sowieso jeden Abend im Hafen ist wieder und nicht vier Tage am Stück übers Meer segelt, dann ist das auch noch mal ein bisschen was anderes, weil man dann zumindest weiß, okay, in sechs Stunden kann ich erstmal wieder an Land und dann passt das wieder.
Das ist sozusagen so das Airbnb des Segels.
Ja, da gibt es auch, es gab noch sowas, habe ich gerade aber nicht im Kopf.
Mit Segelgelegenheit.
Diese Saison endet aber im Oktober, ne?
In Deutschland, oder was?
Ja, natürlich, ja klar, man kann auch woanders hin, ja. Aber die sind, glaube ich, überwiegend so in deutschen Gewässern. Obwohl, stimmt gar nicht. Ich sehe gerade links, Mittelmeer, Atlantik, alles dabei. Also vielleicht auch das ganze Jahr. Ich habe das nur von einem Kollegen gehört, dass er sich da irgendwie einen Trip klicken wollte, der auch nämlich auf der Matenca war vor mir und dann gleich angefixt war mit dem Segeln. Und meinte, er war zwei Tage auf dem Boden, dann krieg ich so eine Nachricht. Ich denke bereits über Exit-Strategien nach. Raus aus dem Job. Genau, wie man das mit dem Boot so hinbekommen kann. Mit dem Boat-Life. Und ansonsten, für mich um nochmal diese Eingangsfrage mit dem vier Tage am Stück Segeln, für mich war es großartig, man hat auch nach fünf Mal mit Segeln immer noch dieses Gefühl zwischendurch, ist das jetzt alles noch normal eigentlich, was wir hier so tun? Weil dann kommt sich halt auf dem Meer schon sehr klein vor. Klein vorkommt.
Nee, nee, wie du meinst, ist das mit dem alles noch so richtig, was wir hier tun?
Na ja, also normal, nicht richtig, sondern weil du sitzt halt da so am Steuer und steuerst oder stehst oft, wenn es zu wellig ist, dann ist sitzen immer ein bisschen schwierig. Und dann siehst du halt, wie so eine Welle kommt und die ist auch ganz schön groß und dann kippt das Boot so ein bisschen zur Seite und die Bücher fliegen alle unten aus dem Regal und irgendein Topf scheppert irgendwo hin und dann richtet sich das Boot wieder auf und man fährt halt ganz normal weiter. Aber irgendwie denkt man sich auch so, also die Naturgewalt und man spürt sie halt mit jeder Welle und dem Wind und so. Und ab und zu gibt es dann so diesen kleinen Selbstreflektionsmoment, wo man denkt, was machen wir hier eigentlich? Eine kleine Nutzschale auf diesen großen Ozean. Und gerade in dem, also wir hatten einmal so Wind, ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht mehr, welche Windstärke das ist, aber wenn man den Horizont nicht mehr sieht, weil die Wellen sozusagen, wenn du im Wellental bist und dann nur noch Welle um dich rum siehst quasi, waren also schon mehr als zwei Meter, würde ich jetzt mal tippen. Und dann ist aber auch wiederum auf der anderen Seite faszinierend, dass man dann einfach so das akzeptiert und als normal halt jetzt so, ist jetzt halt so, ne? Also man kann ja eh nicht anders als das jetzt zu akzeptieren. Und auch die beiden, die zum ersten Mal auf dem Boot waren, die haben das auch sehr schnell mit Fassung dran. Also bei denen kamen auch die ersten Fragen als so die Bücher einmal. Die sind halt wirklich so alle aus dem Regal raus, quer durchs ganze Boot und irgendein Teekessel ist durch die Gegend geflogen. Dann haben die ja auch noch mal so kurz so die etablierten Kräfte quasi anguckt, so alles normal, okay, ja, okay, dann, okay. Und dann meinte Elisa oder ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer das war, meine ich so, ja, ja, ich hab vergessen die Holzlatte da vorzumachen und normalerweise fliegen die dann nicht raus und so, passt schon, ja.
Wie ist das aber gerade, wenn du sagtest, da kommt so eine Welle bei einem Kleinboot, bist du ja immer daran bestrebt, eben nicht parallel zur Welle zu sein, sondern sie schon wirklich zu nehmen von vorn?
Das will man mit einem großen Boot im Prinzip auch. Also so ein bisschen, also wenn die Welle so von der Seite kommt, was bei uns oft der Fall war, dann willst du sozusagen kurz bevor sie kommt, dann so eher reinsteuern und dann direkt nach dem Scheitelpunkt so seitlich herunter surfen. Das ist aber nur den noch erfahreneren Skipperln gegönnt, das wirklich meisterhaft zu verführen.
Das wollte ich nämlich gleich noch weiterfragen, aber ich stehe mir das nicht so leicht vor. Ich meine, selbst in so einer Nussschale, also ich hab das in Norwegen halt häufig machen müssen, weil wenn du irgendwie so aus dem Fjord rauskommst, so Welle, hallo, musst du das Ding halt schon irgendwie ja steuern. Und das ist schon nicht leicht gewesen.
Aber es ist auch Bootsteuern, das ist eigentlich ja total trivial. Aber bereitet den Leuten doch am Anfang auch immer wieder Schwierigkeiten. Es gibt so ein paar ganz simple Tricks, um sich zu helfen. Zum Beispiel, wenn der Mast nach links geht, also nach Port oder Bugboard, wie es auf Deutsch heißt, dann steuerst du auch in die Richtung, weil das Boot immer sozusagen in die entgegengesetzte Richtung driften will, wenn Wind auf dem Segel ist. Du willst eigentlich schon steuern, bevor das Boot sich dreht. Das siehst du schon, wenn der Mast zur Seite gedrückt wird, dann musst du schon steuern. Dann bleibst du auch bei starken Wellen ziemlich gut auf Kurs, ohne die ganze Zeit auf den Kompass zu gucken. Und dann dieses Wellengefühl nach 3-4 Stunden oder so, hast du das dann auch irgendwann drin.
Wenn man falsch steuert, dann kann man sich damit auch richtig auf die Fresse legen.
Ja, wobei jetzt in den Bedingungen, in denen wir unterwegs waren, da war jetzt nie so starker Wind, dass das passieren hätte können. Und wir hatten auch immer relativ kleine Segelfläche. Also wir hatten schon das Segel kleiner gemacht. Und dann, ja, so richtig doll was falsch machen, kann man dann eigentlich nicht. Kann das eigentlich genauso kippen auch?
Also wenn man sich, also im Normalfall wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Nee, selbst wenn der Mast im Wasser liegt, richtet sich das in der Regel nochmal auf. Also das Einzige, wenn es sich, also es sei denn, du hast wirklich 180 Grad, also direkt unter dir. Aber dann ist sowieso... Genau, dann ist eh schon irgendwas schiefgelaufen. Und ansonsten ist halt zu viel Wasser im Boot das Problem. Das heißt, wenn du zur Seite kippst und dann kommt ganz viel Wasser rein, dann ist das nicht so ganz klar. Aber der Kiel ist halt schon sehr, sehr schwer. Und bei der Matenka auch relativ tief. Das heißt, die Hebelkraft ist sehr stark. Und da muss schon wirklich doll was passieren, damit es nicht mehr hochkommt.
Na gut, du hast es ja im ganzen Stück zurückgeschafft.
Ja, und auch so diese paar Tage ohne Internet, weil sonst war es ja immer in Küstengebieten. Und jetzt war es diesmal wirklich mal so richtig null. Null Internet, null Telefon.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Wie war denn so die digitale Situation?
Es war großartig, wirklich.
Moment, Moment, Moment, du hast gerade gesagt, es gab kein Internet.
Das sind Dinge, die für Tim jetzt nicht zusammenpassen.
Aber das Ding ist halt...
Na ja, erzähl mal, wie das so ist. Das kennt man ja gar nicht mehr. Ist ja wie in 80ern.
Wie, jetzt fahr doch einfach mal ein bisschen raus hier aus Berlin.
Ich hab das getan und das ist gar nicht so schlecht, wie man denkt.
Aber das Problem ist, oder nicht das Problem, sondern die Sache ist die, du hast gar nicht so viel Zeit für Internet, weil wir waren zu sechst und wir haben immer die Schichten zu zweit gemacht. Das heißt, wir hatten sozusagen drei Schichtteams und wir haben nachts zwei, vier Stunden Schichten gemacht und tagsüber sechs, sechs oder acht Stunden. Also tagsüber war es auf jeden Fall länger, weil dann eh mehrere Leute wach sind und man auch noch mal jemand anders noch das Steuer halten kann. Aber du bist schon, gerade wenn du so eine Nachtschicht hattest oder auch eine Spätschicht reicht auch schon, dann bist du halt auch erstmal ordentlich durch und dann penst du ja auch erstmal eine Weile, insofern die Wellen es zulassen. Und das ist dann auch nochmal das nächste Problem. Manchmal kann man nicht so gut pennen und das war bei uns auch sehr oft der Fall, dass das Boot so über die Wellen gerollt ist, dass es immer so links, rechts, links, rechts. Normalerweise, wenn du den Wind von einer Seite hast, dann kannst du ja eine Wand in deiner Kabine aussuchen, gegen die du dich kuschelst und dann ist gut. Aber wenn es die ganze Zeit über die Wellen rollt, dann rollst auch du halt. Und da dann erstmal überhaupt eine Position zu finden und sich damit abzufinden, dass du auf der Matratze die ganze Zeit mit der Matratze hin und her rutscht, dauert dann vielleicht ein bisschen mit Einschlafen und dann wachst du auf und dann ist auch schon deine nächste Schicht quasi.
Ich glaub, da hab ich letztens was gesehen, was mir dazu einfällt, was ein wirklich sehr gutes Utensil dann wäre für das Bett. Moment, ich such das mal raus.
Hängematte ist bei so einem kleinen Boot das Schaukel zu sehr, da schlägst du links und rechts an.
Und könnte man das nicht mit Technik erschlagen?
Klar, so ein Gimbal wäre das ideale Ding. Also hier diese Kameradinger, wo du das Stativ so frei bewegen kannst und der hält deine Kamera.
So Steady-Cap-mäßig.
Genau, das heißt irgendwie Gimbal heutzutage. Und wenn du das für deine Kabine hättest, dann ja.
Genau, dass man das Bett so lagert, dass es sich quasi immer automatisch ausgleicht.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es dafür nicht eine Lösung geben könnte. Ach Scheiße, da kriegst du die Vorschau nicht. Wenn der Tim mal auf diesen Pin klicken würde von Pinterest.
Ja, das mach ich jetzt.
Dann musst du dir bestimmt erst mal einen Account anlegen. Tim hat natürlich einen.
Die nicht, natürlich hab ich einen. Die nicht, ich hab überall einen Account, na fast.
Man kann aber auch die Pins so anschauen.
Leht aber nicht.
Wieso leht das denn?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass man so 10 oder so anschauen kann. Dann gucken wir, ob das anders funktioniert.
Ich weiß auch grad nicht, warum der hier nicht durchlädt.
Einmal durchladen bitte.
Was ist denn da zu sehen?
Was man da sieht, ist so ein Schlafkissen, was man sich nähen scheinbar kann, wo du dich so reinlegen kannst. Und ich hab das gesehen und dachte mir so, das ist ja mal geil.
Aber auch mit dem würdest du hin und her rollen. Das war wirklich toll. Also wie gesagt, es sind Bücher aus dem Regal geflogen und alles mögliche. Es waren auch teilweise so ruckartig, dass du dann wirklich, du lagst dann so und dann plötzlich rollt.
Ich hab schon den richtigen Kommentar im Chat. Kardanische Aufhängung, das ist das, was man haben will.
Super, ja.
Aber das würde doch funktionieren, oder? Wenn man das Bett kardanisch aufhängt.
Wenn das Boot groß genug ist, um das da unter zu bringen, ja. Das ist halt, Boot ist ja auch nicht so viel Platz gerade so bei Segelbooten.
Ja, aber wenn ich das richtig sehe bei der kardanischen... Brauchen wir da zwei oder drei? Geht es darum, dass der...
Also, du bist sicherlich auch nicht der Erste, der diese Idee hat. Das gibt's bestimmt auch. In den größeren Booten kann ich mir total vorstellen, dass Leute aus der Idee kommen.
Naja, eben.
Deswegen frag ich mich. Aber bei der Matenka würde ich das... nicht so...
Also, wenn man ein Boot, sozusagen, wenn man sich so ein Nerdboot baut, dann baut man auf jeden Fall schon mal das Bett kardanisch aufgehängt.
Wenn man so ein Weicher ist und nicht mit dem Wettkrank umgehen kann.
Das ist ein Beitrag zur Sicherheit. Wenn du immer eine ausgeschlafene Kraft haben kannst, ist es ein Feature.
Aber umgekehrt, wie gesagt, braucht man dann auch nicht so viel Internet. Weil du bist halt mit dem Segeln beschäftigt und wenn du dann die ganze Zeit so das Meer vor dir hast und Natur und dann kommen noch ein paar Delfine vorbei gehobst und so, dann brauchst du halt auch wirklich kein Internet. Und gerade zu dieser Zeit mit dem Wahlkampf und Nordkorea und was nicht noch alles so für Krisenherde in der Welt gebabbelt sind, ich war auch einfach echt froh, kein Internet zu haben. Es war wirklich sehr befreiend, sich von diesem ganzen Quatsch und Bullshit und diese ganze Zeitverschwendung, diese ganzen Videos und was nicht immer. Wirklich, ich bin nach Hause gekommen und hab so vorm Computer gesessen und dachte mir, also normalerweise würde ich jetzt dies, das und jenes jetzt erstmal gleich anklicken und aber noch so voll in diesem Bootsmodus, dass mir das jetzt irgendwie gar nicht so interessant erscheint. Mittlerweile bin ich wieder zurück im Internet. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde das wirklich sehr entspannt und befreiend. Und hier auf Instagram gibt es auch noch ein paar Bilder und da seht ihr auch ein paar Delfine rumhopsen, wenn du da draufklickst.
Ach, Delfine auch, ja?
Na sicher.
Na bitte.
Da links das erste.
Das ist ein toller Programm.
Das links ganz oben, klick mal das Video. Ohne Döen. Ich bin auch nicht mit Döen.
Hops, guck, da sind sie.
Warte, da kommen gleich noch mehr. Von der anderen Seite.
Kommt, hopp.
Und nochmal.
Du hast da vorgestanden und die dirigiert sozusagen.
Ja, die mögen schon Boote gerne. Also die kommen, wenn sie in der Nähe sind, schon mal vorbei und schwimmen dann so ein bisschen mit. Und wenn du die Kamera rausholst, bleiben sie auch ein bisschen länger. Weil die haben so ein bisschen geschätzt, dass wenn wir keine Kamera rausgehalten hatten, dann sind die irgendwie relativ schnell wieder abgezischt. Die sind schon so auf Touristen getrimmt. Und genau, dann auf Instagram siehst du noch was Schönes. In der zweiten Crew-Besetzung war nämlich ein Bäcker dabei. Und der hat dann auf dem Boot Brot gebacken. Er hatte ein bisschen Sauerteig mitgebracht. So ein Handgepäck hat? Was man so ein Handgepäck hat als Bäcker. Und die Martänker hat ja keinen Ofen im Gegensatz zu moderneren Booten. Das heißt, er hat sich vorher schlau gemacht, wie man Brot backen kann auf dem Herd. Und hat dann tatsächlich...
Auf dem Herd, wo es den es nicht gibt?
An den Herd gibt es einen Ofen, gibt es nicht.
Ach so, verstehe.
Und zwar hat er einen großen Topf genommen, da drin einen kleinen Topf gepackt, um den kleinen Topf Wasser. Und hat das sozusagen mit heißem Wasser Topf in Topf erstmal gebacken. Und dann war aber die Kruste nicht so richtig krustig und dann hat er die Kruste noch mal in der Bratpfanne quasi noch mal so ein bisschen angekrustet. Und dann, das war das geilste Brot, was wir in dem ganzen Trip gegessen haben, wirklich. Also Spanien, Portugal, Mittelmeerraum ist ja sowieso Brot jetzt nicht unbedingt die große Stärke. Auf Instagram sind jetzt nicht viel mehr Siegelfotos. Genau und das Brot war richtig geil. Dann haben wir noch Knoblauchbutter dazu gemacht und das war ein Traum.
Das ist spannend. Ich hab das irgendwie, als ich mal für meinen Wandertrip so nach Ideen gesucht hab, was ich so kochen kann, gibt's auch echt Leute, die irgendwelchen Krempel mit schleppen, um zu backen.
Es gibt auch Solaröfen, ne?
Ja, dann nicht mal in so einem Solarofen, sondern wirklich so was Ähnliches, wie du gesagt hast, mit den Topf in Pfanne und so weiter. Das ist echt krass. Da will ich auch noch mal Danke sagen an die Leute, die mir in der letzten Sendung ein paar Links reingeschmissen haben fürs Wandern. Die hab ich noch nicht alle durchgelesen, aber danke.
Da gab's richtig Debatte, ne? Ich war beeindruckt.
Ich auch. Ich hab noch nicht so viel Zeit gehabt und freu mich jetzt darauf, die durchzulesen, weil jetzt kommt der lange Winter und dann krieg ich mich für die nächste Saison vorbereiten.
Oh, gesagt grad noch einer, aber es stimmt. Lidl gibt's auf den kanarischen Inseln, in Portugal hab ich's nicht gesehen, und Lidl hat deutsches Brot. Also bei Lidl, auf Gran Canaria, gab's auch richtig geiles Brot. Sonst nirgendswo, aber da, ja. Und was wollte ich noch sagen? Eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen. Ich bereite mich auch noch mal weiter auf die nächste Saison vor. Und es gibt dafür einen YouTube-Kanal, der sehr inspirativ dafür ist. Und zwar heißt der SVD-Los. Ich such das gerade mal raus. Das sind so zwei Amerikaner, die auch vor mittlerweile sechs oder sieben Jahren gesagt haben, fuck it, Software Engineer ist gar nicht mal so geil. Ich kaufe mir jetzt ein Boot. Und der initiale Plan war, glaube ich, nur so ein bisschen umher zu segeln. Ups, jetzt spielt das hier. Und daraus sind dann aber sieben Jahre geworden und mittlerweile können die halt ihren Lebensunterhalt komplett damit finanzieren. Also die haben irgendwie 200.000 Subscriber und kriegen pro Video, was sie releasen, 11.000 Dollar über Patreon alleine. Und leben jetzt einfach komplett den Bootstraum. Und dieser YouTube-Kanal, der ist wirklich sehr anschaubar. Nur würde ich sagen, schaut ab Folge 60 oder 70. Weil die ersten Videos von denen sind so, wir sind zwei Amerikaner und wir sind jetzt ja so auf dem Boot. Und ist auch von der Produktion her eher schwierig. Aber so ab Folge 60, 70 wird die Qualität und der Content einfach grandios. Und jetzt haben sie eine neue Crew seit ein paar Wochen oder Monaten. Und haben offensichtlich explizit Leute gecastet, die Videoerfahrungen in irgendeiner Form haben, Schnitt und so weiter. Und die Production-Quality von deren Videos ist einfach grandios. Und das gucke ich jetzt auch regelmäßig, wie gesagt. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, dann ab Folge 60 oder so, irgendwo sind sie dann im indischen Ozean und fahren zu so einem Archipelago, wo niemand lebt. Und haben das da für einen Monat für sich ganz alleine. Und da kriegt man auf jeden Fall auch sehr gut Fernweh und Segellust und ja. Und nächstes Jahr werde ich ja versuchen, vielleicht auch mal selber dann zu segeln. Also nicht mehr mit zu segeln, sondern segeln zu lassen. Captain Huckel. Captain ist man erst, wenn man eine gewisse Crew unter sich hat.
Für uns bist du der Captain.
Also ich wollte gerade sagen, für Tim und mich bist du auf jeden Fall der Captain.
Sehr freundlich. Also ich werde versuchen, nächstes Jahr noch mal so einen Meilen-Turn zu machen und dann gleich den Ocean-Schein zu machen.
Jetzt weiß ich gerade, woran mich erinnert sein, dein Skipper-Shirt. So ein bisschen heimblödmäßig.
Was unfair.
Ist es, aber die Assoziation. Wie Captain Blau, der sieht ja nicht gerade aus.
Ne, da fehlt ihm das Bäuchlein. Aber Tim, das könntest du dann machen.
Ja, ja, wir sprechen uns noch.
Hast du nicht gesagt, du machst jetzt wieder Sport?
Ich mach Sport.
Für die Bikini-Figur.
Für die Bikini-Figur, ich muss bloß erstmal nochmal richtig...
Bikini shoppen....
in die Spur kommen.
Kannst du noch einen stricken.
Gut, anderes Thema.
Also gestrickte Bikinis, das fände ich...
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Schon eine Weile her, dass ich eingetragen habe. Ehrlich gesagt hab ich noch nie eingetragen.
Ich auch nicht, ich seh das aber immer aufploppen in diesen Strick-Communities, wie sie sich Unterwäsche und Bikinis und... Und wie heißt das andere? Badeanzüge stricken. Ja, das ist total komisch. Also ich kann mir nichts Furchtbareres vorstellen, aber wie es gefällt?
Ja, also ich meine, wenn ansonsten nichts juckt, kann man es ja so machen.
Ja, könnte man. Also nächstes Jahr dann vielleicht Freak Show segeln.
Das wäre doch mal was Schönes.
Aber dann im Mittelmeer, weil das auf jeden Fall entspannter ist.
Wir müssen nachher nochmal drüber reden, aber ich hab da gerade so einen interessanten Timeslot im Auge, wo vielleicht was geht.
Na toll, jetzt nehm ich meinen gesamten Jahresurlaub schon im Januar. Ach nee, stimmt nicht, das ist der von diesem Jahr, den ich im Januar nächstes Jahr nehme.
Dann gucken wir mal, was geht.
Alles klar.
So, gibt's noch irgendwas?
Diese ganzen Apps und so weiter. Wolltest du noch was sagen? Da haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen, das weiß ich. Es gibt da irgendwelche neuen...
Geil. Letty hat noch typische Segelverletzungen.
Ja, ich find das in der Tat spannend, wie andere Sport... Also ich sag jetzt einfach mal, dass auch Segel eine Sportart ist. Das kannst du mir gerne widersprechen.
Also wenn Regatta segeln, ist auf jeden Fall Sport.
Na, ich meine, du strengst dich halt schon extrem an. Und mich würde man wirklich interessieren, was sind so die typischen Segelverletzungen? Ich will es jetzt nicht durch Unfälle nennen, nicht, dass es so negativ rüberkommt.
Also harmlos ist, erst mal sich überall anstoßen. Schienbeine sind besonders gerne und schullose Füße, die an irgendwelchen Rädern, Haken, Schienen Aua! konstant hängen bleiben quasi. Also meine Schienbeine, wenn ihr die sehen würdet, da sind wirklich von oben bis unten so Markierungen von diversen Kontakten. Dann relativ üblich sind so Brandverletzungen von Seilen. Bin ich jetzt verschont worden. Ich hab mir hier eine Brandverletzung vom Lötkolben geholt, als ich die Lichter in Elisas Boot getauscht hab. Bin ich am Lötkolben hängen geblieben. Also das auf jeden Fall.
Gewöhnt man sich daran eigentlich mit den Seilen?
Es gibt da so eine gewisse Technik auch, dass einem nicht die Seile durchrutschen, wenn man die ganze Zeit aufpasst und es ordentlich macht, dann passiert es auch nicht. Und ansonsten ist wahrscheinlich das Horror-Szenario halt mit dem Kopf am Baum kleben bleiben. Das ist allerdings jetzt zum Beispiel bei der Matenka oder auch bei anderen Cruiserbooten in dieser Größe, da ist der Mast relativ weit oben. Das heißt, es ist nicht so...
Das ist selbst für den Hubschrauber unerreichbar.
Ansonsten sind die meisten Verletzungen, oder Verletzungen oder Wehwehchen, du stößt dir halt permanent Sachen an. Und gerade wenn das Boot so in extremer Lage ist oder fortgeschrittener Lage, sage ich mal, oder die ganze Zeit hin und her rollt und du musst halt runter auf Klo, dann den richtigen Halt im richtigen Moment zu finden, weil du siehst ja die Wellen nicht kommen unter Deck und du siehst auch nicht den Horizont und dann machst du gerade so einen Schritt und plötzlich liegst du am anderen Ende des Bootes und es gibt Leute, die sind aus dem Bett gefallen. Aber es ist alles nicht super dramatisch. Die schlimmsten Verletzungen, da musst du wirklich, also wie gesagt, mit dem Baum, das passiert auf kleineren Segelbooten gerne, wo der Baum relativ niedrig ist. Bei Rennen passiert das, weil die Leute alle in Hektik sind. Unser Skipper ist schon zweimal vom Mast gefallen, weil irgendwie die Seile gerissen sind, die ihn da festhalten sollten. Der hat schon Titan in der Wirbelsäule. Aber das ist keine übliche Verletzung. Das ist wirklich, habe ich zum ersten Mal gehört. Und er ist schon zweimal hinter sich. Na, alle guten Dinge sind drei. Auf der anderen Seite siehst du halt so Boote mit Familien, wo kleine Kids irgendwie an den Seilen Tarzan spielen und um irgendwie das ganze Boot rumwurbeln. Und du als einigermaßen erwachsener Mensch denkst dir so, ah, kann mal irgendwie diese Kinder festhalten. Aber die haben das schon so als komplett natürliches Habitat für sich erschlossen.
Boah, das ist wie Kinder beim Klettern zuzuschauen. Wo du denkst, alter, hallo, nicht machen.
Ja, und ansonsten hier diese ganzen Programme und Apps. Also das Einzige, was ich vielleicht noch erwähnen wollen würde, weil das kennt nicht jeder. Witzigerweise, ich hab im Flugzeug auf dem Hinflug neben so einem Typen gesessen und der war so ein bisschen bonzig angezogen. Und hat sich auch schon relativ laut stark beschwert, als die Klimaanlage nicht gleich ansprang und so. Und dachte mir, ah, unsympath. Und dann hab ich so während des Fluges nämlich so eine Windwettervorhersage aufgemacht und dann sprach er mich an und fragte mich, was denn das sei, weil er würde auch segeln. Und dann haben wir den Rest des Fluges über Segeln gesprochen. Und dann ging Ende des Fluges, ist unsere Freundschaft aber doch wieder zerbrochen, denn er hatte sich als Chef einer der Strategen bei VW geäußert, zu erkennen gegeben. Und das war nachdem ich ihm gesagt hatte, was ich so von den Großkonzernen und ihrer E-Strategie halte, als ich ihm das gesagt hatte. Und dann meinte er, ach, ist ja witzig, weil ich bin Strategie bei VW.
Danke für dieses Häufchen auf meinem Tisch.
Ja, das war aber auch das Ende des Fluges insofern. Ist alles gut verlaufen. Aber selbst er kannte diese tolle App nicht und das heißt Predict Wind. Da gibt es auch eine Website zu. Und die nehmen im Prinzip die Wettermodelle von allen, die sie kriegen können. Und machen noch eigene Berechnungen oben drauf. Und du kannst halt so Sachen sagen wie, ich möchte von Cádiz nach Madeira und mein Zeitrahmen ist das Startdatum und das Enddatum. Und ich könnte ein bisschen früher und ein bisschen später. Und dann kannst du sagen, sag mir mal in 6 oder 12 Stunden Intervallen die Route. Also angenommen wir fahren um 8 Uhr los. Angenommen wir fahren um 12 Uhr los. Angenommen wir fahren um 18 Uhr los. Weil der Wind ändert sich ja die ganze Zeit und es kann halt sein, dass du schneller bist auf der gesamten Strecke, wenn du später lossegelst. Und die machen halt diese ganzen Forecasts mit wann will ich da sein oder was ist die schnellste Route. Und die sagen dir echt alles so. Die Wellenhöhe, die Wellenperiode, der Maximalwind, der Minimalwind, der Durchschnittswind. Die Windrichtung, die du die meiste Zeit hast, plotet dir die Kurse anhand der optimalen Windrichtung für die Strecke und das alles.
Die haben ja echt coole Visualisierungen auch, die man sonst nur in irgendwelchen Forschungspapern in der Tat sieht.
Ich könnte das jetzt euch auf der Webseite leider, also es ist nicht ganz günstig, wenn man die coolen Features haben will, aber ich glaube die Free Version auf der Webseite, die kann auch schon diese Animation so ein bisschen.
Auf was läuft das? Auf iOS?
Das läuft im Web. Also die beste Version dieses Dienstes ist die Web-App und sie haben halt Rapper auf Mac und auf iOS und auf Android, aber wie das so mit Web-Rappern halt ist, nicht so geil und die Web-Version ist tatsächlich sehr viel cooler. Also da findet man auch alles und man kann wirklich viele Sachen einstellen, zum Beispiel auch zum eigenen Boot, wie groß das ist, wie schnell das maximal ist und was das für einen Tiefgang hat und das alles. Und ich kann euch das jetzt hier mal so zeigen, das wäre jetzt hier von einer... von den Azoren nach Madeira hatte ich hier irgendwie mal nachgeguckt und dann fahren dann halt hier so die Boote einzeln los, so die erste Gruppe und dann nach sechs Stunden die nächste Gruppe und dann siehst du auch welche anderen Kurse, die wir nehmen müssen, weil der Wind halt dann anders ist und da kann man dann wirklich ziemlich cool so seine Fahrt optimieren. Natürlich sind auch die Vorhersagen nicht 100 Prozent, aber hat doch in den meisten Fällen gestimmt.
Was heißt da, legelt man in irgendeine Richtung und dann kommt so, die Route hat sich geändert, schlagen sie nach links.
Im Prinzip könnte man das so machen, aber in der Realität machst du einen Kurs so in etwa und dann schaust du mal wohin der Wind dich führt. Was noch eine interessante App ist zum Wind gucken.
Aber es kann dann sozusagen sein, dass man so einen Eierkurs macht, der nicht so die direkte Linie ist, der dann aber eben trotzdem schneller ist, weil da eben dann der Wind von der richtigen Seite kommt.
Genau, weil es gibt hier auch, ich weiß nicht ob es eine coole Webseite davon gibt, windy.com würde es suggerieren, dass es das gibt. Hier kannst du den Windschatten um die Inseln herum sehen zum Beispiel. Genau, wenn du jetzt mal da so Richtung Kanaren gehst, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen unin, ja genau, und da so auf die Kanaren reinzoomst, dann siehst du halt auch, wie krass die Inseln, weil die halt ziemlich hoch sind durch ihre Vulkanenwipfeln, Windschatten werfen und das ist eben auch dann für die Routenberechnungen wirklich mal effizient von A nach B kommen willst. Also diesen Windschatten merkst du auch wirklich extrem krass. Ne, eben nicht. Also langsamer, das ist halt kein Wind, genau.
Also nicht Windschatten.
Nicht Windschatten, wie von du fährst hinterher, genau.
Sondern da ist dann kein Wind. Also hier willst du ja Wind haben und beim Fahrradfahren eben nicht.
Genau und da muss man schon sagen, dass sich da in den letzten Jahren noch so einiges getan hat, was so Wetter, Wind und Wellenvorhersage betrifft und auch die Visualisierungen dazu. Die sind schon ziemlich cool und sehr nützlich. Und wenn ihr wirklich diesen SVD-Los-Channel gucken würdet, dann seht ihr auch, die sind im indischen Ozean, haben teilweise wirklich echt krasse Bedingungen und wir benutzen diese Software die ganze Zeit, um sich sozusagen einigermaßen davor zu schützen. Ja, da sieht man auch wirklich dann die Hoch- und Tiefdruckgebiete, Wandern und so. Das ist ziemlich cool gemacht. Auch für die Kiteserver sicherlich vollen Interesse.
Auch so die Hurricanes hier kann man da sehr schön sehen. Hier noch die Maria ist ja hier noch am Zwirbeln, am Rumzwirbeln.
Aber das ist eben dann auch noch eine Sache beim Segeln, weil immer ganz viele Leute fragen so, und wart ihr mal in einem Sturm und so weiter und eigentlich ist man nie in einem Sturm, es sei denn man will das, weil die Vorhersage mittlerweile so gut ist, dass du, also gerade so eine fetten Tiefdruckgebiete oder sowas, siehst du einfach schon lange genug im Voraus, dass du weißt, da will ich jetzt nicht hin. Und gerade wenn man so im Mittelmeer oder so segelt, wo man wirklich dann jeden Tag fast in einem Hafen ist, da bleibt man dann im Zweifel einfach einen Tag länger im Hafen und fährt dann den nächsten Tag weiter. Wenn du jetzt mal unten an die Südspitze von Afrika guckst, da, also das Indische Ozean ist halt auch ein sehr tricky Gebiet, weil da kontinuierlich sozusagen von dem Südpol irgendwie die Tiefdruckgebiete hoch.
Von Afrika oder von Amerika?
Aber es ist bei allen Horns ein bisschen wild. Genau, jetzt ist gerade, jetzt kommen, also das eine ist am Gehen und das andere kommt von links wahrscheinlich dann demnächst wieder. Das ist immer so ein, die kommen dann ja in regelmäßigen Abständen quasi schon immer da lang gewirbelt und immer, wenn man oder wenn man da unten lang will, wird es halt tricky. Und gerade in Südamerika siehst du es jetzt gerade da, ist es sehr stark und da will man auch nicht unbedingt hin. Das heißt, die Weltenumsegler, die nehmen meistens die Kanalrouten, wenn sie es entspannt haben wollen. Und die Rekordsegler, die segeln um die Horner sozusagen.
Ja, ich hab das gesehen mit dem Hand gegen Koya, vor allem beim Panama-Kanal, weil da braucht man wohl eine Anzahl von Leuten, die auf dem Schiff dabei ist.
Krasse Projektion hier auch. Was ist denn das? Ist das diese Mercator, wo so oben alles so riesig wird, damit das alles auf der gleichen Höhe ist?
Immer Mercator war, glaube ich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall der Standard für die Seekarten.
Ja doch, es ist die Mercator, genau.
Hab ich mir gemerkt.
Krasser Typ, ey.
Weil Mercator ist ja auch die Seekartenprojektion.
Ja, da hätte ich jetzt auch genauso gut daneben liegen können.
Da gab's, da hab ich in meiner Vorlesung auch ein lustiges Video gefunden, warum jede Karte falsch ist und warum man eigentlich nie die richtige Karte bekommt. Also, das kann ich mal reinschmeißen. Das war ganz lustig gemacht. Mal gucken, wo meine Vorlesungsaufzeichnungen sind.
Das lässt sich irgendwie nichts optimieren. Irgendwas ist immer falsch, ne?
Und nicht mal die Kugel wäre ja akkurat, weil die Erde auch keine Kugel ist in dem Sinne.
Na ja, gut. Also, da kommst du mit Ellipsoid irgendwie hin. Und ehrlich gesagt, das Maß, in dem die Erde unrund ist, spielt da nicht mehr groß eine Rolle.
Was übrigens auch sehr interessant ist bei den Vulkaninseln, ist die Magnetic Deviation. Ah, das verwechsel ich jetzt immer. Entweder Deviation oder Variation. Ziemlich stark, also sieben Grad war es bei einer kanarischen Insel. Ich glaube, da war es bei Madeira. An einer der Ecken war auch auf der Karte so explizit Warning, Magnetic, und dann Anomalie. Manchmal bleibt es mir hier im Hals stecken. Genau, und dann siehst du eben wirklich, okay, hier brauchst du nicht auf den Kompass gucken. Alles huibou. Aber auch sieben Grad sind schon ganz ordentlich. Und der Kompass auf der Matenka, der hat, also ich verwechsel das immer, aber ich glaube, die Deviation ist das, was der Kompass falsch macht, weil irgendwie Metall in der Nähe ist oder was auch immer. Und die Variation ist das, was von der Erde sozusagen kommt, vom Magnetfeld. Und da war es dann so, dass sich beide genau ausgeglichen haben und der Kompass das erste Mal auf diesem Boot tatsächlich den GPS-Kurs entsprochen hat. Also das war auch ein Novum.
Also wir können ja einen Software-Übergang machen. Was sonst so? Ich meine, es ist ja ein bisschen was passiert, nachdem wir jetzt in der letzten Sendung diesen Fokus auf die...
Vielleicht, ich will hier nicht reinkrätschen, aber wir hatten das mit dem Basic Income noch. Das passt so ein bisschen zu Huckels Kanal, den er da hatte. Weil Huckel ja von den YouTubern erzählt hat, die versucht haben herauszufinden, wie man das Leben doch ein bisschen schöner leben kann.
Und es auch geschafft haben.
Und es vor allem auch geschafft haben, was ja echt cool ist. Ich habe gerade den, ich glaube nicht den aktuellen, den vorletzten Podcast von 99% Invisible gehört, der zu empfehlen ist, falls ihn noch keiner kennt, was man sich nicht vorstellen kann. Ja, das geht gar nicht. Und lief außerdem auch auf Planet Money, die haben darauf ebenfalls die Folge verlinkt, wo es um Finnland geht mit dem Projekt über ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen. Es ist ja nicht direkt, weil die Bedingung schon war, die Leute müssen arbeitslos sein, die sich dafür bewerben konnten. Wir haben irgendwie 2000 Leute randommäßig ausgesucht aus der Bevölkerung, die arbeitslos sind.
Ja gut, aber in dem Moment, wo sie da ausgesucht wurden, gab es keine weiteren Bedingungen, die sie erfüllen mussten und das Geld zu bekommen. Von daher ist es schon bedingungslos, bloß halt nicht für jedermann.
Genau, nicht für jedermann. Und was noch ein bisschen speziell auch an dem Ding in Finnland ist, das ist wohl eigentlich nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich. So rein von, ich glaube selbst von der Verfassung her nicht, mussten sie was ändern an der Verfassung von Finnland, weil das sonst nicht gegangen wäre mit dem Projekt. Das war irgendwie relativ spannend. Und das haben sie auch getan. Das kommt vor allem nicht von irgendeiner Organisation, sondern wie ich das mitbekommen hab, direkt selber, dass der Staat wirklich an solchen experimentellen Projekten arbeitet. Und nicht nur wohl an diesem Basic Income Projekt, sondern halt an mehreren Sachen. Das erwähnen die auch ganz kurz im Podcast.
Das heißt, sie probieren einfach mal verschiedene Modelle aus? Sie probieren Dinge aus.
Und was halt spannend ist, was Roman Mars da halt auch angemerkt hat, also 99% Invisible, Roman Mars ist ja auch ein Designer. Er hat auch immer so ein bisschen viel dieses Design-Denken.
Also Roman Mars ist der Macher von dem 99% Invisible Podcast, wenn ihr ihn nicht kennt. Das ist ein schön aufwendig gemachter Geschichten-aus-der-Welt-Erzähl-Podcast.
Dazu auch sehr zu empfehlen, sein Ted Talk über Flaggendesign. Das ist wunderschön. Wie schon einige Weihnachtsabende versüßt. Jedenfalls, was sie halt eben gesagt haben, dass es eben so sehr speziell ist in Finnland, dass es halt eben von der Regierung ausgeht. Und sie versuchen, ähnlich wie in einem Design-Prozess für ein Produkt, eben das Feedback der Nutzer wirklich mit einzubeziehen. Dass sie nicht von vornherein sagen, hier ist jetzt das Gesetz und es wird die Welt verbessern, sondern dass es eher so ein iterativer Prozess ist. Also er bezieht das sehr auf dieses Design-Denken und wie man im Design arbeitet. Aber ich mein, wenn du in einem iterativen Software-Projekt arbeitest, ist das ja, ich sag mal, ein ähnliches Teil, was ich sehr, sehr spannend finde. Das Einzige, was da so ein bisschen rauskam, ist, dass es halt nicht so richtig gut funktioniert. Und dass die Leute in Finnland das so ein bisschen kritisch sehen, die das ins Leben gerufen haben, ob das so ohne Weiteres funktionieren würde. Und was ich noch spannender fand, ist so ein bisschen versucht herauszufinden, warum so eine Projekte meistens scheitern. Da frag ich euch mal, was denkt ihr denn, wann das erste Projekt in den USA gestartet ist?
So war es jetzt.
Zum Basic Income.
Grundeinkommen.
Ende der 60er.
Ende der 70er. Nixon hat wohl eine Rede gehalten zu, es müsste man nochmal drüber nachdenken, wie das mit der Arbeit vonstatten gehen könnte. Das wusste ich auch nicht. Es war sehr spannend. Und warum an vielen Punkten das wohl gescheitert ist, dass man eine Debatte geführt hat, ohne konkrete Aussagen über dieses Verhalten zu finden, weil keine Datengrundlage da war. Man hat immer mit Spekulationen eine Debatte geführt. Und was sie unter anderem anbringen ist, dass es in den USA wohl so war, dass man angeblich in den Daten gesehen hat, bevor die Daten ausgewertet wurden, dass es ja zu zahlfielen Scheidungen gekommen ist. Das könnte man ja überhaupt nicht propagieren. Scheidungen. Scheidungen. Und warum ist das zur Scheidung gekommen? Weil Frauen auf einmal Geld hatten und gemerkt haben, yay, unabhängig, ich bin auf niemanden mehr angesehen.
Ich muss mit dem Scheißer nicht mehr zusammenhängen.
Ich kann endlich das machen, worauf ich Bock habe. Das konnte man natürlich dann nicht so präsentieren. Und bevor die Daten überhaupt ausgewertet haben, haben sie es halt schon klein geredet. Dieses gesamte Basic Income Projekt.
Die hatten alle Angst, dass ihre Haushaltskräfte davonlaufen.
Genau. Der Podcast ist echt sehr, sehr spannend. Auf ganz vielen Ebenen, weil sie auch am Schluss nochmal versuchen zu schauen, was heißt das eigentlich so generell für die Gesellschaft. Viele fangen dieses Basic Income Projekt ja damit an, zu sagen, was wäre, wenn Leute einfach die Möglichkeit haben, alles zu machen, was sie können, wenn sie ein Grundeinkommen haben. Und in Finnland war das Herangehen, wirklich nur von Arbeitslosen auszugehen. Also in Deutschland gibt es ja auch irgendwie Projekte, wo man jetzt nicht arbeitslos sein muss. Und in Finnland war wirklich die Idee, es mit Arbeitslosen auszuprobieren, um zu schauen, ob sich die Arbeitslosenquote verändert. Also ob das sich positiv auswirkt darauf, dass Leute auch wieder in den Arbeitsmarkt reinkommen, neue Ideen entwickeln. Weil es in Finnland wohl auch nicht geht, dass wenn man arbeitslos ist, nebenbei so Minijobs haben kann. Das funktioniert wohl irgendwie nicht. Also es war auf jeden Fall ein sehr spannender Podcast über dieses gesamte, wie kann man leben, wie kann man das zu seinem Lebensmittelpunkt machen, was man schön findet.
Ich meine, die auf dem Boot zum Beispiel, die haben immer noch viel Arbeit, weil die rennen die ganze Zeit mit den Kameras umher. Die müssen ja irgendwie, um ihre 11.000 pro Video zu kriegen, die sitzen da wahrscheinlich auch mal Tage an so einem Video, wenn du die Produktionsqualität von denen siehst. Also ich stelle mir schon vor, dass die viel Zeit auch damit verbringen, Videos zu machen. Also es ist ja immer noch, wenn einem das Spaß macht, auf einem Segelboot im Indischen Ozean, auf einem einsamen Archipelago.
Ja vor allem macht es ja nicht nur denen Spaß. Also man macht ja dann auf einmal Dinge, die für andere auch gut sind. Die sonst sich aber vielleicht nicht rechnen würden oder überhaupt gar nicht erst so zum Start kommen und die dann so ein eigenes Leben entwickeln und so weiter. Also ich bin ja im Prinzip auch ein Produkt des Grundeinkommens. Ich hab mein Grundeinkommen halt nur irgendwie durch meine Hörer ermöglicht. Als ich hier gestartet bin, 2009 ging das ja eigentlich erst. Also ich hab zwar Jahre vorher gepodcast, aber da war das ja quasi auch so, so wie die ersten Videos hier von den Segelvögeln, da hab ich halt irgendwie so meine Podcasts in die Welt geschmissen, wie es mir gefiel. Aber es war ja alles noch nicht so, dass ich jetzt da, das war jetzt sagen wir mal noch nicht Beruf oder so. Es war halt einfach, was ich gemacht hab. Und dann stand ich halt so ein bisschen, und dann hab ich halt irgendwie gemerkt, naja, was machst du jetzt? Irgendwas musste ich, das hatte sich irgendwie alles geändert. Und dann dachte ich mir so, wie gehste da jetzt eigentlich ran? Also was ist jetzt hier eigentlich das eigentliche Ziel? Und wie könnte sich das tragen? Also ich wollte das halt machen und hab dann halt überlegt, welcher Modus könnte das tragen? Und dachte mir so, ja, weil ich hatte, ich hatte so diesen allerersten kleinen Auftrag damals, hab ich so für so eine Interviewreihe gemacht, für die Aktion Mensch. Das wär jetzt für sich genommen noch nicht genug Geld gewesen, um irgendwie alles zu tragen. Aber es war so ein, da ging so die Tür auf und hat gesagt so, vielleicht könnte man damit ja auch Geld verdienen. In einem Maße, dass es vielleicht auch irgendwas trägt. Dann war für mich aber sofort die Frage, okay, wie verhält sich jetzt dieses für andere Arbeiten zu für mich Arbeiten? Ist jetzt irgendwie mein Ziel, anderer Leute Wort zu reden, quasi? Oder bleib ich eigentlich bei meinem Wort, weil deswegen hab ich das ja alles gemacht. Und da ich ja durch dieses andere Ereignis, das mir mal der Rechner geklaut wurde, auf der ersten Republika und dann hab ich halt mal gesagt, na okay, da hatten sich ja schon immer mal ein paar Leute wegen Spenden gemeldet und so. Wollte ich immer nicht, aber jetzt wäre vielleicht mal so eine Gelegenheit. Und dann war die Response halt gleich so, dass ich gemerkt hab, so, oh, alles klar, das scheint irgendjemand auch was zu geben. Dann kann man das ja vielleicht mal so beibehalten und dann hab ich's ja noch mal probiert, dann 2009, gleich gemerkt so, okay, alles klar, hier passiert was und vielleicht kann ich das ja auch in einem ganz anderen Modus fahren. Und seitdem fahr ich das eigentlich so in diesem Modus. Das heißt so, die Spenden sind so mein Grundeinkommen und das ist so ein unfassbarer Peace of Mind. Das ist so ein Lebensluxus, für den ich extrem dankbar bin und der einen halt auch... Ich kann mich immer hier hinsetzen, in so einer Zen-Haltung hier in der Metaebene sozusagen einfach nichts tun. Einfach so dieses ich gucke ins Netz oder keine Ahnung, dreht Däumchen oder denkt drei Tage darüber nach, wie ich irgendwie meine Löcher in diesen Tisch reinbohre, um diesen Kabelsalat endlich mal in den Griff zu kriegen. Und merke aber, dass das genauso die kreativen Phasen sind, aus denen dann auch Neues entsteht. Weil erst, wenn man sich selber so zurücknehmen kann und erst, wenn man keinem Druck hinterherläuft. So ist es ja auch bei Urlaub. Ich glaube, deswegen reden wir auch so ein bisschen. Dieses Gefühl da, wo du meinst, du allein und die Welt und so weiter. Man kommt halt zurück und man weiß danach, was einen eigentlich wirklich ruft.
Das finde ich genau das Wichtige.
Wenn man das halt irgendwie mehr oder weniger permanent hat, zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße, eben dieses Grundeinkommen, dann orientiert man sich halt für seine Einkommenswahl oder was auch immer anders. Manche sagen halt, dieses Grundeinkommen, das ist alles, was ich brauche, ich bin irgendwie Asket und mehr brauche ich nicht. Und jetzt tue ich einfach nur noch gute Sachen für, keine Ahnung, mich oder andere. Wobei selbst wenn man es nur für sich tut, tut man es damit eigentlich auch schon für andere, weil man geht den anderen ein bisschen aufs Schwein.
Das sei denn, investiert das alles in Koks und jeder andere läuft ab und weg.
Das ist eine andere Debatte so. Aber bei so Klinkenputzern denke ich mir halt auch manchmal, neulich klingelte hier wieder an der Tür. Abgesehen von diesen bundestagspotenziellen Bundestagsaspiranten, die so vorbeikamen und mich irgendwie überzeugen wollten. Was war das? Der wollte irgendwelche Spenden einsammeln für irgendeine Organisation. War das der Aspie? Ach, der war dann auch... Okay, verstehe. Man merkte so richtig, wie jung war der? Paarundzwanzig? Keine Ahnung. Der war nicht alt. Der war so völlig aufgeblasen in dieser Rolle. Und laberte halt so seine Sprüche runter und tat mir irgendwie in dem Moment ein bisschen leid. Ich dachte mir nur so, ey, scheiße, dass dir noch nichts Schöneres über den Weg gelaufen ist als jetzt die Nummer. Weil ich merke, wie du leidest, nur du merkst es noch nicht. Und ich meinte dann nur so, ne, alter, vergiss es so. Aber, ja, das war ein bisschen traurig. Und das ist auch das, als diese Debatte ums Grundeinkommen in Deutschland losging, schon eine Weile her, ne? Also, gute Frage, wann die losging, die mag sicherlich schon ein paar Mal losgegangen sein, aber ich kann mich erinnern, dass wir so in unserer, in unserem Twitter-Versum und in der Blogosphere, hieß das ja damals, genau, in der Blogosphäre, ich weiß gar nicht, warum das so ein Thema war damals. Ich hab da irgendwann mal drüber geblockt. Da muss ich das nochmal nachschlagen. Und ich blogge ja jetzt nicht, also damals hab ich noch öfter geblockt.
War eine schöne Zeit mit diesen Bloggen.
Genau. 2009, siehst du mal, das war nämlich genau in dem Jahr wieder hier. Kann ich mal den Link, mal einen Chat reinwerfen. So hab ich so mal so aus dem Bauch heraus argumentiert, warum das meiner Meinung nach einfach eine gute Idee ist. Weil ich find's halt schwierig, die ganze Debatte läuft immer, wenn man gerade so mit Leuten, die im Steuersystem drin sind, also Leute, die in irgendeiner Form in dem, wie es jetzt gerade ist, drin sind. Da kriegst du schnell so einen, kann nicht funktionieren, weil und bedenke doch das und ich kenn doch die Realität und so. Und mich hat das bisher selten überzeugt, weil ich mir denke, dass genau diese Realität sich dadurch auch schnell ändern kann.
Klar, aber das ist halt so ein Henne-Ei-Problem. Also wenn du es dann erstmal eingeführt hast, kannst du halt auch nicht so sofort schnell wieder zurück oder raus, falls es sich doch irgendwie rausstellt.
Aber deswegen ist das Finland-Projekt vielleicht genau das Richtige. Einfach mal nicht von vorne rein zu sagen, jo, das ist es, sondern wirklich mal so iterativ und reflektierend über so eine großen Probleme einfach mal nachzudenken. Also ich meine, wann ist das in der Softwareentwicklung gewesen, dass man sich dachte, dieses Waterfall-Modell für Softwareentwicklung ist einfach mal nicht so geil. Ich meine, das ist dasselbe Prinzip wie in diesem Regierungsfu. Es ist halt nicht so geil, wenn man alles nur so häppchenweise und so träge vor sich hinschiebt, sondern, ich weiß nicht, einfach mal ein bisschen modern und treibend.
Es gibt ja hier diese Grundeinkommensverlosung. Aber die ist ja dann immer nur für ein Jahr. Da hab ich jetzt ehrlicherweise noch nicht so nachrecherchiert, was denn so deren Erkenntnisse sind oder ob sie die überhaupt publizieren oder was da eigentlich so der Modus ist oder von Leuten, die das da heißen.
Ich kenne die Jungs, das ist doch der Pirat, der da noch mit dabei ist.
Nee, weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf. Ich könnte in meine Mail gucken.
Mein Grundeinkommen ist das?
Ja, ich glaube ja. Also das wäre sicherlich mal interessant, wenn Leute, die das sozusagen dann jahrelang bekommen haben, mal berichten.
Ja, das stimmt. Die größte Sorge ist, glaube ich, was halt immer so rankommt, ist dieses, ja dann kündigen Leute ihren Job. Ja, ist doch geil, dann denken sie vielleicht auch mal ein paar Monate drüber nach, was sie eigentlich wirklich machen wollen. Ich sehe das halt so bei einigen, so in diesem näheren Verwandtschaftsdunst, Gedöns, dieses, ich studiere jetzt das und das. Ja geil, dann was willst du mal machen? Ah naja, naja, ja, kommt zum Punkt. Hast du dir noch immer keine Gedanken darüber gemacht? Mein Gott. Also ich finde das halt irgendwie komisch, wenn man sich nicht so wenigstens eine Idee hat, was man machen will, vielleicht durch einen Hobby, was man hat, ne?
Ja, du, aber das ist nicht so einfach. Also ich meine, letztens hat jemand bei so einer Open Mic kommen, wo dann so die Experts immer so die Berlinspäschen machen und sich über alle Sachen, die jetzt für sie besonders witzig in Berlin sind, amüsieren, meinte der, dass es in Berlin keine Jobs gebe. Also entweder man arbeitet bei einem Start-up oder in einer Burger-Bude und ansonsten gibt es einfach keine Jobs irgendwie und hat so über diesen Mythos hier in Berlin geil und Job und so ein bisschen gesprochen. Und im Prinzip ist das schon richtig. Also wenn man programmieren kann, kriegst du in Berlin ohne Probleme einen Job. Wenn du Burger braten kannst, wahrscheinlich auch. Aber zum Beispiel Grafikdesigner oder sowas, total der Höllenort, weil jeder Arsch und sein Bruder oder Schwester herkommt, um als Grafikdesigner irgendwo zu arbeiten oder als Künstler wie auch immer. Ansonsten sind alle anderen Jobs eher Mangelware, Industrie oder sowas gibt es hier auch nicht groß. Insofern konnte ich diese kleine Anekdote ganz gut nachvollziehen. Insofern kann ich auch gut verstehen, dass es total viele tolle Unis und Studienfächer gibt, noch und nöcher, aber die wenigsten führen dann auch zu...
Einem Job in Berlin, das ist lustig. Ich hab das bei Freunden, dass sie Maschbauer sind. Und hast du halt in Berlin einfach nicht. Also hast du auch noch Rolls Royce, glaube ich, die hier unten irgendwo... Was machen die doch gleich? Irgendwas für einen Flugbereich.
Flugzeug, Triebwerke.
Genau. Das stimmt schon, dass es in Berlin alles so ein bisschen komisch ist an einigen Stellen. Das stimmt schon. Ja, aber ich meine so dieses... Dann sind sie aber meistens ja schon immerhin... Haben sie was studiert, was sie vielleicht geil finden? Und nicht so ins Blaue halt nur so... Ja, heute studiere ich BWL, morgen studiere ich Tanzen.
Also ich finde das ja jetzt nicht grundsätzlich schlecht, wenn Leute was studieren, ohne da jetzt gleich so eine Berufswunsch mit zu verbinden. Weil das ist meiner Meinung nach... Ich finde es... Eigentlich finde ich es sogar besser, weil Studium soll ja nun eigentlich auch sein, freier Entfaltung und man lernt halt irgendwie Dinge. Und du lernst halt irgendwie fünf oder zehn Sachen da im Leben und drei davon vielleicht ein bisschen intensiver. Und irgendwann später merkst du eigentlich erst, wie du all diese ganzen Fähigkeiten in irgendetwas anderem kombinieren kannst, was so vorher noch gar keinen Namen gehabt hat oder wofür es einfach auch noch gar nicht die Zeit noch nicht für gekommen war. Was weiß ich hier, so Podcasting irgendwie. Ich hab früher schon geredet, ich hab viel mit Computern gemacht und die fand irgendwie Lehren ganz interessant. Aber dass das dann halt mal in so einer Rolle zusammenfallen würde, stand halt auf keinem Zettel. Also, wir kommen auch glaube ich ein bisschen ab, weil ich denke, das Grundeinkommen ist jetzt nicht so sehr eine Frage mit Jobs. Und ich meine, wenn die, da bist du glaube ich jetzt ausgeschert, so dieses, ja dann kündigen die Leute ihren Job. Auf der anderen Seite beklagen ja mal alle, dass es nicht genug Jobs gibt, dann wird ja gerade einer frei. Das ist doch okay, oder? So und davon ganz abgesehen, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, so eine der, haben wir mal eine Weile mit der Argumentation, der Befürworter ein bisschen mehr beschäftigt. Und was halt so ein Punkt ist, ist, dass wenn man sich heutzutage anschaut, wo Leute Arbeit reinstecken, ja, dann ist halt nur ein Teil, ein kleiner Teil davon tatsächlich bezahlter Arbeit. Was alles in Haushalt für Familie, Kindererziehung etc. gemacht wird, was in freiwilliger ehrenamtlicher Tätigkeit gemacht wird. Wenn du das einfach mal summierst, das habe ich jetzt nicht getan, irgendjemand wird sicherlich so eine Rechnung mal aufgemacht haben, die bestimmt auch ihre Fehler hat, aber das ist im Verhältnis zur freien Wirtschaft, wo auch Gehälter gezahlt werden für Dinge. Einen riesen Anteil, ob es mehr ist oder weniger, keine Ahnung, aber das sind nennenswert und das sind halt auch alles Tätigkeiten, die uns allen zugutekommen. Es ist gut, wenn Leute Zeit haben, ihre Kinder zu betreuen, ihnen Zeit zu geben und einfach da zu sein. Und wenn es nur auf dem Spielplatz rumhängen ist oder Hausaufgaben helfen oder keine Ahnung, ob für Ideen kommen oder in den Urlaub fahren. Das ist alles Quality Time und zwar nicht nur für die Leute selbst, sondern da kommen halt entspannter Kinder irgendwann in diese Gesellschaft so und nichts nervt halt mehr als irgendwie unentspannte Kinder, oder? Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt so unentspannter sind, vielleicht in einem anderen Maße, aber es gibt halt Kinder, die einfach auch unter ihrer Kindheit leiden, weil einfach niemand Zeit für sie hat und das kann man dann auch vielleicht den Eltern nicht vorwerfen, weil die dann halt genau in diesem Rausch mit, ich muss Geld verdienen, ich muss 10-12 Stunden am Tag arbeiten und bin dann halt auch nicht da und das ist ja auch alles so eine Spirale. Und da finde ich jetzt halt das Grundeinkommen etwas, was das eben löst oder lösen kann, potentiell lösen kann, indem man einfach die Leute frei macht und sagt, du wirst mit deiner Zeit zwangsläufig Dinge tun, die gut sind, nicht nur für dich, sondern eigentlich für alle. So und wenn potentiell jeder eben diese Basis hat, dann können all diese Leute, die einfach auch keinen Bock haben auf diesen Casper-Kram. Ich meine, haben wir auch schon ein paar mal gehabt, ich bin da irgendwie mittlerweile so weit von weg, ich kann einfach auf dieses Business Casper de Theater, das ist mir einfach zu bekloppt.
Da kommt mein Pickel von.
Das ist ein Tanz, der da getanzt wird, den will ich auch gar nicht lernen, weil das ist mir einfach zu affig. Natürlich gibt es einen nennenswerten Teil der Wirtschaft, der irgendwie wichtige Dinge produziert und Sachen macht und Produkte macht, die ich gerne haben will. Alles super, das kann man ja auch alles tun, aber viel ist halt auch wirklich, wo man sich denkt, muss es das jetzt auch geben, diese ganze Klinkenputzerei und das sind halt irgendwie Jobs, wo die Leute auch nicht glücklich werden und da kann das Grundeinkommen dann halt einfach auch die Leute rausnehmen und sagen, willst du jetzt irgendwie 10 Stunden nicht von irgendwelchen Leuten anschreien lassen oder startest du erstmal nur mit der Hälfte der Kohle, aber hast einfach diesen Stress und kriegst einfach als Geschenk schon mal Zeit, die du irgendwie produktiv umsetzen kannst, worin du dann vielleicht Dinge lernst, Zeit hast, überhaupt zu lernen und nicht nur Quatsch erzählt zu bekommen, den du dann ausführen musst und daraus dann eben auch neue Kreativität Und wie du diese Intuitivität entfalten kannst.
Das ist glaube ich das, was ich meine mit, dann hast du halt endlich mal Zeit darüber nachzudenken. Also viele hängen halt in diesem Trott einfach drin, dieses ich muss jetzt zur Arbeit, ich muss jetzt, und ich kann nicht einfach so kündigen, weil ich muss noch das und das und das bezahlen. Und einfach mal so dieses kündigen können und sagen können, nee, jetzt denke ich einfach mal zwei Monate drüber nach und hab eben Zeit für Kinder und alles und drum und dran.
Aber ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch darauf hinweisen, dass jetzt hier in diesem Kreis klingt das total alles fantastisch und wunderbar. Und ich bin mir auch sicher, dass jeder Einzelne von uns irgendwie mit solcher Zeit irgendwas Sinnvolles anfangen würde. Aber ich kenne auch genug Gegenbeispiele, wo ich auch schon eine Vorstellung hätte, was die mit ihrer vielen Zeit machen würden. Wahrscheinlich Computerspiele spielen und kiffen. Also nicht von einem selbst auf andere schließen, das ist schon ein differenzierteres Feld. Nichtsdestotrotz würde ich auch im Zweifel eher den Versuch mal starten und gucken, wohin die Reise führt. Aber trotz alledem, also nur weil wir jetzt hier schon im Hinterkopf irgendwie vor Ideen sprühen, wie wir das dann alles so ausgestalten würden, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das auf die Mehrheit der Leute auch wirklich dann so zutrifft.
Aber dein Umfeld würde sich ja auch ändern. Derzeit machst du das vielleicht auch in Reaktionen und als Frust auf irgendwie die sonstige Situation, weil du keinen Bock hast da mit dem anderen Marsch mitzumarschieren. Aber wenn du dann um dich herum erstmal alle aufblühen siehst und irgendwie verrückte Sachen machen, willste dann wirklich noch vor deiner Konsole rumhängen?
Nee, dann würdest du dir denken, geil, was die alles machen. Also ich glaub halt auch, dass das echt nochmal so ein bisschen ein bisschen rauskommt. Also eine meiner besten Freundinnen ist Logopädin. Und der trägt sich schon gefühlt seit Jahren einen Arsch, dass sie halt endlich mal ihre eigene Praxis aufmachen soll. Aber ich glaube, da ist so ein bisschen auch sich nicht trauen und manchmal auch so ein bisschen Komfort. Und sie wäre für mich so ein Kandidat, wo ich mir denke, wenn du halt einfach mal die Zeit hättest zu sagen, ich kündige jetzt, hab dann irgendwie trotzdem meinen Gehalt, dann würde die das halt endlich mal machen. Also das ist halt wirklich so ein, wo ich schon seit Jahren so im Schied-Modus bin bei ihr. Ich halt schon denke so, das würde echt super mal...
Wobei aber, was ist das, Logo-Pädel?
Logopädel ist das mit dem Sprechen.
Okay, die brauchen dann auch kein Equipment zum Beispiel. Weil, also nicht so teures wie zum Beispiel Zahnärzte oder so.
Nicht wie Zahnärzte, nicht wie irgendwie bildgebende Verfahren. Nee, nee, das geht ganz einfach. Also zum Beispiel Tims Sprechproblem sind ja auch teilweise Sachen, die du durch komisch atmen, also therapiert bekommst. Genau so, Hecheln und Stäbchen.
Kann ja zum Geburtsvorbereitungskurs gehen.
Also wenn das das ist, was dich glücklich macht, Tim.
Das will ich jetzt so nicht sagen, aber da muss man auf jeden Fall viel hecheln.
Nee, ich bin auch froh drüber, auch nicht gesagt, aber danke, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Wollen wir noch mal von vorne anfangen?
Wir kommen noch mal rein.
Ich schmeiß doch noch mal die Zeitmaschine an.
Ich guck mal in die Mailbox, bestimmt schon wieder ein neues Video ist nie angekommen, so wie das hier gerade klingelt.
Okay, also, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder eine Menge von Kommentaren bekommen. Die einen werden kreativ beitragen, andere werden uns ausführlich darlegen, warum das ja alles nicht funktionieren kann. Wegen die anderen Länder machen es ja auch nicht. Und dann wollen ja alle zu uns, was sowieso schon alle wollen. Egal, und wenn schon, und immer noch besser, als wenn keiner zu uns wollen würde.
Naja, und Staatsbürger wird man jetzt auch nicht so über Nacht in Deutschland.
Also, das wird wieder mit den neuen Menschen, die hierher kommen, wollen wir mal was an diesem Scheiß-Essens-Problem in Deutschland.
Okay, die Debatte wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gerade nicht aufmachen. Das sind halt so wiederkehrende Argumentationsgänge. Wo auch sicherlich was dran ist. Und dann irgendwie die ganzen Leute, die in Frage stellen, dass es sozusagen überhaupt realistisch ist, das Steuersystem jemals so umzubauen, dass es dann eben auch sinnvoll ist. Dann gibt es natürlich noch diese verschiedensten Modelle. Weil wir reden jetzt von Grundeinkommen. Das ist ja so eine grundsätzliche Idee. Da gibt es ja dann die irgendwie mit ihren umsatzsteuerfinanzierten Modellen, einkommensteuerfinanzierten Modellen und anderen Modellen, die es dann auch alles gibt. Da gibt es viel. Mir geht es jetzt gerade um die grundsätzliche Debatte, die eigentlich auch eine ethisch-moralische Debatte ist, die auch einfach nicht akzeptiert, dass es jetzt so ein Primat von Wirtschaft und Arbeit gibt. Weil ich denke, andere Modelle sind vorstellbar. Ob wir die jetzt schon in den Experimenten da schon scharf genug definiert bekommen, keine Ahnung, nur es fehlt einfach die Experimentierbereitschaft. Es fehlt einfach überhaupt mal dieses, was wäre wenn. Was wäre wenn, wenn du jetzt eine 3000-Seelen-Gemeinde in Deutschland nimmst und da einfach mal so lange Geld reinpumst, bis die alle Gigabit-Internet haben. Was würde dann wohl passieren mit dieser Stadt, wenn du da überall Gigabit-Internet reinmachst und dann noch ein Grundeinkommen oben drauf. Das gucken wir uns einfach mal fünf Jahre lang an und dann sind wir schlauer. Hat nicht so viel gekostet, weil ist einfach mal überschaubar, was alles so an Geld weggeworfen wird. Geht schon. Und das wären so die Experimente, die ich gerne mal sehen würde. Aber immer so dieses so, nein, das dürfen wir gar nicht auch erst nur andenken, weil, bla. Und jetzt haben wir ja gerade, wo wir jetzt gerade irgendwie, kriegen wir vielleicht langsam in den Bogen in Richtung Technologie, da gab es auch jetzt gerade hier so eine geile Meldung bei Golem, ne, habe ich hier noch nicht in der Liste. Da könntest du noch mal schauen. Telekom gibt zu, dass sie irgendwie im Hintertreffen sind mit Glasfaser. Hier, genau. Das ist Telekom wegen fehlendem FTTH, also Fiber to the Home, massiv unter Druck. Durch ihren radikalen Vectoring-Kurs verliert die Telekom in München, Hamburg und Köln immer mehr Kunden an die Glasfaserbetreiber der Stadtwerke. Daher musste auch der Deutschlandchef gehen.
Ja, no shit! Hallo?
Da reden wir jetzt seit Jahren davon. Und dieses Ganze... Ja, nein, und wir haben doch Kupfer, da geht doch bestimmt auch Licht durch.
Guck mal, wir haben hier eine Kerze, damit kann man auch im Dumpf sitzen.
Und jetzt genau diese Diesel-Debatte, da war ich dann neulich irgendwie bei VW. Hab mir einfach mal ein paar Überlegungen, weil meine Karre fällt auseinander, und ich weiß jetzt echt nicht, geht jetzt Elektro oder geht nicht. Egal, kam dann irgendwie mit diesem VW-Menschen in einem Gespräch, du kannst nicht bei VW stehen und irgendwann nicht über Diesel reden. Weil da war dann halt irgendwie auch wieder so ein Caravan, meist du, gibst du halt auch ein Benzin? Er so, nein, und das ist ja hier Wohnmobil, und sie wollen ja auch Reichweite haben und bla. Reichweite ist ja schön gut, aber ich damit nicht mehr nach Hause komme irgendwie.
Ist halt nicht so geil.
Ja, dann natürlich kommen sie damit nach Hause. Jetzt vielleicht schon noch so, aber wenn dann erstmal hier die Verbote kamen und man merkte so richtig, wie sich so ein Innendruck aufbaute bei ihm. Also er war schon so richtig so, er wusste genau, was jetzt kommt. Er hat diese Debatte wahrscheinlich schon zehnmal am Tag. Und wurde schon so richtig, lief rot an.
Ja, weil wir halt so, höhö, Diesel irgendwie, es zählt uns hier halt vom Pferd und eigentlich wollen wir sowieso keine Verbrenner.
Weil so, ja, kann ja alles kommen, so.
Und er flusste sich auf und meinte dann irgendwann so, das deutsche Volk wird sich nicht enteignen lassen. Das war so Freeze-Moment, so dieses so, oh man, ey, müsst ihr unter Druck stehen.
Ach Gott, also was soll ich den Leuten noch sagen? Ich hab das dann irgendwie unkommentiert, ich hab den einfach sitzen lassen und dachten mir so, ich guck mir jetzt was anderes an. Also, das ist einfach dieses, man, das, warum können wir nicht einfach mal wieder in die Zukunft denken? Warum können wir nicht einfach mal die Dinge mal testen, ausprobieren, gewähren lassen, parallel einfach mal?
Aber das mit der Gemeinde ist halt auch wieder gefährlich. Dann gibst du dir den 5-Jahren-Grundeinkommen, ne? Und dann sagst du, ja, stellt sich raus, doch nicht so eine gute Idee, sorry Leute, ihr habt jetzt 5 Jahre hier rumgedudelt, ihr müsst euch jetzt wieder einen Job suchen.
Ja, machst eine Übergangsphase, 90, 80, 70 Prozent. Verstehst du, geht alles. Wenn man das will, geht das auch. Dieses Ganze geht nicht, weil...
Nee, geht nicht, gibt's nicht. Alles geht.
Das ist einfach eine Frage der Kreativität und der Bereitschaft. Und mir kann einfach keiner erzählen, dass es alles nicht geht. Klar geht das. Man muss das auch wollen.
Der Podcast Papst hat gesprochen.
Lass uns lieber über Apple reden.
Übrigens, der VW-Strategie-Typie, der war natürlich auch, der hatte auch nicht so eine wirklich einsichtige Schiene. Das war das Grundthema.
Die kriegen das volles Brett eingehämmert. Die müssen jetzt noch drei Jahre lang das Lied des Diesels singen, bevor sie dann irgendwie das Loblied aufheben. Jetzt haben wir auch Elektroautos, das ist auch geil. Ist doch vollkommen klar.
Und auch dieses Too-Big-To-Fail ist halt einfach Grundmentalität.
Ja, in Deutschland stimmt das wahrscheinlich auch, aber in China hab ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Der hatte einen interessanten Punkt, über den ich noch nicht so drüber nachgedacht hatte, wo er meinte, auch in diesem Zuge seiner Ausführung zu Big-To-Fail, also dass jetzt so Firmen wie Tesla, die könnten halt nicht das Gleiche leisten jetzt, wie so ein Konzern wie VW. Also ja, was denn? Naja, so Service-Netzwerke, so ein Auto geht ja nicht nur in eine Werkstatt, weil eine neue Firmware eingespielt werden muss, sondern weil jemand einen Unfall hatte und repariert werden muss und so. Eine, in Berlin. Die haben ja halt keine Werkstatt oder Servicezentren oder sowas.
Angebot und Nachfrage. Die Karten gehen ja auch nicht so auf kaputt, weil es ja nicht so viel drin ist.
Naja, er meinte halt durchaus berechtigt, dass jetzt die größten, also die meisten Reparaturen, die sie machen, ist jetzt nicht, weil die Autos von sich kaputt gehen, sondern weil Leute Unfälle haben. Also, das ist auf jeden Fall ein signifikanter Teil der Werkstatt arbeiten.
Das soll unmöglich sein. Ein Kotflügel vom Tesla zu reparieren.
Naja, erstens ist natürlich schonmal die Grundvoraussetzung, die das nicht jeder Tesla haben wird in näherer Zukunft. Roddy wartet auf einen Tesla, wie, zwei Jahre oder so. Naja, wie auch immer. Das hat er halt noch nicht auf jeden Fall. Kann auch noch ein bisschen dauern. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass du sofort in den Laden gehen könntest, ohne einen zu kaufen. Selbst wenn ganz Deutschland einen haben wollen würde, wäre das erst auch in drei Jahren wahrscheinlich der Fall. Und dann, ja, wenn sie dann mit skaliert wären, hätten sie wahrscheinlich auch überall ihre Werkstätten, aber...
Ja, aber das gelingt doch anderen Marken, die nicht so viele Autos verkaufen wie VW auch, sich da ein entsprechendes Reparaturnetz hinzustellen. Das ist alles Quatsch. Und ich meine, wenn die erstmal nicht mehr so viele Teile verkaufen und Diesel und so weiter, ich meine, wenn ich Kfz-Mechaniker wäre, ich würde mir ja heute schon mal ganz schnell überlegen, wie viele Jahre ich noch auf der Uhr habe. Klar, wenn du jetzt in zehn Jahren Rente gehst, dann gibt es noch genug rumzudieseln. Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie in der Ausbildung bist, ich meine, da tust du dir doch nicht diesen Gas-Gemisch-Klimbim an, sondern dann machst du mal schnell noch mal deine Elektro-Ausbildung.
Du, also wir müssen da auch gar nicht darüber diskutieren. Ich gebe ja nur wieder, was der Herr da meinte.
Er meinte, das hätte dich jetzt irgendwie überzeugt.
Nee, ich hab nicht gesagt, dass mich das überzeugt. Ich fand das einen interessanten Punkt, über den ich noch nicht nachgedacht habe.
Ja gut, da gibt es eine Menge Punkte, was so Service und so weiter betrifft. Aber ich denke, dass auch da vieles auf altem Denken basiert. Also allein diese Händler-Struktur-Vertriebssache, wo ja Tesla einfach sagt, ja wie Händler, wir machen einfach unsere eigenen Shops auf, das klickst du dir online, da geht das auch. Und das Firmware-Update kommt auch online.
Den Punkt mit den Badungskonstanzen, den fand er auch, da hat er auch so, da hast du gesehen, wie er im Sitz am liebsten schon angefangen hätte zu rotieren. Leider hat der Sitzgurt es verhindert. Oder glücklicherweise in meinem Fall. Also ich hab ihm ja auch vorher, bevor er sich mir offenbarte als VW-Strateger, habe ich mir auch erstmal hier alles runtergebetet, was wir hier schon in der Freak Show tausendfach wiedergegeben hatten. Und dann hat er gesagt, witzig. I'm from the Empire. Und dann war der Flug auch glücklicherweise schnell zu Ende, sonst hätte das vielleicht noch unangenehm werden können. Es war trotzdem interessant, mal mit so jemanden vom Kern der Macht, vom Zentrum der Macht quasi zu sprechen. Einfach so das Weltbild präsentiert zu bekommen. Auch wenn ich den Punkt noch nicht so auf dem Schirm hatte, und ja, okay, kann ja sein, hat mich jetzt nicht überzeugt, sondern war einfach nur ein Teil von seinen Ausführungen, wo ich zumindest mal dachte, ah ja, okay, das könnte ein Punkt sein, über den man sprechen könnte, auch wenn der auch nur so halb gar ist. Naja, ich hab jetzt auch schon überlegt, ob ich mir ein E-Motorrad kaufen soll. Witzigerweise, der einzige Händler, der in Berlin die sinnvollsten E-Motorräder verkauft, ist mein Honda-Händler. Honda selbst hat, glaub ich, noch kein einziges E-Motorrad oder E-Roller vorgestellt, aber sie verkaufen jetzt diese Zero Motorcycles in ihrem Laden.
Kurzer Einwurf noch bevor, wo du jetzt gerade sozusagen von dem Marketing-Sprech aus dem Tunnelstern berichtet hast, fällt mir einfach gerade so einer meiner Lieblings-Twitter-Accounts ein, den ich jetzt einfach mal in die Runde schmeiße, totally unrelated, aber wenn ihr irgendwie Spaß in eurer Timeline haben wollt, dann abonniert doch mal Death Star PR. Death Star PR ist sozusagen Marketing-Sprech aus dem Tunnelstern und kommentiert immer so aus einer Star Wars Perspektive die Welt. Elektromotorrad. Ja, sag ich ja gleich. Und, gibt es schon was ordentliches?
Na, es gibt, Yamaha wagt sich jetzt so langsam raus, die machen so Rennboliden, also richtig so Superbikes, das ist ja nicht so meine Art Motorrad.
Na, so hat der Tesla auch angefangen.
Genau, Zero Motorcycles heißen die einzigen, die so in der Tour...
Ein Stück davon hab ich schon gehört, das wollten wir ja schon immer mal hier ansprechen, richtig.
Meinst du, es taucht was? Die erste Serie, also ich hatte da auch mal was zu getwittert und dann meinten gleich so Leute, oh die erste Serie, die hatten so Kinderkrankheiten wie, du willst vorwärts fahren und das Motorrad fährt rückwärts und so. Also die hatten wohl schon so die Kinderkrankheiten raus und jetzt ist die zweite Generation da und die bekommen überall eigentlich sehr gute Reviews von sowohl von der Reichweite her als auch so ihr generelles Konzeptpreismodell ist wohl auch, also ist bezahlbar alles. Das einzige, was mich jetzt noch interessiert, ob das zu klein für mich sein könnte, weil ich habe ja relativ lange Beine und eigentlich ist mein Motorrad schon zu klein für mich. Für längere Strecken geht es dann in die Knie. Und die sehen auch so auf den Fotos ein bisschen zu lütt aus für meine Dimensionen und ich wollte jetzt eigentlich mal demnächst bei dem besagten Honda-Händler vorbei und mal gucken, ob sie da eins rumstehen haben. Also sie bieten auf jeden Fall Probefahrten an, aber ich weiß nicht, ob sie die dann immer kurz vorher mit dem Lieferwagen anliefern oder ob sie die permanente haben. Letztes Mal als ich da war, habe ich die nämlich nicht gesehen, auf Anhieb. Aber die sehen auf jeden Fall nach einem korrekten Motorrad aus. Und Motorrad könnte ich halt bei mir auf dem Hofe auch laden zur Not, also Auto wird schwierig, aber ja, mal gucken. Also da berichte ich dann, wenn ich mal eins unterm Hintern gehabt habe, aber ich fand es auf jeden Fall interessant, dass jetzt eben ausgerechnet der Honda-Hinder, dessen Hausmarke sozusagen keine eigenen E-Motorräder hat, dann diese Marke mitverkauft.
Also ich hab mir das auch schon mal so ein bisschen angeklickt und die haben ja auch so 11 Kilowatt-Modelle, die man halt mit so einem A1 bei alten Fahr-Führerscheinen auch noch in Klasse B fahren kann. Kosten allerdings auch, da muss man auch so 5-stellig was hinlegen, aber wenn man jetzt sozusagen auf Motorrad steht und so, die haben ja ganz ordentliche Reichweiten.
Also ich komm mit meinem Motorrad nicht so weit wie deren. Also ich hab aber auch ein altes Motorrad mit noch Vergaser, die sind ja sowieso relativ ineffizient. Also ich komm, glaub ich, 220 Kilometer, 250. Vielleicht, wenn ich Landstraße fahren würde, würde ich vielleicht auch auf 300 kommen, aber die machen halt auch 325. Und wenn sie die im Stadtbetrieb hinbekämen, also es klingt auf jeden Fall, ich hab mir das schonmal so durchgelesen mit meiner Praxis.
Elektro ist ja profitiert eigentlich von Stadtbetrieb. Die gehen halt schnell alle, wenn sie loskacheln.
Ja, wobei ständig anfahren, also auch da zieht doch so ein E-Motor sicherlich etwas mehr.
Nö, das ist eigentlich eher die hohe Leistung, die dir das Ding leer macht. Das ist ja eigentlich so ein Vorteil im Stadtverkehr, so ein Elektromotor.
Wie auch immer, also ich fahre ja viel in der Stadt. Insofern, ich würde ja sowieso abends das in die Steckdose stecken können, aber die Reichweite klingt auf jeden Fall nicht schlechter, als die von meinem Motorrad.
Da ist dann die Reichweitenangst nicht so ausgeprägt, ne?
Das war eine Sache, da war ich noch auf einem Segelboot, aber schon wieder mit Internet. Da hatte ich irgendwie zu diesem Reichweitenangst-Thema was Geiles. Mal sehen, ob ich das noch finde, gleich in meinen Aufzeichnungen. Anyway, aber ja, das ist da kein Thema, genau. Ja, würde ich mal demnächst auschecken, weil eigentlich habe ich auch keinen Bock. Also ich finde ja an Motorrädern, also Motorradfahren macht mir schon Spaß und irgendwie ist auch da dieser unrationale Spaß, wenn der Motor so unter einem loskesselt, ist schon da. Aber im Prinzip finde ich es nicht so geil und ich finde auch laute Motorräder mega scheiße. Meins ist ja relativ leise. Und dachte mir dann auch so, also meins ist jetzt von 2002, das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr das jüngste. Und wenn ich mir jetzt ein neues nochmal kaufen würde wollen, würde ich auf jeden Fall nicht, glaube ich, einen Verbrenner haben wollen. Deswegen habe ich dann das erste Mal so ein bisschen rumgeguckt und das ist momentan die einzige Marke, die sinnvolle Motorräder baut, die jetzt nicht so totale Renn-Superbikes sind.
Ja, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, als Stadt-Ding. Ich meine, du bist halt schnell, du kannst halt auch mal über Land, also gerade so dieses Ich muss ins Umland-Debatte, wo dann so ein Roller mit seinen 50 bis 100 Kilometern so ein bisschen an der Grenze ist. Da kannst du ja hier zu jedem See donnern. Genau, so was, mal so 100, 150 Kilometer, da hast du ja immer noch eine Ladung voll. Und wenn du zwischendurch mal irgendwo eine Steckdose siehst, ist das Ding ja ein paar Stunden dann auch schon wieder voll, weil ist ja auch nicht so viel drin. Also da hast du nicht diese sinnlose Energiebedarf, den eigentlich ein Auto hat. Deswegen denke ich mal, so überhaupt zwei Räder werden eine viel größere Rolle spielen in der nächsten Zeit.
Wie ist denn der Roller jetzt?
Und vor allem an den Fahrrädern. Ich mein, geh mal hier in so einen normalen Fahrradladen. Also von diesen größeren Dingern, die haben schon ganz amtliche Elektro-Abteilung. Weil da gibt es einen riesen Bedarf. Gar nicht mal jetzt bei so zukunftsorientierten, sondern einfach mal...
Die Modis.
Rentner, Leute, die einfach eh gar keinen Bock oder nicht die Möglichkeit oder den Wunsch haben, jetzt ein Auto zu fahren, die eigentlich nur so einen schönen Wettertransport brauchen, aber den dann auch regelmäßig in Anspruch nehmen, obwohl einfach die Kraft nicht mehr so da ist und wo dann vielleicht auch mal der eine oder andere Berg auch noch mal gestemmt werden muss. Und wenn du so im hohen Alter mit deinem Fahrrad mal eben einen steilen Berg mit 10% Steigung problemlos hochfahren kannst, dann ist das natürlich ein Gewinn an Lebensqualität, der lässt sich gar nicht so richtig in Worte fassen. Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Ding, das ist super populär jetzt im Urlaub, also fast kein Urlaubsort, wo du dir nicht schon E-Bikes mieten kannst. Das ist so ein Trend, also gerade in Bergen, aus denselben Gründen natürlich.
Also immer noch Fahrräder?
Genau, E-Bikes, also Pedelecs, wobei du halt jetzt auch schon so diese E-Mopeds halt auch bekommst, die ja dann nochmal andere Auflagen haben, Nummernschildversicherung etc., weil es ja quasi wie ein Moped ist, aber dann kannst du halt auch ordentlich wegkacheln. Gut, derzeit liegen die halt noch so irgendwo so zwischen 2000 und 3000 Euro, je nachdem in welche Kategorie du dich da einkaufen möchtest, aber viele Probleme, die du heute bei E-Autos hast, hast du da schon nicht. Laden ist nicht so das Ding, weil Wechselakku nimmst du einfach hoch, steckst sie rein, nimmst einen anderen, zack, bumm, immer alles geladen, gar kein Thema. Parken ist kein Problem, die Vorteile in der Stadt sind auch unmittelbar, weil du brauchst halt nicht so einen Parkplatz dafür, das ist eine gute Alternative. Du kannst hier in Berlin mit dem Elektro-Fahrrad mülllos mal eben die Stadt durchqueren. Und bist wahrscheinlich auch schneller als mit dem Auto. Du hast halt nur noch so diese Klassiker, die halt gegen Fahrrad sprechen, was ist mit schlechtem Wetter, Winter etc. Und da denke ich mal, wenn so Roller und so Kabinenlösungen demnächst auch nochmal das Feld aufrollen.
Wisst ihr das eigentlich, ob bei diesen E-Rollern, die jetzt hier die ganze Stadt unsicher machen, ob das bei solchen dann auch so noch Wechselbatterien zum Mit-Hoch-Nehmen sind?
Da gibt's viele von den Dingern, die ich jetzt gesehen habe, die haben halt so auch Bosch, das Bosch-System ist ja, wo der Motor nicht mehr, also es wandert ja jetzt alles von den Rädern. Am Anfang war es ja immer so, hast ein anderes Rad und dann in der Narbe hast du den Motor, Narbenmotor. Da ist ja das Problem, oder was heißt Problem? Die Eigenschaft ist, du trittst, das Rad kriegt mit, dass du schneller wirst und schiebt dann quasi mit. Hast aber immer so eine Latenz. Und das Bosch-System ist halt, du gehst direkt an die Kurbel und in dem Moment, wo du mehr trittst, tritt quasi der Elektromotor sofort mit. Das heißt, du hast eine unmittelbare Verstärkung und auch eine viel effizientere Verstärkung.
Ah, da ist der E-Roller da oben. Die haben auch so Hand-Akkus. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das bei dem Motorrad ist. Ich vermute mal, da kann man den Akku und nicht so so eben mal rausnehmen.
Glaub ich auch nicht, weiß ich aber nicht.
Wäre natürlich umso geiler noch, weil dann müsste ich nicht irgendwie Power-Tank-Technologie, weil dann müsste ich nämlich nicht aus dem zweiten Stock vielleicht noch das Verlängerungskabel in den Hof herablassen, aber das wäre jetzt auch noch machbar. Zur Not.
Ja, also es zeichnet sich halt ab, dass es auf allen Ebenen was gibt. Hier, Tread ist ganz fleißig gerade am Posten. Also es gibt jetzt neue Tretroller, so kleine Scooter, die halt elektrisch sind, die immer besser werden. Ich hab ja noch so ein altes Teil, die haben halt immer noch so ein bisschen das Zulassungsproblem, aber die sind im Prinzip auch schon ganz interessant. Du hast halt einfach so einen Tretroller, der irgendwie mitbeschleunigt. Dann halt die Roller hatten wir ja auch schon tausendmal, wie zum Beispiel der UNU. Und da gibt es ja jetzt auch noch so diverse andere Anbieter. Dazu halt jetzt hier die ganzen Roller-Sharing-Dinger, die wir hier in Berlin genießen, die es leider in anderen Städten so noch nicht gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ist Q jetzt auch schon mal woanders als in Berlin unterwegs. Ich glaube, die Emmys sind auch in Hamburg jetzt oder so. Also das wird sicherlich bald kommen. Die Q ist nur in Berlin.
Ich finde das nämlich schon sehr beeindruckend.
Berlin, Hamburg, München, Düsseldorf, Stuttgart, Mannheim. Also geht voran.
Ich finde die Durchdringung auch relativ beeindruckend. Das ging ja relativ flott. Wir fangen jetzt mal an zu, gerade als ich hier ankam, hat hier einer den E-Roller von meiner Nase abgestellt und man hört dieses Surren, das Charakteristische, doch jetzt sehr oft in der Stadt.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich letztes unterwegs war. Ich war mit dem Auto unterwegs und an uns zogen so eine Horde Leute mit diesen E-Rollern in der Gruppe vorbei. Das ist schon ein bisschen lustig. Genau. Also ich meine halt wirklich so einiges an Leuten.
Es gibt ja die Vespa-Fahrer, die machen ja im Frühling auch immer Anrollern. Die treffen sich dann auch zu so einer großen Horde und fahren dann mit ihren stinkenden Vespas durch die Gegend. Wenn das durch E-Roller ersetzt werden würde, wäre ich sehr dafür.
Das muss halt erst mal sexy werden. Und ich glaube, was halt viele Motorradfahrer immer noch ausmacht, weil jetzt im Sommer war ich ja unter anderem in Mecklenburg irgendwo, da Seenlandschaft, sehr schön, blickst du da so über den See und denkst dir, ach alles wie schön hier und die Vöglein-Switchern, dann auf einmal so in der Ferne so drei Kilometer entfernt. Weißt du, so ein Motorradfahrer deckt einfach alles in so einen Lärmstaub ein und ich sehe ihn so förmlich vor mir, so ja, wie geil, ich und die Natur. Aber was das für so einen Fingerabdruck hinterlässt, das ist irgendwie in dem Moment nicht klar. Und die beklopptesten sind natürlich hier diese Harley-Penner.
Ja, das ist ja nicht mal nur Harley.
Das sind aber immer die lautesten. Das sind ja die, die sich über diesen Lärm auch so explizit zu definieren, was ich halt auch sagen muss.
Es gibt auch andere Marken, die das, achso, aber so Chopper, was auch immer. Die Harley, die läuft ja halt unrund, das ist besonders schön.
Also Easy Rider war ein geiler Film, muss man auch mal gesehen haben. Hält auch lange der Kult, aber jetzt ist halt...
Hat ja nicht so ein Happy End, ne? Also ich hab mir den auch irgendwann mal angeguckt und dachte mir, warum ist das jetzt so? Ja, ich weiß schon, aber gerade das Motorradfahren nimmt ja ein unrühmliches Ende. iOS 11 ist scheiße.
Ich hab noch kein Update gemacht. Ich wurde gewarnt. Man hat es mir gezeigt und so dieses... Ich warte da einfach noch so ein bisschen.
Ab vorher auch, also.
Also ich bereue jetzt auch ein bisschen nicht, wie sonst üblich zum ersten Point Release gewartet zu haben. Normalerweise geht's ja eigentlich gut, aber irgendwie muss jetzt in der speziellen Konstellation mit meinen Einstellungen auf meinem Gerät, mit meinen Apps irgendwas ganz schlecht gelaufen sein und bei mir, ich hatte jetzt diverse Crashes, also Phone, ich hab heute das Telefon zweimal schon neu gestartet. Ich war schon kurz davor, es ein drittes Mal zu tun. Bei mir bleiben Apps stehen. Richtig nervig ist, meine Telefon-App erlaubt mir, also will irgendwann nicht mehr telefonieren. Das heißt, ich höre nichts und der Angerufene hört mich nicht, die Verbindung kommt zustande, aber ich bin taubstumm. Nach dem Reboot geht's dann direkt wieder mit dem Telefonieren. Ich hatte auch versucht, schon ein paar Screenshots zu machen von grafischen Abenteuern, wo die obere Hälfte des Screens im Landscape-Mode ist und die untere im Portrait-Mode. Also sehr artistisch wertvoll auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dass irgendwas in der GPU durcheinander gekommen ist.
Ja, so generell ist dieses... Oder auch Apps, also selbst der App Store oder so, die gehen so auf und bleiben einfach stehen. Und es passiert nichts und irgendwann gehen sie wieder aus und dann kommen sie wieder. Und also ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt von diesem Upgrade gar nicht begeistert. Ich warte jetzt mal noch auf das Point-1-Release. Ich hoffe, das kommt in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft. Ich habe heute schon das 11.0.1 installiert und gehofft, es wird besser, aber für alle die, die ähnliche Probleme haben. Kann ich schon sagen, das wird nicht besser mit diesem 0.1. Also die andere Alternative ist dann clean install oder warten, bis das iPhone X da ist.
Hast du dir das bestellt?
Das hat der Arbeitgeber quasi bestellt. Die Unwissen zu fragen. Was meintest du davor, als ich meinte, dass du ein Update löstest oder ein clean install oder das neue iPhone X? Hast du gerade auch noch was gemurmelten?
Ich murmelte verschiedene Sachen. Also ein clean install könnte vielleicht auch helfen. Klingt halt für mich so ein bisschen nach irgendeinem GPU-Fuck-Up.
Aber das ist ja nur das eine Phänomen, dass da mal der Screen so hängen bleibt. Das andere ist ja...
Klar, kann alles Mögliche sein, aber wenn halt erst mal was... Hast du Scheiße am Schuh? Also Klassiker. Egal. Wir sind ja jetzt auch nicht dafür bekannt, dass wir jetzt Apple kritisieren.
Das ist auch direkt nach dem Update überhaupt erst.
Na gut, kann ja sein. Montags Gerät, keine Ahnung. Irgendwie Fehler, Next-Versible, Fixed. Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht endemisch.
Es gibt genug Leute, die keine Probleme haben, aber als ich darüber twitterte, kamen diverse Berichte von, ich bin gut, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin. Es gab schon Solidarisierung.
Lustigerweise gibt es bei der Podcast-App diverse Änderungen, über die ich nicht viel sagen kann, weil ich ja die App ohnehin schon längere Zeit nicht mehr benutze. Da hat sich einiges getan und einige Dinge sind da irgendwie auch weggefallen. Aber was mir aufgefallen ist, nach dem Update und ich mir das nur so weite angeschaut habe, und das finde ich irgendwie geil. Erinnerst du dich noch, wie steil ich hier irgendwie abgegangen bin, als iOS 7 rauskam? Ich habe das ja ein Jahr lang nicht installiert. Ich habe das erst ganz kurz vor iOS 8, als das so in Sichtweite war, habe ich gesagt, ok, jetzt installiere ich das mal, es muss ja nicht lange drunter leiden. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe schon so ein bisschen auch an mir gezweifelt. Ob ich ein Old-Fart bin, der irgendwie mit Change nicht mehr klarkommt und so. Mich haben auch schon so andere Podcasts da schon so ein bisschen von der Seite angeguckt, so ja, der Tim und so, hier guck mal mit seinem iOS 6 und so. Liebt in der Vergangenheit, nicht mehr zukunftskompatibel, was man so sagt. Und in gewisser Hinsicht hatten sie auch recht. Irgendwas hat mich einfach total gestört und es waren so viele Sachen, die mich gestört haben. Und so über die Jahre hinweg ist ja dann eins nach dem anderen dieser Dinge auch gefallen. Es wurde immer eins nach dem anderen viel weg. Das war dann okay, bei iOS 8 hat sich was geändert, bei 9 und so weiter, 10 ging die ganze Zeit weiter. Und jetzt mit 11 hab ich das Gefühl, jetzt sind sie genau da angekommen, wo ich sie eigentlich von Anfang an haben wollte. Also was das User-Interface betrifft, gibt es einfach so ein paar Dinge, also es sind so Kleinigkeiten. Zum Beispiel ist ja die Fonds, die einem so entgegenschlagen, was weiß ich so, dass die Zahl auf dem Datum...
An alles mehr Gewicht wieder.
Alles hat mehr Weight, alles ist irgendwie weg von diesem mega dünnen, zisillierten, vollkommen übertriebenen Kitzel-Kritzel. Und jetzt hat es irgendwie so die Schwere, die es irgendwie gebraucht hat, finde ich. Das ist irgendwie da.
Ich bin ja ein sehr großer Fan von diesen sehr dünnen Schriften.
Ich finde auch, dass die elegant aussehen, aber sie sind halt nicht unbedingt ergonomisch.
Also nicht für jede User-Interface-Applikation, für die sie verwendet wurden. In iOS 7 waren sie auch ideal.
Ja, also die Lesbarkeit. Also es ist halt dieses alte Ding mit definiert die Optik dein Design oder definiert die Funktionalität dein Design. Und Design ist ja eigentlich Funktionalität und schön, wenn es dann auch noch gut aussieht. Und im Idealfall geht beides so Hand in Hand in den in den Sonnenuntergang. Und es ist der Beginn einer wunderbaren Freundschaft. Ja, das kriegt man halt, das kriegt halt auch Apple nicht unbedingt immer hin. Und ich denke, dass iOS 7 halt mega aus so einer ästhetischen Revolution herauskam. Also sie haben zwar jetzt auch was so, wie man mit allem interagiert, auch neu gedacht. So, aber es war halt irre. Ich meine, so Text, der irgendwo stand. Vorher hattest du da so fette dreidimensionale Buttons. So, und dann war es auf einmal nur Text, der wie jeder andere war. Und dann so Version zu Version zu Version wurde es irgendwie immer weniger. Und jetzt bei iOS 11 sind die Buttons wieder da. Jetzt hast du diesen grauen Schatten drum herum. Klar, kann man jetzt sagen, sieht vielleicht nicht so schön aus, aber ist halt ungemein praktisch.
Jetzt wollte ich gerade mal, es ist gerade gefriest. Ah, da, es kommt wieder. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht rechnet der Bitcoins im Hintergrund oder so. Eine Sache, die ich jetzt mal direkt nachgucken will, kannst du dich noch erinnern an die Apple Music, also die Music App Shuffle-Diskussion? Also ich hatte ja das Problem, dass ich Shuffle eingestellt hatte. Musik, alle Musik wurde geschuffelt bei mir. Nichts wurde in der ursprünglichen Reihenfolge abgespielt. Und ich habe den Button nicht gefunden, das User-Interface. Und Leute auf Twitter haben mir eine Step-by-Step-Anleitung geschickt, wie man also zu diesem Button wieder kommt. Und jetzt werde ich mal gleich kurz gucken, ob das sich geändert hat jetzt auch mit iOS 11 und der Shuffle-Button wieder in sichtbarer Reichweite ist. Ja, tatsächlich. Oder? Warte mal, Moment, das ist der hier.
Oh, ja, das haben sie wieder.
Aber warte, Moment, das geht noch, wenn ich den Track jetzt abspiele. Kann ich das hier ganz leise machen? Ja, genau, dann kam nämlich diese Karte hier hoch von dem Track, wenn du da draufklickst. Und dann hier unten, da ist der, der ist immer noch da unten, da ist der Shuffle-Button der globale. Also für Tim nochmal, falls du die... Für die Hörer ist es. Also, genau, man ist hier so in der Albumsansicht und spielt einen Track ab und da ist ein Shuffle-Button, aber dieser Shuffle-Button, der sortiert nur die Playlist um. Also der... Es gibt noch ein globales Shuffle und zwar muss man dann hier unten drauf klicken, in den eigentlichen Player und dann kommt so eine Karte hochgepoppt und dann muss man noch darauf kommen, hier Tim, dass man die Karte noch hochscrollen kann. Und dann ist ganz am Ende ist da so ein Shuffle-Button und...
Für mich war das das Wichtigste, diesen Shuffle-Button zu suchen, weil ich alles immer im Shuffle höre. Also ich hab genau die Geschichte andersrum gehabt.
Also das hat sich noch nicht gebessert. Die Music-App ist nach wie vor ein Usability-Desaster. Aber gut.
Bist du den Apple-Musik-Kunde?
Auch das, ja.
Und ist das Leben besser mit Apple Music?
Ich glaube mein iTunes ist seitdem ein bisschen...
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, also ich bereue es nicht. Im Gegenteil. Ich finde es durchaus praktisch. Weil...
Wird man dann auch alles, was man finden will?
Erstaunlich viel.
Wir haben wirklich mittlerweile... Sie hatten ja schon immer einen sehr großen Katalog und waren eigentlich schon immer weit vorne mit dabei. Und dann zwischendurch hat Spotify mal sie so ein bisschen überholt gehabt. Was so Indie-Labels angeht. Aber mittlerweile, also ich kann mich nicht erinnern an das letzte Mal, wo ich was nicht gefunden hätte. Also auch, weil ich höre ganz viel so kleinere Bands auch und so nicht Zeitgeistmusik. Und bisher habe ich tatsächlich alles da gefunden. Und wenn ich halt eine CD, ich kaufe ja auch immer noch Musik so auf Amazon Marketplace, wenn ich halt der M-Frei, Losless und so weiter haben will. Und es gibt halt keinen Bandcamp-Account, oder wo ich das kaufen kann. Dann kaufe ich mir auf Amazon Marketplace für einen Euro oder so die CD, meistens ein Original verpackt, weil ich ja eh auf ältere Musik stehe. Und dann rippe ich mir die. Und dann ist die aber auch sofort auf allen Geräten halt zum Streamen verfügbar. Und in meiner Library also das Einzige, wo ich jetzt ein bisschen noch mehr darauf aufpasse, ist, dass ich meine gekaufte Musik wirklich an einem Ort nochmal so konsolidiert separat aufbewahre, damit sie nicht irgendwann mal durch irgendeine iTunes-Installation oder so oder irgendein Cloud-Sync-Verhalten ausgelöscht wird. Aber ansonsten bin ich eigentlich ganz froh und auch auf dem Segelboot, weil wir Internet hatten und die Leute irgendwelche Musikwünsche hatten. Also ich habe auch viel gestreamt dieses Mal, was ich sonst eigentlich nicht so viel tue. Und das funktionierte auch tadellos.
Wenn du Apple Music hast, hast du dieses iTunes-Match quasi mit dabei.
Und das Geile ist auch noch, wenn ich von meiner Band irgendwie so mp3s mal rausrenne und die in meine eine Library reinziehe, dann habe ich die auch, also kann ich die auch hier abspielen. Also das SYNKT auch den Nicht-Label-Kram.
Aber ich habe ja iTunes Match gemacht. Das Matchen wäre mir egal gewesen. Ich will sozusagen überall auf den Scheiß zugreifen. Und da ich jetzt nicht so ein Musik-Hörer-Typ bin, bin ich da so bisher mit meinem kleinen Katalog irgendwie ausgekommen. Ich mache das bloß einfach wahnsinnig. Ich rippe halt irgendwas dazu. Und dann meint er mir halt irgendwie, ja, kann ich hier nicht runterladen, geht nicht, ist irgendwie nicht kompatibel. Hast du sowas auch? Oder ist das wiederum nur bei mir?
Also du hast iTunes Match, aber nicht Apple Music. Richtig. Na, bei mir sagt er, wenn ich irgendwie so Musik von der Festplatte in die Library reinziehe oder in irgendeine Playlist, dann sagt er mir immer erst, kann ich jetzt nicht in die Cloud dünken.
Weil das muss jetzt erstmal bei iCloud irgendwie, da muss man halt warten, bis das so reingesynkt ist. Aber manchmal kann ich halt Dinge auch gar nicht. Dann sagt er halt, das wäre jetzt nicht kompatibel. Dann gibt es da so Einschränkungen mit irgendwie zu lang. Da hast du so ein DJ-Set, ja so Sachen, die jetzt... Also das ist sozusagen Musik, die mich interessiert. Ich will da halt mal so in vier Stunden ein DJ-Set reinhaben. Und wenn die da halt so Limitierungen haben mit, das darf nicht länger sein als eine anderthalb Stunde, dann sag ich mir nur so, wozu bezahle ich für diesen Scheißdreck, wenn ich nicht in der Lage ist, irgendwie mal so ein paar Hundert Megabyte zu sinken. Warum gibt es so eine Beschränkung? Muss Musik immer in Tracks organisiert sein?
Das ist doch bekloppt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich... Können wir in meiner iTunes-Library gucken, ob ich was habe, was überhaupt länger als eine Stunde ist? Ich weiß, es ist die diskordische Bibelstunde, aber die ist wahrscheinlich nicht so lang. Die Ehreslaunch, das was der... Oh sorry, der Dose da zum Schluss gespielt hat. Ich guck mal gerade.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hab auch von den Nation Sets, die mit Sicherheit über eine Stunde gehen, das eine ist glaube ich zwei Stunden. Also ich nutze jetzt mittlerweile nämlich auch Apple Music.
Ja, manchmal geht's, manchmal geht's nicht so. Und das ist halt das, was mich so ein bisschen wahnsinnig macht. Und mich hat halt die Performance von diesem iTunes-Match bisher nicht so davon überzeugt, dass ich jetzt irgendwie noch mehr Geld dafür ausgeben muss und dann irgendwie Zugriff auf Musik zu haben, die mich sowieso nicht hören will.
Zwei Stunden dreißig ist die Ehreslaunch immerhin mal. Also ich guck mal gerade.
Zwei Stunden fünfzig hab ich hier noch dabei.
Und das SYNKT auch.
Ich guck mal jetzt, genau, jetzt warte, ich guck jetzt quasi dann auf meinem Telefon, ob es da dann auch ist. Check, check, check, check. Also das komplett gesünd scheint zu funktionieren.
Das ist vielleicht so wie mit deinem Telefon.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, also ich hatte jetzt mit Apple Music wirklich, also als ich es released hab, da gab es so sehr komische SYNK-Verhalten und dann wurden auch so bestimmte Teile nur so halb gesynkt und so. Das war alles ganz furchtbar am Anfang, aber jetzt, ich würde sagen das letzte halbe Jahr oder Jahr, eigentlich keine Klagen mehr.
Aber ich sehe gerade ein Pfeil ist hier nicht gesynkt, wo auch dahinter steht, dass ein Fehler drin ist. Und das sind dann bei zwei Stunden 56 und 32 Sekunden. Also vielleicht ist die magische Grenze irgendwo bei zwei Stunden 50.
Ja, ich werde das mal in Zukunft im Auge behalten. Aber mit einzelnen Tracks kriegen sie es mittlerweile ganz gut hin.
Ja, also jetzt so ein vollständiges Review wollten wir jetzt hier eh nicht. Was ich noch sehr interessant fand, ist, dass sie den Zugriff auf Mac-Adressen und sowas auf niedrigster Ebene gesperrt haben jetzt bei iOS 11. Das heißt, Tools können ich da auf der Ebene auch nicht mehr identifizieren. Überhaupt haben sie ja gnadenlos, machen sie irgendwie alles dicht. Habe ich so den Eindruck. Also sie meinen das ja irgendwie total ernst. Und sie haben ja jetzt auch im neuen Safari, dann halt auch auf dem Mac diese, wir lassen uns nicht mehr tracken und wir zwirbeln euren Scheiß so lange durcheinander und die ganze Werbeindustrie ist jetzt irgendwie auf die Hinterbeine gegangen. Also, wie könnt ihr das nun machen? Jetzt können wir irgendwie nicht mehr unsere User überwachen. Das finde ich irgendwie sehr beruhigend, wenn sich diese Szene gegen Apple auflehnt und sagt, irgendwie geht es noch. Dann habe ich so das Gefühl, ich bin auf der richtigen Plattform.
Ja, so das ist auf jeden Fall nach wie vor so ein Punkt, warum ich potenziell lieber ein Apple-Gerät als ein Google-Gerät oder ein Microsoft-Gerät kaufe, wo dann irgendwie so ein PC irgendwie daherkommt mit irgendwie gleich vorinstalliertem Snake Oil, Viren-Scanner und irgendwelchem Crap, der gleich beim ersten frischen Booten mit irgendwelchen Third-Parties redet. Oder halt im Falle von Google, eine Firma, die halt ganz klar das Geschäftsmodell hat, auf den Daten basierend irgendwie Werbeplätze zu verkaufen. Und Apple hat halt das Business-Modell über teute Hardware zu verkaufen. Das finde ich in dem Fall auf jeden Fall deutlich sympathischer, als das ihr mit den Daten zu macht. Ich meine, ist halt die Frage, ob also inwieweit das dann wirklich stimmt oder nicht dann auch vielleicht ein bisschen Marketing geblubber ist. Also zum Beispiel dieses Location Services, wo du deine Frequent Locations siehst und so weiter, wo sie auch sagen, das wird nur auf dem Gerät gespeichert, beim Find My Friends oder Find Friends, was ja auch so eine App ist, wo die Leute erstmal so ein bisschen ungemütlich werden, wo ja auch im Prinzip nur eine iMessage geschickt wird an deine Freunde und du dann, wenn dein Gerät an ist, zurückschreibst, hier bin ich gerade. Klar, das klingt alles auf jeden Fall plausibel, aber solange man nicht wirklich mal auf die Datenbanken geguckt hat, da bei Apple ist halt natürlich ein gewisser Rest Zweifel noch da. Aber ja, es ist trotzdem erst mal von der Grundprämisse sympathischer.
Ja, Hardware.
Überteuerte Hardware, genau.
Ich komm jetzt, gegen Ende des Jahres muss man sich ja dann immer noch mal überlegen, ob man noch mal so mit seinem potenziellen Jahresgewinn unter Umständen noch mal die ein oder andere Investitionen tätigt, die man dann gegebenenfalls rechnerisch günstiger kriegt. Wegen? Potenzieller? Steuervermeidung, schwierige Diskussion. Also, das ist ja immer so schnell dahergesagt. Weil, ich meine, das Geld, das man ausgibt, ist halt weg. Da kriegt man dann halt an. Die gewinnen dann nicht, auch selbst wenn man Steuern drauf zahlen muss.
Und als kleine Geräteche noch zu tun, ich musste kürzlich ein Geldwäsche- und Fraud-Prevention-Training absolvieren, weil ich ja gerade bei so einer Bank arbeite. Da wird ja auch gesagt, wie Geldwäsche funktioniert. Das ist halt so ein bisschen counterintuitive. Du sollst jetzt irgendwie der Wächter der Ordnung sein und dann sagen sie dir gleich in den ersten Kapiteln also Geldwäsche wird auf diese und auf diese. Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel. Unternehmer X möchte gerne so richtig...
Die tiefsten Einblicke in Kriminalität kriegst du bei der Polizei.
Ja, auch wieder. Aber gerade so Geldwäsche war sehr interessant, weil da schon viele so Gelegenheiten oder so kleine Delikte, wo man mal so ein Auge zuhört und denkt sich so, ach, das fällt jetzt eh nicht auf. Also selbst bei Kleinbeträgen. Und da wird halt beschrieben auch, wie dieses Scoring bei Banken überhaupt funktioniert und ab wann du so ein manuelles Review bekommst, sozusagen. Und die Schwellwerte können relativ klein sein. Also ich war hinterher tatsächlich so ein bisschen, okay, okay, okay, schön aufpassen.
War das jetzt, darf man so was öffentlich diskutieren oder war das dann auch noch so unter...
Nee, nee, nee, vielleicht gibt's das sogar öffentlich. Es gibt so, es war auch, also es war kein Workshop so in dem Sinne, sondern du musst da halt so durch so einen Web-Test durch. Aber du kriegst wirklich viel Informationen. Du kannst halt viel überspringen und nur die Summary durchlesen und dann deinen Tester ausfüllen. Aber ich habe tatsächlich mir die Zeit genommen, mal viele von den Info-Dingern so angeklickt, um mal die Details zu verstehen.
Damit du die gleichen Fehler nicht wieder machst.
Ja, ich hatte noch keine Geldwäscheprobleme. Aber man hat ja ab und zu...
Es ging bisher immer alles super.
Nee, Hucke, das diskutieren wir hier nicht öffentlich.
Uns kannst du es doch sagen.
Uns kannst du gerne auch Tipps geben.
Nee, ach, das ist jetzt... Weiß nicht, ob mir jetzt so spontan was Knackiges einfällt zur Wiedergabe. Aber es ist schon so, dass dein Verhalten, so dein Transaktionsverhalten, schon dauerhaft gemonitort wird sozusagen. Und wenn du sozusagen so ein gewisses Ein- und Ausgaben-Niveau die ganze Zeit hast und plötzlich kommen halt so Beträge, zum Beispiel aus dem Ausland, dann springt da schon direkt mal so ein Alarm-Schlückchen.
Ich kenn das so. Ich hab ja auch so eine Ahnung, so ein N24-Testkonto. Mal gucken, wie das so ist. Was hab ich gesagt? Und benutze das zum Beispiel gerade jetzt für die Ticket-Einnahmen für unsere Konferenzen jetzt im Oktober. So, und dann liegt das Ding halt auch so ein Jahr lang so rum mit irgendwie kein Umsatz und dann auf einmal so bang bang bang.
Aber du, da macht ihr keine Sorgen, das ist ja eine Start-up-Bank. Die haben hundertprozentig immer noch nicht ihre Scoring-Algorithmen.
Ich hab nach zwei Tagen eine Mail bekommen.
Okay, die sind schon so weit. Bei der anderen Institution, also da ist man noch nicht ganz so weit.
Ja, die haben irgendwie so gefragt, so ist das hier Veranstaltungen oder was und so und ich so, ja hier Link und dann war auch Ruhr. So, aber so und früher war das ja bei PayPal ganz krass, ne? Also da hatte ich das auch mal für solche Sachen und da kriegste dann auch schnell mal eine Sperre reingewirkt.
Ja und es waren noch so Beispiele wie, anscheinend ist es so, dass Geldwäscher dann wirklich, also ihr kennt ja diese E-Mails so, hier 500 Euro am Tag verdienen, bla bla bla bla und da geht es halt auch so darum, dass dann irgendwelche Studenten halt irgendwie kriegen so Geld aus Osteuropa überwiesen oder kriegen überwiesen und sollen nach Osteuropa das weiter überweisen und die streuen sozusagen ihre ganze Kohle auf möglichst viele kleine. Aber sozusagen auch diese Transaktionen fallen dann schon auf, wenn halt so ein Student, der sonst nur Barfell kriegt und seine Miete gerade davon bezahlt und dann kommen da irgendwie so Beträge mit unklaren Quellen und Zieleinrichtungen und so. Also lauter solche Beispiele waren das größtenteils, aber es waren dann am Ende auch so ein bisschen verstricktere Unternehmensstrukturen und von einem Unternehmen zum anderen mit, du kannst dieses Geld jetzt nicht direkt geben, aber wenn du mir jetzt 1000 Smartphones abkaufst und dann mit Mehrwertsteuer im Europa und...
Demnächst werden sie da mit Machine Learning rangehen und sagen, ja so sehen Transaktionen aus, die wischiwaschi sind.
Genau, das ist natürlich auch das, das wird auch schon gemacht. Dieses Scoring passiert ja als erstes, bevor ein Mensch dann drauf guckt. Nur haben sie dann eben auch passenderweise so Gegenbeispiel, also Falls Positives sozusagen präsentiert, wo vom Reintransaktionsmuster, wenn man jetzt naiv rangehen würde, würde das auch quasi das Scoring triggern. Und deswegen ist dann halt immer noch mal so ein Mensch dabei, der dann da drauf guckt, ob das nicht vielleicht doch Sinn macht. Weil in dem Moment, wo du den ersten Verdacht hast, musst du das melden, dem Geldwäschebeauftragten. Und dann hat das Legale, also hat das Folgen sozusagen. Und wenn du sozusagen jemand, der verdächtig ist, sofort für Geldwäsche meldest und diesen ganzen Prozess in Gang bringst und sein Konto gesperrt wird und deswegen irgendwie wirtschaftlicher Schaden entsteht, dann fällt das auch auf die Bank im Zweifel zurück. Und deswegen ging es in diesem Geldwäschetest oder in diesem Training halt auch die ganze Zeit darum, die richtige Balance zu finden und das Scoring halt immer mit noch menschlichem Auge zu übersehen. Ja und wenn, weiß nicht, ich könnte mal gucken, ob das irgendwie im Internet verfügbar ist, aber auch dieses Fraud-Thema, also Fishing und diese ganzen Themen, auch Skimming und also die haben wirklich da so alle möglichen Themen beleuchtet, war durchaus auch sehr interessant.
Ist das was, an dem man öffentlich teilnehmen kann?
Na ja, ich hatte halt so einen Link bekommen und das war aber so, es war jetzt nicht auf die Bank so gemünzt, also es war auf jeden Fall irgendwie, ich kann noch mal gucken.
Aber es war jetzt nicht, wurde bezahlt und du hattest dann bezahlt einen Link?
Ich hatte einen Login, doch. Also ich vermute schon, dass man, aber andererseits, das könnte wirklich jeder wissen, also ich weiß nicht, warum das so geheim gehalten werden müsste, außer die Leute kommen vielleicht auf Ideen und wissen, ah, das mach ich schon mal nicht, also ich muss noch ne Stufe.
Doch, wie ne Bombenbastel.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, für mich war das eher so, ah, okay, so geht das und so geht das, alles klar. Also hat mir gefühlt eher die Sinne geschärft, als jetzt mich auf Ideen gebracht, meine kriminelle Energie zu entfalten. Na ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich schau mal, ich kann mal fragen, ob dieser Link irgendwie öffentlich ist, oder ansonsten mal selber rum googeln. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass es da was gibt. So, kleine Themengeräte zu Ende.
Ich hatte also überlegt, was ich mit meinem Geld so mache. Nicht, dass ich da jetzt besonders viel von hätte, aber na ja, kurz gesagt, ich hab da noch so einen älteren iMac in meiner Privatnutzung, den wollte ich jetzt mal raus rotieren, weil kriegt jetzt nicht mehr aktuelle Software-Updates pipa pro. Und dann hab ich ja hier noch so ein iMac stehen, so ein 27 Zoller von 2009, der mir hier treue Dienste leistet, auf den ich aber eigentlich auch gar nicht verzichten möchte, der aber eigentlich ganz cool war. Und dann dachte ich mir, dann kaufst du halt einen neueren iMac. Warum nicht? Für mich halt jetzt, einerseits ist das sozusagen immer so mein Veranstaltungscomputer, das heißt, wenn ich irgendeine Art Event hab, wo ich mal einen Computer brauch, der nicht mein Laptop sein soll, gerade so Audio-Schnitt, Sendezentrum, la la la, einfach mal so ein dicker iMac mit einem großen Bildschirm, wo man irgendwie ordentlich korrekt aufnehmen und schneiden kann. So ist es einfach top. iMac ist überhaupt klasse, rein in den Karton, hinstellen, aufbauen, anschließend fertig, läuft alles so. Toll. Und das will ich natürlich auch weiterhin haben, da hab ich halt überlegt, okay, wie neu darf denn ein iMac so sein? Hast ja dann immer so Feature versus Preis, aber dann war halt für mich schnell eine natürliche Grenze bei im Jahr 2011 gefunden, weil seitdem halt diese Macs sich nicht mehr als externe Bildschirme benutzen lassen. Das ist ja so ein Feature bei dem iMac, du kannst da so Commando, Apple F2 drücken und dann schaltet der quasi um in Ich-bin-ein-Monitor-Modus, während der andere Rechner dahinter noch weiterläuft. Das heißt, du kannst auch produktiv irgendwas laufen lassen und kannst ihn aber auch noch als zweiten Bildschirm benutzen. Und genauso verwende ich das hier, weil dann habe ich halt an meinem Mac Pro quasi hier bis zu drei Displays dran. Und für mich ist das halt einfach super. Ich sehe ein, dass das nicht jeder braucht. Aber das war für mich dann halt irgendwie wichtig. Okay, 2011 kann ja nicht so teuer sein. Gehe ich doch mal irgendwie auf eBay, guck mal. Und habe das festgestellt, was man immer so feststellt, wenn man mal nach einem alten Macs guckt. Die Scheiße geht immer noch für so viel Kohle weg. Es ist absurd, wie irgend einer nur behaupten kann, Macs werden teuer. Das ist so ein Blödsinn. Also uralt, ich meine, was haben wir jetzt? Sechs Jahre ist das Ding alt. Sechs Jahre alter Computer. Gut, der war dann auch Vollausbau mit irgendwie viel RAM und irgendwie i7 und irgendwie so ein rechts unten Modell, was man damals kaufen konnte. Und noch eine SSD nachgerüstet, also auch noch mal so ein bisschen Value-Edit, aber da muss dann halt auch noch mal ein Tausender loswerden, wenn du das Ding halt auch wirklich klicken willst. So, den krieg ich jetzt diese Woche und dann hoffe ich, dass das irgendwie auch genauso smooth läuft.
Hattest du schon gesagt, wo du ihn gekauft hast?
eBay.
Es gibt ja auch noch diese anderen.
Es gibt auch noch die anderen. Sicherlich wäre dann noch ein bisschen, also ich hab jetzt so aus dem Stand nichts gefunden, was so gut ausgestattet war. Also es gab auch noch ein paar Angebote, aber der war halt dann mit irgendwie voll RAM und mit irgendwie SSD und für den Preis, für den ich dann geklickt hab, war es dann auch noch so okay. Nur hätte ich so gefühlt gesagt, hätte ich ihn irgendwie auch für zwei Drittel des Preises erwartet. Aber ist halt nicht so.
Ja, nach unserer nach unseren ganzen Mac Pro Berichterstattung war er dann bei Second Mac und so, da bei Ebay waren ja plötzlich, also was heißt plötzlich, war vielleicht so eine generelle Strömung, aber war ja, ich hab ja meinen noch für 600 sonst was geschossen und dann...
Weißt du, nachdem wir darüber geredet haben?
Das gleiche Modell dann für 1000 gesehen, ja. Aber wie gesagt, das kann auch einfach generelles Interesse oder Angebot-Nachfrage gewesen sein.
Ja, aber so symptomatisch, also für mich kommt sozusagen kein iMac-Infrastruktur in Frage hier, der irgendwie älter, jünger als sechs Jahre ist, weil mir dann einfach irgendwie die Features wegbrechen, die ich gerne haben möchte. So bin ich auch mit meinem Mac Pro nach wie vor sehr glücklich und hab auch heute, weil no risk, no fun, direkt vor der Sendung hier noch mal ein High Sierra Update gemacht, weil das kam ja nun diese Woche auch noch raus. Und alles prima, wie Dennis ja auch schon meinte, gibt's da auch ein Firmware-Update, also der Mac Pro kann jetzt quasi auch da von seinem neuen Fallsystem auch booten und das hat irgendwie alles funktioniert.
Ja, also du hast SSD mit APFS auf der Boot-Palatte. Gut, ja bei mir ist ja eigentlich dann immer nur der einzige Hemmungsgrund bei meinem Mac Pro, dass ich sicher sein will, dass mein ganzes Audiozeug funktioniert. Aber ich habe ja jetzt mit meinem USB-C Mac Pro habe ich ja schon einmal erfolgreich von USB-C auf Thunderbolt 2 und von Thunderbolt 2 auf Firewire 800 adaptiert und dann mit einem Firewire 800 in das Firewire 400 von dem Interface adaptiert. Und siehe da, die Latenz war, weiß nicht, ein, zwei Millisekunden langsamer als sonst, aber es funktioniert total los. Das heißt, ich werde dann wahrscheinlich morgen mal das Interface an das MacBook anschließen und wenn da alles jetzt mit High Sierra flutscht und die Plugins und alles laufen, dann werde ich es auf dem Mac auch mal, auf dem Mac Pro auch gleich mal installieren.
Ja, es ist halt ein Update, was jetzt nicht......Apis bricht. Genau, nicht viel bricht. Also zumindest sieht es danach aus. Wie immer, wenn man ein neues OS installiert, fühlt es sich danach erst mal schneller an.
Nicht bei dem iOS.
Nee, aber so beim Mac werden ja erst mal so gnadenlos wahrscheinlich alle Caches weggelöscht, die irgendwie das Ding ausbremsen. Danach dickt es dann wieder an. Aber so aus meiner Perspektive kann ich eigentlich beide Updates freigeben. Also sowohl iOS 11 als auch High Sierra macht einen ganz guten Eindruck und bin gespannt, was wir dann noch alles so sehen werden. Gerade beim Mac Pro steht ja jetzt quasi die Frage aus, kann man jetzt auch noch diese modernen Flashkarten jetzt reinwerfen? Also diese haben wir ja schon mal länger diskutiert. Diese NVMe-Dinger müssten jetzt eigentlich auch out of the box unterstützt werden und durch dieses EFI-Update könnte es halt sein, dass man vielleicht sogar davon bootet und falls irgendjemand das ausprobiert hat und weiß, ich will das wissen, weil das will ich nicht. Dann bin ich ja noch mal so richtig speed reinkriegen in meinem Mac Pro, denn, habt ihr diese Benchmarks gesehen von diesen neuen iPhones?
Das wurde davon berichtet, dass die schneller sind als das kleine 12er.
Was hast du da? Du hast einen 15 Zoll Mac Pro.
Ja, rechts unten.
Hast du mal Geekbench gestartet? Weißt du, was es ist? Start mal.
Da muss ich runterladen.
Genau, musst du mal runterladen, Geekbench 4. Ich würde mich mal interessieren, was deine Kiste da so macht. Weil mein Mac Pro hier, der jetzt mit irgendwie Doppel-It-Wix-Eon-Schnick-Schnack fast das Schnellste, was man kriegen kann. Ich habe ja sozusagen so die zweitschnellste Büchse. Und dann kriegst du den halt irgendwie so auf so ein Geekbench-Score von 3000. Und Multicore wiederum sieht dann aber ganz gut aus. Da ist irgendwie viel. Hab ich jetzt gerade vergessen, was das ist.
Aber du hast ja auch immer noch nicht die schnelle Grafikkarte, ne?
Ich hab, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was du mit die schnelle Grafikkarte meinst.
Ich hab nicht die uralte Grafikkarte drin.
Ich hab irgendwo so eine Radeon, 280 oder so was, vergiss das immer, wie das Ding heißt. Und im Rahmen dieser ganzen Geschichte jetzt mit external GPU steht ja auch zu hoffen, dass eben auch so die allerneueste Generation von Grafikkarten, die jetzt auf den Markt geworfen wird im Mac Pro, funktionieren wird, weil halt die Treiber dabei sind.
Ich darf das Geekbench im Demo, also im...
Ja, ja, sagst du einfach later.
Und ich mach jetzt einfach CPU-Benchmark?
Genau, einfach den CPU-Benchmark mal los.
Hoffentlich macht der hier mit ohne Stromadapter auch volle Leistung.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Wie lange dauert das so?
Minute oder so, anderthalb vielleicht.
Na dann starten wir gleich noch mal mit richtig Strom.
Ich denke nicht, dass der Unterschied dann so groß sein dürfte.
Na ja, also wenn dann...
Wenn schon dann richtig.
Warte, Moment, Moment.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was die Karre so hergibt. Also ein Performance so rauszuholen ist.
So alles andere hier zumachen.
Naja.
Ja, also und iPhone schnell.
Das iPhone mit diesem A11, also ich rede jetzt sowohl vom iPhone 8 als auch von dem X, was jetzt so ja noch keiner gebenchmarkt hat, aber wo ja im Prinzip derselbe Prozessor drin ist. Also dieser A11 ist ja ein Prozessor mit sechs Cores, wobei zwei quasi auf High-Speed getrimmt sind und vier sind auf Low-Energy getrimmt. Das heißt, sie sind nicht so schnell, aber verbrauchen halt extra wenig Strom und die anderen sind halt schnell und im Gegensatz zu dem Vorläufer, dem A10, kannst du die auch alle gleichzeitig verwenden, wo vorher so ein Entweder-Oder-Modus war. Und das Ding haben die so dermaßen getunet, dass der A11 bei Geekbench mit einem Score von 4000 rauskommt. Also das iPhone 8, 4000, mein Mac Pro mit 2, 3,6 Gigahertz Xeon-Duel hast du nicht gesehen, mit 12 Gigahertz, 3000.
Ich will eigentlich gar nicht wissen, was bei dem Benchmark jetzt bei mir rauskommt.
Aber, du hast welche Generation?
Oh warte, ich glaube das ist die 2013.
Aber der läuft schon oder?
Ja, der läuft schon.
Ja, die fahren da so eine Lepora von verschiedenen Algorithmen, die typisch sind für bestimmtes Processing. Was da genau drin ist, kann ich nicht so richtig sagen. Hier postet schon jemand ein MacBook Pro 15 Zoll, der kommt auf 4370. Das dürfte bei dir so ähnlich sein.
Also bei mir sind es dann doch immerhin 3790.
Du hast welches?
Ich hab das 15 Inch Retina Late 2013.
Also bei dem 15er haben sie ja eh immer schon das Maximale rausgeholt. 4370.
So in dem Dreh, ich glaub ein paar zerquetschte.
Ja, lässt es zehnmal laufen, kriegst immer wieder andere Ergebnisse.
So, aber iPhone.
Ich meine, das musst du dir mal geben, ja. Und Multicore, weiß nicht mehr so genau, war auch bei 18.000 oder so was. 13.000 glaube ich, so was in der Größenordnung. Also ein Stein, der da drin ist, in einem Telefon, der irgendwie auf Verbrauch so wenig Akku wie nur irgendwie möglich gemünzt ist und damit irgendwie aber auch einen Tag hält, powert irgendwie so ein Telefon und sie kommen halt jetzt in der Performance an die aktuellen Intel Steine für tragbare Computer ran. Das muss man sich echt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Also ich hab keine Ahnung davon, was bei Apple da in ihrer Hardware-Abteilung passiert, aber es ist vollkommen unwirklich. Vor allem in der Android-Welt, also die ganzen anderen Smartphones, die erzielen halt Benchmarks, die ungefähr bei 50 Prozent dieses Speeds liegen. Also der Unterschied ist nicht, ist ein bisschen schneller oder so, sondern die spielen gerade in so einer komplett anderen Liga. Stellt sich natürlich wieder die Frage.
Haben sie für Geekbench optimiert?
Wenn sie diesen Skandal aufgeklärt haben wollen, sollten sie die Freak Show-Partei wählen.
Oh man, naja, da frag ich mich halt so, wie lange will man jetzt eigentlich noch Intel in seinem Laptop drin haben? Vor allem mit dem Akku, den du in deinem Laptop hast, im Vergleich zu dem Akku, der in dem iPhone drin ist. Fährt deine Kisse ja mehrere Tage. Wie oft kannst du ein iPhone laden mit dem vollen Ladezustand deines MacBooks? Dreimal? Viermal?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich mache das ab und zu mal. Aber ich habe jetzt nicht mehrere Male hintereinander geguckt, bis meine Kisse alle ist. Aber da geht schon so einiges. Und vor allem, was kriegst du noch mal raus, wenn du auch kein Platzproblem mehr hast? Und nicht noch eine Myriade von Sensoren und so weiter noch mit rein müssen, sondern du im Prinzip so ein Real Estate hast, den du mal so ein großer Laptop bietet.
Ich frage mich nur, ob bei diesem Benchmark, das macht ja den Anschein, als würde er da ein bisschen mehr testen, als nur ein paar Zahlen zu addieren. Also von wegen Speed Recognition und Blur Filter applizieren und so weiter. Aber ist das wirklich wirklich vergleichbar? Also würde jetzt, ich meine gut so die meisten Applikationen, die fett sind, zum Beispiel Final Cut, wird ja auf jeden Fall von der GPU profitieren. Insofern ist das kein guter Vergleich, aber sagen wir mal so ein Reaper Rendering, was ja schon eher CPU ist. Wenn jetzt so dein, weiß nicht, sagen wir 16 Tracks irgendwie parallel rausrendern, ohne noch groß zu konvertieren, dann mach ich ja die CPU auf jeden Fall auch voll. Dann ist natürlich noch die Speicherbandbreite und deine, also sowohl RAM als auch Festspeicher, noch die Frage.
Klar, aber das sind natürlich auch alles lösbare Probleme, wo ich jetzt nicht sagen würde, da ist jetzt so, ja, Apple baut zwar verdammt schnelle CPUs, aber sie sind nicht in der Lage einen schnellen Datenbus zu bauen.
Ich meine, das Ding ist für mich, auch mein 2012er MacBook Pro, mein Mac Pro jetzt eigentlich ist das für alles schnell genug, außer wenn ich in Final Cut jetzt was rendere, zum Beispiel diesen kurzen Delfinschnipsel, da gibt's eigentlich vier Minuten von. Und ich hab das halt in 1080p aufgenommen mit 50 Frames die Sekunde, also es ist schon eine signifikante Datenmenge so und wenn man dann auch nur vier Minuten mal rausrendern will, denkt man sich so, das kann jetzt nicht so lange dauern, dann sitzt er da eine Dreifelstunde, bis da alle Frames rausgeputzelt sind und ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist ja dann auch viel GPU wahrscheinlich.
Ja und ich meine, auf dem iPhone kannst du jetzt über die 4K-Video machen und das irgendwie on-device mit filtern und hast nicht gesehen.
Aber abgesehen von dem Video ist, genau das wollte ich eigentlich sagen, sind alle meine Computer schnell genug für alles, was ich so tun will. Also es gibt, seit SSD da ist und genug RAM in die Kisten reinpasst, gibt es eigentlich kaum irgendwie im Moment, wo ich denke, oh, das dauert mir jetzt aber zu lange. Außer vielleicht Webviews, die schlecht gewrappt sind und mit JavaScript den ganzen RAM aufessen, aber auch andere. Genau, aber insofern so ein richtiges Geschwindigkeitsproblem habe ich sowieso nicht. Nur wenn ich bei dem Mac Pro sehe, was mein Hexakor und die Grafikkarte so an Strom fressen und dann noch langsamer sind als das Gerät, was, also das hier ist ja auch deutlich schneller als der Mac Pro und verbraucht ein Drittel vielleicht von dem Strom.
Der Mac Pro ist halt die Harley-Davidson. Rechner. Da muss man auch halt so dicke Lüfter.
Ja, da wird ordentlich Hub.
Da geht es ja auch ums Prinzip. Der Mac Pro ist solange der geilste Rechner bis Apple seinen Eck da wieder zusammen hat und mal ordentlich Computer baut, wo man auch Begehrlichkeiten entwickelt.
Und vor allen Dingen halt Dinge rein und raus stecken kann.
Genau.
Für das alte rein, raus stecken kann. Also das ist eigentlich so eher das Killer-Argument der Stromverbrauch, den sie haben für die Leistung, die sie haben. Also das finde ich dann fast so das Interessanteste daran. Und nicht unbedingt der Fakt, dass es schneller ist als mein Mac Pro, weil der ist schon ziemlich schnell. Aber den Mac Pro mit einem Drittel des Stromverbrauchs, das wär's.
Wann kriegen wir dann Arm Everywhere? Also ich kann mir nicht mehr vorstellen, dass Apple nicht voll darauf hinarbeitet, genau das zu machen.
Wird sich das nicht als erstes vor allem bei dem kleineren Macbook zeigen? Da haben sie doch auch einen der Prozessoren drin, die in einem iPhone drin sind, oder?
Also alle Macbooks sind Intel. Es gibt keinen Mac, den du derzeit kaufen kannst, der mit was anderem läuft als Intel.
Aber gab es schon mal irgendeinen Rumor, irgendeinen Screenshot, irgendwas, wo MacOS auf Arm schon mal lief?
Also Rumors gibt es, ob die substanziell waren, weiß ich nicht schon. Nur, da musst du jetzt nicht groß rumornen, selbstverständlich baut Apple MacOS auch auf Arm. Du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass sie jetzt irgendwie in der zehnten Generation ihre eigenen Prozessoren sind und nicht mal mit ihrem eigenen Betriebssystem benchmarken.
Aber da müsste es doch schon mal irgendwelche Spuren fangen gegeben haben. Das ist so wie zu sagen.
Die Rechner, die sind bestimmt in, damit wird nicht den ganzen Tag rumgesurft, sondern das ist einfach im Lab und da sind dann noch mal so 3 Meter Stahlwand und dann kommt erst die Außenwelt.
Meinst du auch, in den ganzen Libraries nirgendswo würde man da mal ein Anzeichen von sehen?
Na ja, ich meine, man...
In irgendwelchen Heller-Files oder keine Ahnung was?
Das betrifft ja Darwin und Darwin ist ja eh auf Arm. Das ist? Selbstverständlich, Darwin läuft ja auch auf iOS. Der Teil, der Prozessor-Abhängigkeiten überhaupt hat, der läuft ja jetzt schon auf Arm, deswegen siehst du das selbstverständlich. Genau derselbe Körner läuft ja auf iOS. So, und der mag etwas hier und da etwas anders sein, aber im Kern handelt es sich ja hier um dasselbe Betriebssystem. MacOS hat halt das Front-Facing, das ist halt anders. Du hast ein anderes GUI, du hast ein anderes Application-Framework etc. Von dem hast du dasselbe, von dem ist es ein bisschen anders. Und alles ist ein bisschen älter und nicht so modern wie auf iOS, weil es halt ein anderes User-Interface hat. Aber darunter, Darwin, ist ja the same. Und selbstverständlich läuft das. Und selbstverständlich werden die ein komplettes MacOS-Bild auf ihren Prozessoren machen, allein schon um zu sehen, wie schnell das kompilt. Das dann auch noch laufen zu lassen, ist ja noch die kleinste Übung. Bevor sie jetzt das natürlich in so ein MacBook reinschieben können, müssen sie natürlich noch ein paar andere Sachen tun. Wir brauchen zum Beispiel Thunderbolt. Das baut halt Intel derzeit. So. Aber halt nicht für ihre Steine. Das heißt, sie müssten halt eigentlich, da weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie das läuft, ob sie dann was lizenzieren können, was sie dann quasi in ihren Armstein reinbauen. Und ist das auch so ohne Weiteres auf die Architektur matchbar? Ja, im Prinzip muss es das ja sein, weil es gibt ja auch Arm-Server, die auch PCI haben. Also im Hosting-Bereich werden ja auch mittlerweile Arm-Server eingesetzt. Die werden ja auch PCI haben. Da werden auch Komponenten drüber angeschlossen. Das ist dann halt zwar nicht Thunderbolt, aber im Prinzip ist Thunderbolt ja auch nichts anderes, als PCI Express rausgeführt, etc. Plus irgendwelcher moderner Voodoo, den ich jetzt nicht näher beschreiben kann. Was ich damit sagen will, ist, ich glaube, wir können uns schon mal darauf einstellen, dass irgendwann Intel einfach mal raus ist.
Ja, es sei denn, da gibt es so bilaterale Vertragswerke.
Unterwerfungsunterzeichnungen.
Na ja, oder so, was weiß ich, was die da so aushandeln, auch mit ihrem ganzen Thunderbolt, USB-C-Geraffel und so. Und dass dann so, hier die eine Hand, da die andere Hand. Das ist schon, ne?
Eine Hand, andere Hand, ich hab eher das Gefühl, Apple ist schon dabei, irgendwie in der Plattkolle irgendwie durch die Halle zu ziehen.
Und die können gut sein, wenn sie nicht irgendwie das nächste große Unternehmen sind, was sie irgendwie platt machen.
Da haben sie ja auch große Traditionen drin. Ich kann mich immer noch sehr lebhaft an die Power-PC-Zeiten erinnern, wo es auch irgendwie die ganze Zeit darum ging, Leute, schneller, gibt uns mehr Gigahertz. Und sie kamen nicht, dass sie dann abgesprungen sind.
Irgendeiner hat gepostet, als High Sierra rauskam, dass das das 28. Release von Apple, das 28. Major-OS-Release von Apple ist auf dem Mac. Und dass sie seitdem sechs Prozessor-Plattformen auf sechs Prozessor-Plattformen unterstützt haben. Das ist quasi die Genese. Seit 1984, also seit 33 Jahren. Alter Schwede, ist das lange her. Da hab ich so gedacht, sechs Prozessor-Plattformen, krieg ich die eigentlich alle zusammen? Kriegst du sie zusammen?
Stimmt nicht, ich bin nicht alt genug.
Ich auch nicht.
Naja, ich meine, womit fingst du denn an? Keine Ahnung, das weiß ich zum Beispiel nicht. Der erste Mac?
Keine Ahnung.
68K.
Ja, genau, aber war das nicht die ganze Zeit, bis PowerPC kam? Okay, dann hätte ich jetzt einfach nur gedacht, dass der erste vielleicht was anderes hatte, oder so, keine Ahnung.
Das war alles 68. Also die Apple II war halt noch 6502 Prozessorzeit, so 8-Bit halt, und dann der Mac war halt 16-Bit, 68.000. Dann PowerPC.
Und dann unterscheidet man noch so die Generation oder was?
Na ja, 32-Bit. Und dann gab es ja nochmal den PowerMac G5 für kurze Zeit, und das war ja dann der erste 64-Bit PowerPC, das ist sozusagen die dritte Plattform. Und jetzt komm ich ein bisschen ins Schleudern. Dann kommt Intel 32-Bit, Intel 64-Bit. Jetzt sind wir aber bei 5, was hab ich gesagt? 6? Dann war es vielleicht nur 5?
Nein, jetzt vielleicht ARM.
Ich würd grad sagen, wenn jetzt ARM noch dazukommt.
Ja, den Mac, es bezog sich explizit auf den Mac.
Vielleicht ist das das Anzeichen gewesen.
68.000 ist ja 16-Bit. 68.030, 32-Bit. Also 68K, 16-Bit, 32-Bit. PowerPC und dann halt dasselbe jetzt nochmal damit. Und das 7. wäre dann sozusagen ARM. Wobei sie da halt 32-Bit wahrscheinlich irgendwie rauslassen. Aber wenn man es halt genau nimmt, geht es auch noch mit so. Und ich glaub, das wird uns noch eine Weile so begleiten. Also ich freu mich schon auf meinen neuen ARM. Mein neues ARM MacBook ohne Touchbar. Das kauf ich dann auch.
Ja, also diese Touchbar, nach jetzt was weiß ich, einem halben Jahr, das größte Unfeature aller Zeiten an dem Mac.
Da wird auch niemand furchtbar, ne?
Und auch es kommen jetzt immer noch weiter so Application-Updates, so jetzt mit Touchbar-Support. Und ich hab's jetzt ein, zwei Mal angeschaltet, mir so anguckt, okay, was bringt ihr an den Tisch so, ne? Das ist einfach Quatsch, ja. Also ich hab wirklich nach wie vor wieder also diese Control-Keys halt an. Und das ist dann noch vergleichsweise sinnvoll, aber ich hab mir auch den Lock-Key da rechts oben hingelegt, weil es ja keine Escape, also keine Eject-Taste mehr gibt für Command-Shift-Eject, Control-Shift-Eject, Control-Shift-Eject, um den Screen schnell zu locken. Aber weil es so touch ist, man kommt halt... Ja, ich bin auch kurz davor, wieder auf die aktiven Ecken zu wechseln, weil so oft, wie ich auf dieser Taste ausfasse, also es ist ja keine Taste, das ist ja das Problem, so oft, wie ich da drüber getouched habe, einfach nur zum Beispiel so Staub mal kurz wegwischen, alles so bling, bling, bling, bling, screen lock, ist das Letzte, was dann passiert.
Also ich merk auch, ich nutze die so gar nicht. Ich hab mich letztens darüber gefreut, dass Sublime Text jetzt die Integration hat, dass man zwischen den offenen Files hin und her wechseln kann. Also das war wirklich das Sinnvollste, was ich bisher je gefunden habe. Auf der Touchbar, das ist irgendwie ja ganz nett.
Aber die Tabs wechselst du doch eh mit einem Shortcut und dann...
Ja nee, ich bin eher sogar noch so, dass ich ständig Command Tab drücke. Eigentlich würde ich das eigentlich... Ich muss mir mal den Shortcut endlich merken für zwischen den Tabs wechseln, weil ich immer auf Command Tab rumhänge. Aber was ich viel nerviger finde, ist, dass ich einfach mit meinen 100 Tastaturen nicht mehr klarkomme. Also diese blöde Tastatur auf dem Mac Pro ist halt so viel anders als die auf meinem anderen Mac Pro. Ja, meine ich doch. Und dann auch auf dieser richtigen Apple Tastatur. Das ist ja auch eher so wie das MacBook Pro von 2013 und ich weiß nicht wie viele Jahre danach.
Diese Cursor-Tasten.
Oh ja, diese Cursor-Tasten sind ein Traum. Wie häufig ist schon wieder denn?
Shortcut Alert, Shortcut Alert. Der Chat meldet.
Shortcut Alert, Shortcut Alert.
Es gibt Ctrl-Command-Q. Bei euch macht das nichts?
Instant Screen Lock.
Seit wann gibt's denn das? Aber du bist noch nicht auf High Sierra.
Doch.
Ich bin nicht auf High Sierra. Das Ding hat noch nicht mal... Ich hab noch El Capitan.
Bei dir geht's auch?
Nee, bei mir geht's nicht.
Du bist noch auf El Capitan?
Das ist aber auch der 13.12.2013. Na ja, ich weiß gar nicht, warum.
So sieht das gerade aus.
Ich hab das aus Faulheit erst nie installiert, weil ich Angst hatte, dass wieder irgendeins meiner Programme, ähm, hops geht, dich zu...
Kompatibilitätsangst.
Seit High Sierra, okay.
Ja, für meine Entwicklung. Und seitdem ich auf dem Rechner nicht mehr entwickle, vergess ich das halt auch, dass ich den updaten muss.
Ctrl-Command-Q. Wie geil! 28 Jahre. Nee, 33 Jahre, 28 Releases. Und jetzt kann man endlich mit einer Taste sich aus...
Na ja, vorher war es ja auch...
Nee, es ging nur über Screensaver und den du dann so...
Eject, also Ctrl-Shift-Eject ging ja auch die ganze Zeit.
Nee, aber es war doch was anderes.
Es war doch...
Es hat auch was anderes...
Screen...
Es hat den Screensaver gemacht, den du dann...
Also es macht den Screen schwarz und du musst tippen, damit du deinen Login... Wenn du einen Screensaver anhast, dann kann sein...
Ja, aber der muss dann so konfiguriert sein, dass der, wenn er angeht, dann auch automatisch nach einem Passwort fragt, richtig?
Das musstest du in den Security-Settings generell einstellen.
Ja, aber das scheint ja hier davon inkoppelt zu sein. Das ist ja einfach dieses...
Hast du das nicht eingestellt, dass du nach dem Locken das Passwort sofort sehen willst?
Naja, aber nur, weil das... Nur, damit man dann diesen Effekt hat, aber...
Aber du hast es fest eingestellt. Ich weiß gerade nicht, was ich eingestellt habe. Immer in Security, General, weil wenn es gerade auf Immediately steht, dann müsstest du das jetzt mal ausschalten, um dann zu gucken, ob dein Control-Command-Q immer noch Immediately lockt.
Control-Shift-Eject im Sinne von Power-Taste auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist, ja.
Doch. Power-Taste macht Screensaver an.
Jetzt hast du neu gestartet.
Nein, aber der hat erst den Bildschirm schwarz. Es verhält sich anders als Control-Command-Q. Control-Command-Q macht sofort das, was ich will.
Okay, das ist also... Ach ja, doch.
Und Control-Shift-Ding-Zi macht dunkel, macht Screensaver an. Das heißt, der aktiviert den Screensaver.
Na, aber bei mir wird es jetzt auch schwarz, wenn ich nichts eintippe. Es verhält sich anders, aber im Prinzip gab es vorher schon Screen-Log-Command. Das ging dann nicht mehr.
Mich hat das aber genervt, weil ich wollte halt nicht... So ein Screensaver ist ja manchmal auch ganz sinnvoll und man will nicht unbedingt immer...
Ich hab keinen Screensaver an, bei mir wird es einfach schwarz. Schwarz-braun ist die Haar-Synos. Schwarz-braun bin ich auch nicht.
Warte mal, wo ist überhaupt hier Bildschirm-Schoner? Oder was meint es?
Security und dann bei General. Also allgemein, wahrscheinlich wenn man auf Deutsch fährt.
Passwort erforderlich? Ah ja, genau. Dann sag ich jetzt mal fünf Minuten. So, Control, Shift, Plumsi. Genau, das aktiviert nämlich nur den Screensaver. Control, Command, Q lockt den Screen.
Also du kriegst jetzt auch sofort die Passwortabfrage, obwohl du es auf fünf Minuten gestellt hast.
Nein, also bei Control, Command, Q kriege ich sofort Passwort. Und bei Control, Shift, Eject kriege ich Screensaver. Aber nur Passwort, wenn ich es mache. Jetzt kann ich halt Screensaver und kann ein bisschen wackeln und dann so, nee, ich will doch sehen. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Ein neues Feature, jetzt möchte ich das nur noch, dass ich das irgendwie auf F12 locken kann, eine Gene, kann sowas mit so viele Tasten.
Und ich kann endlich meinen populärsten Blogpost, den ich jemals verfasst habe, updaten, den ich am 2. Juni 2011 geschrieben habe. Mac OS X Keyboard Shortcut for Locking the Screen. Und jetzt werde ich ein kleines Update fahren und die Leute sagen, wie es unter High Sierra geht. Ja, geil, endlich mal wieder einen Blog einloggen und was Blogmäßiges tun. Ich muss ja echt sagen, wo du das vorhin so meintest mit dem Blog, ich vermisse tatsächlich so ein bisschen die Blog-Zeit. Weil irgendwie war das so eine Zeit lang so in meinem RSS-Reader, war so der gefühlte halbe CCC irgendwie drin. Und jeder hat mal so ab und zu was gebloggt, was gerade so bei denen passiert. Und es waren auch durchaus öfter mal etwas ausführlichere Abhandlungen. Und jetzt ist es halt immer nur noch so ein paar Zeilen Facebook oder noch weniger Zeilen Twitter und das war's. Also nicht mal Tumblr oder irgendwas passiert mehr. Und das war schon irgendwie eine ganz coole Zeit, wo jeder irgendwie so in diesem Modus war, ach ich tippe jetzt da mal was rein und ja, fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich hab Blog ja immer nur, also ich hab übers Nähen gebloggt früher, aber irgendwann, mir war das halt echt, also beim Nähen brauchst du halt echt so viel Effort. Du nähst die Scheiße irgendwie stundenlang, dann musst du davon halt noch nach deiner stundenlangen Plackerei noch gute Bilder machen, wobei es natürlich bei schwarzen Kalamotten vorstellen kann, echt nicht so leicht ist. Und dann war ich halt irgendwann so, oh nee, das braucht mehr Zeit als nähen, das ist so viel Zeit, was mir flöten geht.
Ich habe heute, nee gestern habe ich eine Mail oder quasi in den Kommentaren gesehen, dass da jemand was gepostet hat von meinem Blog und ich habe ja auch so vorhin meinen Selbstbauprojekten im Gitarrenbereich so ein paar Anleitungen gemacht. Und genau, da hat letztens einer auch so einen Jahre alten Blogpost gefunden, wo es darum ging so ein Gitarrenverstärker- Lautsprecher-Ding zu bauen und meinte, ja, super geil, ich habe mir auch eins gebaut, hier sind die Bilder und nochmal vielen Dank für die ganzen Infos. Und da dachte ich auch gerade wieder, genau so ist das geil, dass dann irgendjemand sucht nach den richtigen Worten, landet bei dir auf dem Blog und findet halt Inspiration bis zur Problemlösung. Und das ist ja...
Das ist gerade der Punkt, warum ich dann überlegen bin, sowas wieder anzufangen. Einfach so ein... Also ich, früher habe ich halt wirklich eher Nähen, ja, übers Nähen oder Stricken geblockt oder was ich halt gemacht habe. Und das ist mir zu langweilig, um einfach nur zu zeigen, was ich mache. Also dafür habe ich mittlerweile Instagram, auch wenn ich es vergesse, dass ich es eigentlich habe. Aber mir ist halt aufgefallen, ich bin gerade dabei, wegen Taschen, Schnittmuster und so weiter zu machen. Also zum einen fürs Rennrad, für den Rahmen will ich mir halt eigentlich noch was Passendes bauen, sodass halt die Trinkflaschen etc. noch Platz haben. Weil da gibt es echt Optimierungsbedarf. Und das ist halt eine Sache. Und die andere Sache ist, ich habe vor einem Jahr oder so einen Prototyp gebaut für einen mehr oder weniger ultraleichten Rucksack, den ich aber so umfunktionieren will, dass er komplett gut tragbar ist. Und nicht nur ultraleicht um jeden Willen, weil das muss ich halt auch komfortabel tragen. Und da habe ich halt auch gemerkt, dass es gibt so ein paar Seiten, wo du vielleicht Infos findest, aber generell halt nicht so viel. Da dachte ich mir halt auch so, ja, okay, dann kannst du das halt schon mal dokumentieren. Oder halt genauso, da habe ich auch schon mal gesagt, dass ich halt schaue, dass ich möglichst Stoffe finde, die sich super machen zum Reisen. Dass du irgendwie ein kleines Packmaß hast, die jetzt nicht unbedingt sofort stinken, wenn du sie einmal anhast. Am besten irgendwie draußen hinhängen kannst. Und da recherchiere ich halt jetzt mittlerweile auch schon. Und das sind so Dinge, ich glaube, da haben halt auch andere ein ähnliches Problem. Also das ist der Grund, warum ich wieder anfangen würde zu bloggen. Und bin auch echt am Überlegen, ob ich mir ein WordPress auf meiner Seite baue wieder.
Macht das. Ich, also genau diese halbe Recherche, halb mein Lösungsansatz, das Ding ist ja auch ganz oft, wenn man so Sachen findet, es löst ja oft nicht genau das Problem, was man hat, sondern man findet so eine Vielzahl von verschiedenen Lösungen, die in etwa was mit dem eigenen Problem zu tun haben. Und man macht so seine eigene Compilation daraus. Und dann wiederum die eigene Recherche, Ergebnisse sozusagen noch mal zu dokumentieren, hilft dann dem nächsten wiederum noch ein bisschen weiter vielleicht. Und gerade zum Beispiel bei diesem Gitarrenlautsprecherbau oder auch im gesamten Audiobereich, da gibt es halt ja auch so viel… Schrott? Na ja, so Esoterik einfach, muss man einfach so sagen. Und das war auch wirklich relativ schwierig, rauszufinden, wie kann man denn so einen Gitarrenlautsprecher bauen, dass der sinnvoll klingt? Und hab dann auch so ein bisschen Information zusammengetragen. Zum einen für mich, falls ich das irgendwann noch mal wieder tun will. Weil man vergisst ja auch Sachen. Und dann, ja, jetzt kommen da ab und zu immer mal Leute vorbei und sagen, geil, hab ich auch gerade gemacht, super.
Also ich mein, ich dokumentiere halt schon irgendwie so die Klamotten, die ich nähe und stricke und versuche halt auch sowas, wirklich so Dinge, die mir halt irgendwie auffallen. Das ist jetzt aber mehr oder weniger auf meinen Körper spezialisiert, weil irgendwie nicht jeder dieselben Maße hat. Dass du dir sowas irgendwie aufschreibst und aber halt auch gleichzeitig zu den Klamotten, dass ich irgendwie manchmal einen Monat, ein Jahr später reingehe und dann gucke irgendwie so, ah, hab ich die Klamotte noch? Wie sieht der Stoff aus? Und würde ich diesen Stoff und diesen Schnitt nochmal machen? Sodass ich halt auch so ein bisschen so eine Wissensbasis einfach nur für mich habe. Also das würde ich jetzt halt wahrscheinlich eher ungern online stellen. Also bis auf den Stoffteil vielleicht. Aber ja, das ist halt schon echt praktisch, so was zu haben, wenn man das nochmal machen will.
Jaja, mehr bloggen.
Ja, mehr bloggen. Also ich hab auch schon... Gut, dass du das ansprichst. Ich versuche auch schon seit längerem meine Blogreflexe wieder zu stellen. Insbesondere weil mir einfach diese ganze Facebook-Isierung einfach total stinkt. Also ich hab irgendwie... Ich kann ja sehr gut nachvollziehen, warum die Leute das benutzen. Weil im Prinzip ist es ja auch das Scheitern des sonstigen Internets gewesen. Weil wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, wie kacke heute immer noch Mail ist. Spam und keine Verschlüsselung. Also einfach auf so vielen Ebenen. Fehlermelden und irgendwie indeterministisches Verhalten. Grundsätzlich schwierig irgendwie. Einfach ist einfach immer noch viel zu schlecht zu erreichen.
Einfach ist immer noch viel zu schwierig.
Genau, einfach ist immer noch viel zu schwierig. Oder Instant Messaging oder so. Da sieht man ja genauso, wie sich so eine Parallelwelt entwickelt hat. Und überhaupt gar kein Wunder, dass Messenger quasi die sinnvollste oder effizienteste, ob es immer so sinnvoll ist, ist eine andere Frage, aber die effizienteste Methode ist, Gruppen zu vernetzen. Kleine Gruppe aufmachen. Wir haben es nie so richtig geplant. Am Ende tauschen wir uns hier über diese Sendung am effizientesten dann doch irgendwie über diese kleine iMessage-Gruppe aus. Weil, geht schnell, direkt, klar.
Auf allen Geräten.
Und irgendwann schreibst du halt keine Mails mehr.
Und auch diese Messenger, zum Beispiel Streamer, auch WhatsApp in Grenzen, obwohl man das ja im Browser auf dem Desktop auch benutzen kann. Aber das Phone muss irgendwie in der Nähe oder gerade auch irgendwie WhatsApp aktiv sein. Und das hab ich alles mit iMessage nicht.
iMessage ist da super. Aber Facebook ist natürlich für die Leute so die Heimat. Und ich erinnere noch an irgendwie so Umfragen. Gerade in Asien so, ja, benutzen Sie das Internet? So nein, benutze Facebook.
Und das äh, genau.
Ändert aber nichts an der Tatsache, dass dieses Facebook ein Problem bleibt. Und das wird auch irgendwie nicht besser. Gerade wenn man sich jetzt hier diesen Klimbim anschaut, der sich jetzt rund um den amerikanischen Wahlkampf im letzten Jahr da entfacht. Und wo jetzt irgendwie Facebook so langsam mal mit der Sprache rausrückt, dass sie da halt irgendwie ihre Netze von irgendwelchen Russen-Bots da am Start haben, die halt konsequent einfach diese Plattform ausgenutzt haben, um die Leute da irgendwie auszutricksen. Auch wenn ich das jetzt nicht als das Primärproblem mache, aber gerade diese Kontrolle, die im Laden darüber hat. Und mag ja sein, dass der Zuckerberg irgendwie tief in seinem Herzen ist, vielleicht sogar ein guter Mensch. Ich hab da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, aber so richtig wissen tue ich es auch nicht. Ich unterstelle mir jetzt einfach mal, dass er nur das alles in Kauf nimmt. Der hat da ein Business-Modell, das basiert eben darauf, irgendwie die Aktivitäten in dieser Plattform möglichst gut überwachen zu können, um dann eben Werbung zu verkaufen. Weil da kommt das Geld her. Facebook verdient das Geld mit Werbung. Ist halt einfach so. Und es ist ja auch klar, dass diese ganze Plattform im Wesentlichen davon lebt. Und es gibt genug wissenschaftliche Studien und Erkenntnisse der letzten Jahre, die halt klar macht, wenn deine Kommunikation da halt läuft, dann bist du quasi nackt im Internet. Also da weiß man alles über dich. Haben wir ja alles schon gehabt mit irgendwie der Vater, das war ja nicht aus Facebook heraus, also dieses ganze Beobachten von Verhalten, von Kaufverhalten irgendwie so auf einmal kriegt der Vater irgendwie eine Mail von so einem Shopping-Laden, der irgendwie klar anzeigt, dass seine Tochter irgendwie schwanger ist, auf Basis dessen, was sie sich halt anguckt und so, weil auf einmal waren dann, was weiß ich, Windeln oder was halt Schwangere so essen, auf einmal für Verlangen erzeugen oder für was sie sich generell interessieren. Also all diese ganzen Daten kann man halt aus diesem beobachteten Verhalten problemlos herauslesen. Um jetzt mal wieder auf den Punkt zurückzukommen, mit Versus-Blogs. Ich habe ja auch gerne gebloggt am Anfang, finde Bloggen an sich halt auch immer noch eine sehr wertvolle Geschichte. Und da dieses, du schreibst, du kannst halt kurz sein, du kannst halt auch lang sein und vor allem du hast so einen fucking Permalink. Dieser Grundeinkommenbeitrag, den ich da vorhin rausgeholt habe, das beste Beispiel, habe ich jetzt vor acht Jahren geschrieben, ist immer noch unter derselben Adresse zu erreichen. Und der wird dann sozusagen, solange ich noch Herr über meine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur bin, ja und vielleicht, wenn auch irgendjemand so gnädig ist, das dann nach meinem Ableben dann irgendwann mal auch weiter zu finanzieren, ist dann so die Bedingung für mein Erbe.
Ihr kriegt die Kohle, aber nur...
Aber Freeways, die Updates müsst ihr einspielen.
Die Permalinks.
Und die Let's Encrypt, die Pegasa. Alle drei Monate müssen die erneuert werden.
Die Metaebene muss auch in 500 Jahren noch gehört werden können. Das ist das Einzige, da möchte ich den Tim Prittler-Funt haben, der irgendwie für 500 Jahre die Erreichbarkeit sicherstellt.
Vielleicht kannst du das mit einem Web-Archiv regeln.
Ich möchte auf jeden Fall nicht irgendwie mit oder der selben URL abgerufen werden können. Ja, bitte. Und ich möchte mindestens einen oder zwei thermonukleare Kriege überleben.
Wie war das? Good URLs never change?
Genau.
Da bin ich ja auch großer Freund von.
Ja und vor allem bei Facebook, abgesehen erstmal davon, dass der Content sozusagen nicht von außen verlinkbar ist, so ohne weiteres, ja, und dann Logins erfordert, etc. Vor allem dann kommt dann halt irgendein ja, wir sehen das jetzt mal anders nochmal und dann ist der Content einfach weg. Und diese Flüchtigkeit der Information, das nimmt uns halt einfach dieses Informationserbe. Die alte Blogosphäre, die sich so in den letzten zehn Jahren entwickelt hat, die ist immer noch viel reichhaltiger und viel fertiger, auch wenn natürlich auch viel weggefallen ist und Links gestorben sind und Server down sind, Leute gestorben sind, etc. Klar, das ist ein Problem, aber Archive Org kann sich da eigentlich sehr gut bedienen und das muss halt irgendwie wieder werden.
Aber ich finde halt auch, dass Facebook und so weiter gar nicht mal die Blogs in irgendeiner Form auch nur ansatzweise ersetzt haben, weil der Content, der jetzt auf Facebook oder Twitter ist, ist ja auch ein komplett anderer. Wie zum Beispiel halt so, also niemand schreibt in längere Abhandlungen in Facebook von sowas wie Grundeinkommen, also niemand.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt nicht so halten lässt.
Die gleichen Leute, die ich vorher im RSS hatte, wenn ich die jetzt auf Facebook beobachte, kann ich das definitiv so sagen.
Ja, die gleichen Leute, aber andere Leute sind halt dann nur noch...
Ich habe noch nie, noch nie, nie, nie irgendwas vergleichsweise sinnvolles auf Facebook in irgendwie Abhandlungslänge gelesen. Kann sein, dass ich jetzt da total ignorant unterwegs bin. Ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr viel mehr auf Facebook unterwegs als du, habe ich den Eindruck. Und auch länger. Und da ist schon für mich zumindest ein qualitativer Unterschied festzustellen. Und aber eben genau das, was du dann eben auch noch sagst mit hier Ownership, die du dann auch im Zweifel abgibst mit den Terms of Services. Ja, ist alles irgendwie eigentlich ungeil, aber ja, vielleicht schaffen wir es ja. Wir machen jetzt hier Mission, weiterer Programmpunkt auf dem Parteiprogramm der Freak Show Partei, die Partei, die Blogosphäre supporten und wieder neu starten. Den Logosmos, wie ich ihn liebevoll nenne. Oder Blogosmos.
Der Parmalink muss für immer stehen und Geltung haben.
Meinst du, wir sollten eine Digitale Agenda für die Blogosphäre erstellen? Tim Cook nicht so begeistert.
Was nicht?
Digitale Agenda.
Doch, denn die müssen eine Digitale Agenda für die Blogosphäre bereitstellen. Ich frage mich, was das jetzt für eine Agenda ist. Solange gucke ich auch gern skeptisch. Die Wähler interessieren sich sowieso nicht für die Details. Hauptsache raushauen.
Das bedingungslose Blog-Einkommen.
Wir haben noch ein bisschen Tim, da geht noch was.
Wir kommen langsam schon in den kritischen Bereich.
So schlimm war es jetzt nicht. Wollen wir noch mal anfangen?
Ich glaube, ich habe ein Déjà-vu.
Nein.
Aber jetzt, wo wir so viel vom Segeln gesprochen haben, können wir ja nochmal über Audio-Bearbeitung reden. Ja, die Jungs von Reaper und Mädels vielleicht auch haben wieder so ein neues Zwischen-Release, also kein Major-Major-Release, aber es war so ein Miner-Release, wie man so schon sagt, was aber durchaus wieder einige Verbesserungen mit sich brachte. Und ich habe diesmal so ein bisschen wieder intensiver dann durch die Reaper.
Dann können wir noch mal kurz sagen, was es ist.
Das ist das Programm, mit dem diese Sendung gerade aufgeblieben wird. Genau, von dem ich Tim lange versucht habe zu überzeugen und was dann geklappt hat als diese Ultraschall-Version der Mod.
Als Ralf das Windows rausgebürstet hat, da war ich dann auch dafür zu haben, obwohl ich auch immer noch haderer war.
Ja, ich weiß schon, aber es gibt keine richtige Alternative.
Auf jeden Fall eine bemerkenswert solide Foundation, da merkt man, dass das Programmierer Erfahrung mit ins Spiel gebracht haben. Ich habe selten so eine stabile und schnelle performante Software gesehen. Ich kenne ein paar Programme, für die es auch gilt und da ist auch der Hintergrund immer der, da sind dann Leute, die wissen, was sie tun.
Ganz genau. Und für die, die immer noch nicht wissen, was das ist, ist eine Digital Audio Workstation. Also ein Programm zur Audiobearbeitung, Aufnahme, Mischung, Komposition. Genau. Und die hatten jetzt im, also die hatten sowieso schon, wie sagt man auf Deutsch, zu Spektralanalyse für Audio, wäre das Spectrum. Das heißt, man kann sich nicht nur die Waveforms von den Tracks anzeigen lassen, sondern auch das Frequenzspektrum, was halt für Audiobearbeitung durchaus sinnvoll ist, wenn man zum Beispiel Störgeräusche finden will oder auch die Frequenzverteilung bei Musik, beim Mixen irgendwie harmonisch haben will und dann kann man relativ schnell sehen, ob etwas sehr Bass-lastig oder sehr Höhen-lastig ist und so weiter.
Oder ob man so Netzproben drin hat.
Genau. Und was sie jetzt aber hinzugefügt haben, ist eine wirklich abgefahrene Art und Weise, nicht nur das anzugucken, sondern auch damit Audio zu bearbeiten.
Jetzt sollte man kurz beschreiben, wie das aussieht. Also wenn man so ein Spektral-View macht von seinem Audio, normalerweise hat man ja immer die Lautstärke, die Amplitude, die da sozusagen sichtbar ist. Die Spektral-Analyse bricht das halt jetzt in sein Frequenz-Spektrum auf und dann sieht das so ein bisschen aus wie so eine Heatmap. Das heißt, ist irgendwo im tiefen Frequenz-Bereich viel Energie, dann ist es da unten hell. Ist in einem hohen Frequenz-Bereich viel Energie, ist es oben hell. Und so kann man dann halt schnell sehen, wo dominieren welche Frequenz-Anteile, wenn also irgendwo viel hohe Töne sind, dann ist es so im oberen Bereich des Plots hell und ist irgendwo alles sehr basslastig oder eben entsprechend auch mittenlastig etc. You name it. Und so auf so eine Heatmap des Audios blickt man drauf und man schaut eigentlich sehr viel mehr so richtig in die Organe des Sounds rein.
Absolut. Ja und dann haben sie so ein Video, was ich hier auch mal gleich in den Chat poste für die Show Notes gepostet, wo sie jetzt eben das Editieren in diesem Spektrum vorführen. Und das ist halt wirklich, also hab ich noch nie gesehen, der guckt sich dann so das Spektrum von so einem Track an und stellt dann, ich glaube er wollte ein S-Laut irgendwie.
Genau, das ist das erste Beispiel, so ein scharfes S und Zischlaute, die ihr jetzt nicht hört, weil das hier in meiner Kette alles eliminiert wird. Aber so ein lautes Zischen.
Genau und das will er rauseditieren, geht dann in den Spektral-View, sieht also diese Stelle, wo das S besonders zischelt und macht dann so eine rechteckige Auswahl in dem Spektrum um das Ding und hat dann an dieser Stelle, in diesem Spektrum, in dieser Zeiteinheit irgendwie die Möglichkeiten, einen Kompressor, ein Gate oder einfach nur die Lautstärke von diesem Frequenzanteil runterzuregeln.
Und das auch noch vorne und hinten und oben und unten noch reinzufäden.
Ja, und das ist wirklich, das war schon mal ein ganz, ganz neues Level. Ich meine, bei Reaper gibt es auch zum Beispiel so einen Noise-Filter-Feature, was ich lange Zeit irgendwie überhaupt nicht auf dem Radar hatte, wo du sozusagen dein Grundrauschen irgendwie aufnehmen kannst und das dann von allem anderen wieder abziehen kannst oder auch so bestimmte Frequenzen kannst du sozusagen rausfiltern und das dann automatisch woanders abziehen und so. Das Ding an Reaper ist wirklich, einerseits wirkt es erst mal auf Anhieb so ein bisschen simpel, weil vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig viele Plugins mitgeliefert werden wie bei einem Logic oder einem Pro Tools oder ähnlichem. Aber die Sachen, die dabei sind, sind teilweise wirklich überraschend mächtig und es ist auch hier und da so einiges noch versteckt. Also das mit dem Spektrogramm wäre das jetzt nicht in den Release Notes gestanden. Ich hätte da auch wahrscheinlich nie danach gesucht, muss man dazu sagen. Ich wäre niemals auf die Idee gekommen, dass sowas überhaupt geht. Aber die moderne Technik macht das möglich.
Ja, das ist vor allem geil auch für... Also man dieses Zischlaut, das ist so typisches Musik, Vocal, Nachbearbeitungs-Ding, wenn man jetzt wirklich im Music Recording dabei ist. Aber das haben wir auch für Podcasts, wo man jetzt nicht jedem S hinterhergeht, weil irgendwo ist es ja auch Quatsch. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so einen Netzbrummen drin hat, so einen 50-Hertz-Brummen, dann würde man das mehr oder weniger als konstante Linie da sehen und wahrscheinlich kannst du dann...
Aber sowas kannst du mit dem anderen Noise-Filter würdest du das auch wahrscheinlich sehr gut rausfiltern können. Kann ich dir mal später nochmal zeigen.
Ja, sicherlich, aber das so visuell zu machen und einfach auch ein ganz klares Gefühl dafür zu haben, was man da jetzt eigentlich gerade tut. Das ist schon geil und es gibt ja auch noch komplexere Probleme, die man damit gegebenenfalls erschlagen kann.
Also für mich ist es zum Beispiel auch oft beim Schlagzeug aufnehmen, da gibt es halt so oft Sounds, die man doch nicht haben will oder Frequenzen, die irgendwie so komisch nachresonieren und hallen, die man dann damit wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut und präzise, viel besser als mit einem Equalizer halt rausbekommt. Weil mit einem Equalizer würde man dann immer diese Frequenz suchen und dann die so ganz scharf ganz rausnehmen. Aber immer auch noch andere dazu. Und hier hat man wirklich so chirurgische Präzisionen gefühlt. Ja, guckt euch mal das Video an, auch wenn ihr vielleicht nur so am Rande Audio interessiert seid, aber das ist wirklich super, super cool.
Das erinnert halt total an Bildbearbeitung dann, durch diese Rädchen, die man hat, um was reinzustellen. Und das geht halt weg von dem eigentlichen Signal. Also so ein bisschen hat man nicht mehr das Gefühl, mit einem Signal zu arbeiten. Sondern eher ein Bild. Also nur wenn ich da drauf gucke, es sieht halt wirklich aus wie Photoshop für Audio. Genau, Photoshop für Audio.
Und das geile wirklich an Reaper ist ja dann eben noch, du kriegst dann so eine Features und es kostet halt irgendwie 60 Dollar für Jahre. Also ich habe das gekauft vor bestimmt drei, vier Jahren und es gab immer noch nicht den Cycle jetzt mal wieder neue Münzen ein. Und das finde ich auch sehr bemerkenswert. Also wie letztens musste ich erst wieder für Little Snitch was einwerfen und Transmit und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Und dieses Tool macht wirklich so viel mehr.
Das ist echt krass. Offenbar haben die immer noch eine ganze Menge Zuwachs, ne? Letty staunt.
Ja, Letty staunt, weil vorher gab es einen Rechteck auf dem Bildschirm und der hat halt mal einfach einen, wie heißt das Ding? Nee, ist ja eher wie so ein Fahrtwerk. Und hat halt einfach mal genau einen beliebigen Ausschnitt halt auch nicht was an den Rechteck gebunden ist, sondern wirklich so ins Detail geht, nach oben und unten.
Also das ist schon echt spannend.
Ich find's auch richtig geil.
Geile Scheiße ist das einfach. Nichts anderes. Also man sieht, also Reaper, das finde ich irgendwie gut, die sind... Ich verstehe nicht, warum die das mit dieser bekloppten Optik nicht hinkriegen. Ich meine, was kann es kosten, da mal... Da zahl ich dann auch gern nochmal das Release. Hier Reaper 6 jetzt auch in hübsch.
Schreibt mir nochmal.
So, dann nehmt ihr einfach nochmal die volle Kohle irgendwie oder, keine Ahnung, macht einfach so 5 Euro irgendwas, eure Base zahlt einfach. Und alles ist gut. Aber die scheinen da wohl auch ganz gut von zu leben oder zumindest ausreichen.
Vielleicht haben sie ja auch kein Screen-Design.
Ja, die haben einfach ewig auf Windows entwickelt und it shows.
Also das ist...
Ich verstehe das nicht. Ich glaube, ich werde das nie verstehen. Tut mir auch leid für Leute, die jetzt irgendwie zuhören und die sich jetzt die Haare rauf... warum ich da irgendwie nicht mit klarkomme. Aber ich glaube, da kriegt man einfach die Mac-Leute und die Windows-Leute kriegt man da einfach nicht zusammen. Für uns ist das einfach die Ästhetik. Sorry, das geht einfach überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde das relativ einfach zu erklären, wenn du dir die Apple User Interface Guidelines und Design Guidelines halt zur Brust nimmst und irgendwie mit Xcode oder so deine App designs und die Dialoge dann kannst du es nicht komplett verkacken. Ist einfach unmöglich, weil die Guides lesen sich schon ziemlich straight forward und machen Sinn und dann hast du ja auch noch diese ganzen Interface-Builder, Guides und Snap-To und hast nicht gesehen. Also diese Dialoge, die Reaper im Stande ist zu produzieren, wo du wirklich denkst, wo bin ich hier, wie bin ich überhaupt hergekommen und wie komme ich zurück. Wenn man so direkt auf dem Mac sozusagen in dem Umfeld anfängt, glaube ich, würde das nie passieren.
Ja gut, aber am Ende ist das glaube ich eine kulturelle Sache, weil wenn du mit dem Mac, also wenn du andere Programme, das Arbeiten mit dem Mac gewohnt bist, dann schmerzt dich sowas einfach.
Klar, das ist natürlich auch so ein selbst verstärkter Effekt, weil wenn du dann auf dem Mac andere Programme benutzt und die sehen so aus und du weißt schon, wie das auszusehen hat. Aber würde mich auch mal interessieren, also ich würde zum Beispiel den Typen, also es gibt ja so ein Interview-Video mit dem Typen, der früher Winamp gemacht hat und jetzt da hauptverantwortlich reapert, aber die Qualität von dem ist so super in so einem super halligen Raum.
Natürlich, klar, warum sollte das Interview auf einmal mit gutem Klang da herkommen? Aber es zählt doch nur, was er sagt. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Es war halt auch ein Windows-User, der das Interview tat.
Aber ich wollte ja gerade sagen, das fände ich mal interessant, wenn du dir den sozusagen zum Interview mal schnappen würdest und mal beleuchtest, was da so...
Die würde ich ganz gerne mal, wenn die mal den Fuß auf Deutschland setzen, dann würde ich die da gerne mal einsperren irgendwie mit Ralf zusammen und dann geben wir ihnen mal irgendwie die Podcast-Reise.
Vielleicht auch noch einen Designer dazu, damit das mit dem optischen...
Aber kommt der aus Usa oder wo kommt der her?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt da ursprünglich her ist, aber meines Wissens arbeitet das Team in Usa.
Also das ist der erste. Es gibt von denen... Interview. Genau, da gibt es auch mehrere Parts. Die sind auch in der Sidebar dann zu sehen. What's new in Version 5? Ich glaube, in dem Interview kann man schon mal so ein bisschen reinhören, wie der so tickt und ist auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich entspannter Typ.
Wieso läuft das Video gleich los hier, wenn ich das anklicke?
Was ist denn hier los? Hab ich dir einen AutoPlay-Link geschickt oder was?
Ah, ich hab noch AutoPlay allowed hier. Das ist ein tolles neues Safari-Feature, ganz groß. Dass man jetzt pro Webseite einstellen kann, ob man AutoPlay haben will oder nicht. Nichts hat mich mehr genervt, gerade auf diesem Produktionsrechner, wenn ich so einen YouTube-Link aufmache, dass die Dinge dann immer gleich roh und los rennen. Und wenn ich halt hier auf dem Mischpult den Kanal ausgeschaltet habe, brüllt es einem gleich rein.
Oh, aber guck mal, das erste Bild von dem Video, was hat er da auf dem Schirm?
Mac.
Ist das sein Raum?
Aber ich glaube, das war schon von dem Justin, der Raum.
Welcher ist das, der linkser oder der rechte?
Rechts, rechts ist der Reaper-Mann.
Ah, sieht ja gar nicht aus wie so ein Windows-Promio.
Naja, sieht aus wie der Typ von der Apple-Werbung, I'm a Mac. Und der links sieht ziemlich nach I'm a PC aus.
Dummer Ausredner, aber ja.
Ja, wir wollten das nicht böse gemeint.
Aber das hör ich mir tatsächlich mal an, das ist wirklich, sieht interessant aus. Haben die das jetzt in so tausend kleine? Jetzt hat er schon wieder automatisch gestartet, die Wichse.
Musst du vielleicht youtube.com mit Sternchen oder so? Nicht, dass er jetzt wirklich immer nur genau dieses eine Video, diese eine URL nimmt. Aber eigentlich steht der Website.
Anderes Thema. Also Reaper, vielgut und immer wieder interessant.
Möchtest du über Sport und Uhren reden?
Ah, genau, die Apple Watch, die haben wir ja ganz übersprungen. Oh, da ist mir eben ein geiles neues Killer-Feature im Chat noch dagereicht worden, das ich noch gar nicht kannte. Ihr seid ja uhrenlos, ne? Es gibt jetzt eine Taschenlampen-Funktion auf der Apple Watch. Wie geil ist denn das bitte? Und es ist sehr Apple-style-ig. Also es gibt ja hier auch so ein Kontrollcenter, was man so von unten nach oben so hochzieht, nur dass da ganz andere Sachen drin sind als jetzt auf dem iPhone. Du siehst da Batterielade-Zustand, kannst auch einen Airplane-Modus einschalten. Du hast diese großartige Wo ist mein Telefon-Funktion, dass du halt dein Telefon suchen kannst mit der Uhr. Mittlerweile geht es ja auch in die andere Richtung. Haben wir dann auch verstanden, dass das mal erforderlich ist. Also ich kann auch meine Uhr, weil manchmal, keine Ahnung, gehst duschen, nimmst die Uhr ab oder was weiß ich, legst sie halt irgendwo hin und weißt nicht mehr, wo sie ist im Sofa. Und dann kannst du halt auch jetzt klingen lassen. Naja, dann gibt es eine Taschenlampen-Funktion. Wenn du da draufklickst, wird der Bildschirm weiß. Du kannst aber auch so nach rechts durchswipen, dann kriegst du erst mal blinkendes weiß oder halt rot. Und wenn du eine Weile wartest oder drauf tippst, dann wird es irgendwie auch hell. Auf jeden Fall wird es hell, wenn du deinen Arm umdrehst. Das heißt, du gehst quasi rein, einmal swipe von unten nach oben, Taschenlampe auswählen, drehst deinen Arm um und deine ganze Uhr leuchtet so hell, sie kann. Du hast immer eine Taschenlampe sozusagen, also nicht, dass das Ding jetzt ein... Genau, ein Klolicht. Sehr schön.
Oder im Zelt reicht es auch noch.
Ja, Flur, was weiß ich, Dunkel, tralala. Irgendwie mal nur kurz irgendwo gucken, Port, Kabel, wo muss es denn rein? Du brauchst nicht unbedingt immer die volle Power von so einem iPhone-Flashlight. Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Irgendwann wird es so wie in Star Trek mit diesen Taschennamen, die sie auch am Handgelenk hatten und so.
Genau.
Die Diskussion hatten wir schon.
Es gibt auch noch ein anderes kleines Detail. Für Apps mit Audio haben sie jetzt die Funktion. Das muss ich noch eine Weile testen. Aber es ist schon mal ganz cool, wenn ich jetzt meine Podcast-App starte, also ich benutze Pocketcast und ich starte die halt und sage hier, den Podcast will ich jetzt hören. Nachher werde ich mir mal diesen 99 Invisible mit dem Grundeinkommen mal anhören, zum Beispiel. Und dann startet auch automatisch das Interface dafür auf meiner Watch. Sodass, wenn ich so loslaufe und dann so dieses Telefon in der Tasche und Werbung. Weißt du, brauch ich jetzt nur Arm hoch, 30 Sekunden, 30 Sekunden, 30 Sekunden, Tap, Tap, Tap und geht weiter. Das ist mit meiner Uhr noch so ein bisschen slow, aber ich glaube, das ist genau das, wo jetzt die neue Uhr punkten kann, weil es soll ja alles deutlich snappier geworden sein. Ich bin ja immer noch so bei der allerersten Modell. Ja, das sind so diese kleinen Feinheiten, die diese Uhr-Expans so von Jahr zu Jahr immer interessanter werden lassen.
Naja, ich hatte ja auch gleich am Anfang gesagt, solange das nicht selber Internet hat, ist es nicht interessant. Das ist ja jetzt zumindest schon mal ein Ansetzen da.
Genau, ein Ansetzen ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil, da haben wir letztes Mal ja schon drüber gesprochen, das Ding hat ja jetzt diese Variante mit LTE, bzw. genau genommen ist es 3G und LTE. Ob GSM auch noch dabei ist, unklar, steht nicht auf der Webseite, wird sich irgendwie sicherlich noch klären lassen. Und diese Funktionalität LTE erfordert natürlich eine SIM, nicht unbedingt eine SIM-Karte, aber halt diese Identität, die quasi dort gespeichert wird. Das Ganze ist natürlich nur so ein virtuelles Ding, also quasi so eine VM auf dem Prozessor oder so ähnlich wie diese Secure Enclave, wo halt TouchID und FaceID drin gespeichert wird, damit das da halt irgendwie läuft. Und da läuft dann quasi dieselbe Software, die sonst auf dem Chip läuft, den du da reinschiebst, läuft da quasi virtuell. Jetzt ist es so, dass das Angebot in Deutschland so ist, dass es nur mit der Telekom läuft.
Bisher.
Und die Prozedur ist ja noch nicht so ganz klar, aber soweit ich das gehört habe, läuft das wohl so. Wenn du sagst, hier, ich hab Apple Watch, ich brauch aber jetzt keine SIM-Karte zum reinschieben, sondern ich brauch eine eSIM, eine Embedded SIM, dann bekommst du, also was ich gehöre, ist ein bisschen Hörensagen, aber klingt für mich irgendwie plausibel. Du kriegst quasi so ein Aktivierungscode von der Telekom, den du dann irgendwie eintippen musst in irgendeiner Prozedur, womit du quasi diese eSIM aktivierst. Und ich vermute mal, dass der Code dann mehr oder weniger von dem Telefon da reingespielt wird oder so, weil so komplett over the air könnte es natürlich auch sein. Weiß ich ja noch nicht. Also zumindest sozusagen die Initialisierung ist mir noch so ein bisschen so ein Rätsel. Und wenn das dann aber abgeschlossen ist, hat man ja quasi eine Multisim in seiner Uhr. Also hast halt deine SIM in deinem Telefon und quasi noch mal so der selbe Subscriber in der Uhr. Bloß eben nicht als Chip, sondern irgendwie virtuell drin. Und im Prinzip verhält sich das auch wie eine Multisim. Nur, dass ja dieses wo klingelt ist, ist jetzt eine sehr dynamische Angelegenheit. Normalerweise, wenn ich jetzt zwei Geräte habe mit Multisim, dann muss ich ja damit das Zweitgerät klingelt, quasi auf die Webseite gehen und sagen, ich will, dass das auch klingelt oder dass das klingelt, wenn der andere aus ist oder so. Das ist quasi so eine statische...
Ich hätte noch nie zwei Geräte, die telefonieren können, weil ich sonst immer nur iPad und iPhone oder...
Genau, aber wenn du ein zweites Telefon hast, wo auch das selbe Spiel mit SMS, wo gehen die hin? Sollen die dann da hingehen, wenn das andere aus ist? Und wenn das anders ist, dann aber nur da und nicht das andere?
So, und bei sowas wie Facetime oder iMessage, dann kommt es halt einfach auf allen an.
Genau, weil es ja nicht im Netz entschieden wird. Aber wir reden ja jetzt hier von einem Verhalten des Netzwerks, in dem Fall halt des Telekom-Netzwerks. Und was neu ist jetzt mit der Uhr und dem Telefon, ist ja, in dem Moment, wo die sich voneinander entfernen, also du verlässt quasi mit der Uhr dein Haus und lässt das Telefon liegen, dann sei es so, dass wenn ein Anruf kommt, dass dein Telefon nach wie vor klingelt, aber deine Uhr klingelt dann halt auch. Was sie ja genau genommen jetzt auch macht, nur dass sie ja deshalb klingelt, weil das Telefon klingelt und nicht weil sie selber angerufen wird. Also das geht ja mit jeder Watch, auch mit meiner. Nur wenn ich halt weg bin mit meiner alten Watch, dann klingelt da natürlich nichts mehr, weil ihr das Telefon nicht seht. Und bei der LTE-Watch ist es halt so, dieses Device, dieses im Netz registrierte zusätzliche Device auf dem selben Subscriber, bekommt dann den Anruf. Jetzt natürlich die Frage, warum? Also wer sagt, dass das jetzt zu passieren hat? Weil im Prinzip kann ja nur das Telefon oder die Uhr selber, oder die Telefon und Uhr können gegenseitig feststellen, dass sie sich nicht mehr sehen. Das weiß ja das Netz nicht. Die sind ja immer noch in derselben Zelle eingebucht, aber können einen Kilometer von anderem entfernt sein. Mit anderen Worten, es muss jetzt irgendeine Aktivierung geben, seitens entweder des Telefons oder sogar auch der Uhr selber, dass die Uhr sagt, ab jetzt möchte ich gerne auch Anrufe bekommen.
Im Prinzip ist die Uhr ja immer an dir dran. Insofern hat sie ja, wenn sie das Telefon nicht mehr sieht, aber immer noch weiß, mit Sensoren, ich bin an den Menschen dran.
Richtig, genau, guter Punkt. Also sie muss sich ja quasi auch ausbuchen können, wenn sie nicht, genau, weil sie würde dann bestimmt nicht mehr klingeln, wenn man sie vom Arm abnimmt. Guter Punkt, genau, das könnte bedeuten, dass es die Uhr ist, die selber sagt, hallo, ich bin's, ab jetzt möchte ich gerne auch nochmal die Anrufe bekommen. Und das ist nun etwas, wo ich mir halt nicht so sicher bin, welchem Standard das jetzt genügt. Manche haben vermutet, ob es denn hier vielleicht irgendein Jahr über Internet, und dann wird Apple Bescheid gesagt, und Apple sagt der Telekom Bescheid, glaube ich nicht. Weil es ja heißt, dass im Ausland das Verhalten nicht repliziert werden kann. Und das scheint für mich danach zu riechen, dass die Uhr quasi derzeit direkt mit dem Provider reden muss. Während ich im Ausland bin, wenn ich jetzt nach Polen fahre, rede ich ja nicht mehr mit der Telekom. Sondern da geht ja nur noch Roaming und so weiter. Das heißt, ich müsste quasi durch den rohmenden Provider mit der Telekom reden, und ich glaube, diese Funktionalität ist generell im LTE-Netz so nicht vorgesehen, oder weiß ich zumindest nicht. Sprich, kann gut sein, dass es entweder hier einen Standardbestandteil gibt im eSIM, LTE, Ausbaustandard, den Apple erstmalig überhaupt verwendet, nämlich dieses Ich kann dynamisch sagen, ob ich Telefonanrufe erhalten möchte oder nicht. Dann ist das aber in irgendeiner Form nicht roaming-kompatibel, was meiner Meinung nach nicht dafür sprechen würde, dass es dem Standard entspricht, weil warum sollte man so ein Feature einbauen und dann funktioniert es nicht im roaming? Kann also sein, dass Apple hier irgendwas eingebaut hat, was nur mit supporteten Providern funktioniert. Das heißt, Apple geht zum Provider und sagt, du willst Apple Watch supporten und 10 Euro extra oder 5 Euro extra im Monat einnehmen, dann bitte hier mal dieses Bootstrapping und diese Autorisierungen und Initialisierungsprozedur machen und euren Support-Mitarbeitern erzählen, wie das funktioniert. Außerdem brauchen wir noch dieses Roaming-Feature, was ein bisschen so eine Sache ist wie diese Voice-Mail-Box. Wie haben sie das genannt? Visual Voice-Mail. Visual Voice-Mail, was ja im Prinzip auch total sinnvoll ist, aber am Anfang nie einer hatte und was man dann erstmal einbauen musste im Netz, damit diese Funktionalität da ist, dass halt dein Anrufbeantworter eben auch auf dem Telefon direkt abhörbar ist und du nicht damit irgendwie DTMF dich mit irgendeinem komischen blöden Teil rumschlagen musst. So, dann kam O2, weil oft die Frage hin, ob sie denn das jetzt auch unterstützen würden, meinte O2, naja, machen wir erstmal nicht, weil es unserer Auffassung nach, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, entspricht das nicht dem Standard. Weil die Spezifikationen würden ja bedeuten, dass quasi so jede SIM für jeden zugänglich ist. Das wird mir jetzt aus diesem Artikel, der auf Heise ist, nicht so hundertprozentig klar, was jetzt eigentlich das Problem ist. Aber in irgendeiner Form macht das auf mich so den Eindruck, als ob Apple hier vom Standard abweicht oder den irgendwie zukunftsorientiert interpretiert, weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Und O2 derzeit die Hände hebt und sagt, machen wir nicht, weil nicht standardisiert.
Naja, O2 ist ja auch nicht mehr O2, ist ja Telefonica und Telefonica ist ja generell nicht dafür bekannt, latest and greatest technology sofort zu deployen. Im Gegenteil, die haben ja nicht auch Alice und Hansenet und so am Ende gekauft und dann ihre ganzen D-Slams gegen Alte ausgetauscht oder Schlechtere. Weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall war es danach nicht mehr das Gleiche. LSDSL, LSDSL, einer der genialsten Namen aller Zeiten.
Auf jeden Fall meint Telefonica, die Spezifikation für eSIM, die in der GSM-Association definiert worden sei, würde hier aufgeweicht und es gäbe hier sozusagen eine Interpretation von Apple. Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das so ein Ding ist, wo Apple sich die Specs angeschaut hat und sich sagt, das habt ihr euch ja toll einfallen lassen, aber wir brauchen aber eigentlich das, weil so sehen wir quasi in Zukunft den Einsatz von mobilen Endgeräten. Und es ist uns scheißegal, was ihr da in euren Standard reingeschrieben habt. Kommt mal klar und baut das mal um. Setzt mal hier ein Bit um, baut hier noch mal eine API rein und dann läuft der Hase auch. Dann sind sie erstmal zu Telekom gerannt, die irgendwie ein modernes Netz haben und was zu verlieren haben. Und haben gesagt so, who's Apple Watch?
Mach mal.
Und jetzt kommt so Telefonica und dann so, oh Gott, das würde uns aber jetzt mal echt lange viel Geld kosten oder keine Ahnung. Also, ist vollkommen unklar. Ich will das jetzt auch nicht hier in irgendeine Richtung so schieben, dass ich der Meinung bin, Apple macht alles richtig. Kann auch sein, dass sie hier total auf Konfrontation fahren. Andererseits ist natürlich so eine flexible Handhabung von Routing über Over-the-Air ist ja auch total sinnvoll. Also, dass man irgendwie sich in eine Webseite einbucht und da klicken und abspeichern muss. Und bei O2 gehst du da rein, Multisim-Konfiguration, und dann sagst du ja die eine oder andere, ja, vielen Dank, du klickst auf Speichern, vielen Dank für Ihren Auftrag. Und ich so, was für ein Auftrag? Dann hab ich den scheiß Setting geändert. Und ja, es kann, bis du so und so viele Stunden dauern bist und sie werden dann auch benachrichtigt. Und dann kriegst du vielleicht so eine halbe Stunde später oder vielleicht auch mal zwei Stunden später so, ja, danke nochmal für Ihren Auftrag. Und wir haben jetzt so als müssten die gerade ein Paket verschicken oder so. Multisim wurde irgendwie beim Bäcker um die Ecke abgegeben. Und kann dort jetzt angerufen werden.
Multisim has no power here. Naja, wenn Apple da mal so Druck auf die Telekom machen würde, dass sie bei Glasfaser reinlegen.
Also es wird mal Zeit.
Läuft's.
Alles durchgerockt.
Letty hat auch schon so ein leicht...
Die Stimme will irgendwie heute nicht so gut.
Deine?
Ich war zufrieden mit deinem Ansatz.
Ja, aber jetzt hast du so ein leichtes...
Ein leichtes...
Du bist krank, wie alle anderen gerade.
Nein, ich war gerade krank. Ich möchte jetzt nicht noch mal.
Tja, weniger Teilnehmer in der Runde, höherer Redeanteil, das bringt das so mit sich.
Ich hab's akustisch gerade in der Tat nicht.
Weniger Teilnehmer in der Runde, gleich erhöhter Redeanteil pro Nase.
Da tut der Letty ja nicht schlecht.
Da muss man dann erstmal... Oder kannst du ja mal mit deiner Logopädin...
Ich hab so... Ich müsste für einen Podcast in meiner Stimme etwas arbeiten.
In der Tat hatte ich ja auch Probleme, als ich angefangen hab mit der Lehre am Anfang, dass mir das ganz schön auf die Stimme gegangen ist.
Ein Drama.
Aber das brauchen wir uns jetzt alles nicht weiter grämen. Denn die Freak Show ist vorbei. Die Nummer 205, habt ihr gehört, wählt. Alle Freak Show-Partei sendet auch weiterhin...
Modern und treibend.
Genau, alles toll. Vielleicht machen wir nächstes Mal nur eins. Sagt einfach vorher Bescheid und dann...
Wir sind da völlig flexibel.
Ich will noch einen Abschlusssong.
Was?
Einen Abschlusssong?